OKAY GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY WE'RE GOING
TO START THE- SAID TO HEARING
TODAY- TODAY'S OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION HEARING IN THIS IS A-
OPPORTUNITY HERE THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE POPOSALS FOR HIGHER
ED- CERTAINLY THERE'S A LOT. TO
TO LIKE HERE AS FAR AS
INVESTING IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION- SEGMENTS AND
REBOUNDING FROM. THE COVER
NINETEEN A PANDEMIC- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROVIDING- PROVIDING SUPPORT
45% ONGOING INCREASES. TO UC
AND CSU ON TOP OF WHAT WE HAD
THE JANUARY BUDGET AND THE
SUPER COLOR FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH YOU HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR FROM OUR COLLEGES
COMMITTEE COLLEGES THE PAST. A
FEW MONTHS BUT- WE STILL HAVE
SOME PRIORITY SOME PRIORITIES
THAT WE'RE HOPING TO WORK ON
BEFORE WE FINALIZE THE BUDGET-
FRANKLY RELATED TO ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY ALWAYS-
PRIORITIES OF THIS- OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WE DO HAVE A LARGE AMOUNT OF-
ONE TIME MONEY IN THE BUDGET SO
WE'RE THINKING OF WAYS TO. TO
BE A CREATIVE TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO- OFF CAMPUS CENTERS SO. TO
THE UC AND CSU FOLKS I KNOW YOU
ALWAYS HAVE A SHINY NEW SCIENCE
BUILDING YOU WANT US TO REHAB
BUT WE WANT TO. WE WANT YOU TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY AND- TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN. WORK ON
EXPANDING ACCESS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT. SOME OF OUR OUR TOP
CAMPUSES ARE IMPACTED AND WE
PROBABLY CAN'T BUILD NEW UC'S
AND SEE ISSUES BUT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GROW SOME OF.
OUR EXISTING CAMPUS BUT ALSO
SOME OF THESE OFF CAMPUS
CENTRES NOT FINALLY A PRIORITY
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
I. IS TO ADDRESS FINANCIAL AID.
AND ARE CALGRANT PROGRAMS- WE
KNOW THAT IS THE ENVY OF THE
NATION ARE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
BUT WE STILL LEAVE TOO MANY-
BEHIND- AS WELL AS DON'T
PROVIDE ENOUGH FINANCIAL AID TO
K. FOR TO COVER THE NON.
TUITION COSTS AND THIS IS NOT
JUST CAL GRANT BUT AS- A
COLLEAGUE THIS EDUCATION SHARE
STORDAHL NOTES TO- THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AS WELL TO
HELP. OUR MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
WHO ARE STRUGGLING SO THAT
THOSE ARE TWO OF THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS PRIORITIES THAT YOU'LL
SEE US ZERO IN ON IN ADDITION
TO WHAT'S IN THE- GOVERNOR'S ON
THE REVISED- WE DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC. TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY EITHER IN THE
ROOM FOR THROUGH- THE
TELEPHONE. PARTICIPATION WHICH
IS ON THE AGENDA AND I WERE ON
OUR WEBSITE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE NUMBER. I WILL READ IT
RIGHT HERE. AGAIN ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SO. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS CODE.
1-315-437-1315 FOUR THREE SEVEN
OKAY SO WITH THAT SO WE WILL
BEGIN WITH- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR- MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS. AND WE'LL
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. M. L. A. L. IN AND
FROM THE C. HOUSE BEFORE STARK
WE TAKE ROLE REAL QUICK MISTER
MARTIN. REYES HERE MCCARTY HERE.
BUT ALL. RIGHT ARE. FOR THE
DEVIL OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ARE THESE TWO
THINGS ARE YES THERE'S WITH B.
RIGHT MY COLLEAGUES WILL TRY TO
BE BRIEF THIS MORNING AT AND
THEN QUICKLY DETAIL WE HAVE A
LOT OF PROPOSALS AND WE KNOW WE
WANT TO GET TO THE QUESTION
ANSWER PORTIONS. SO FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR
PROPOSING A AT SIXTY NINE POINT
THREE MILLION ONGOING BASED
INCREASE THAT WOULD EFFECTIVELY
BE A 2% AUGMENTATION IN
ADDITION 23% PROPOSED IT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT'S ALSO
IN ADDITION TO THE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION. THAT THE EARLY
FEBRUARY EARLY ACTION
AGREEMENT- WOULD ADD TO RESTORE
THE TWENTY TWENTY- CALYXT SO.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS DO YOU SEE BUDGET.
THERE'S A FIFTY MILLION.
FEDERAL FUNDS FROM ARPA FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE. MILLION GENERAL FUND FROM
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS FORTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME. FOR UC DAVIS
PROGRAMS. FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME THE UCLA LABOR CENTER
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE LOSS AND
THEY WERE CENTERS FOR STILL
NEEDS RENOVATIONS. TEN POINT
TWO MILLION FOR USE NEAR SF
DYSLEXIA CENTER. FIVE MILLION
FOR THE UCLA ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES CENTER AND ONE MILLION
FOR THE BERKELEY ALTERNATIVE
MEATS LAW AB- THE OTHER BIG ONE
TIME. PROPOSAL IS- ONE BILLION
GENERAL FUND THAT SPLIT OVER
TWO YEARS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
BUDGET YEAR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AN INTERVIEW TO TWENTY
THREE THAT'S FOR A LEARNING
ALIGNED EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM.
THAT CREATES AN ENDOWMENT
ADMINISTERED BY THE UC AND THE
AND THE ANNUAL RETURNS WOULD BE
ALLOCATED BASED ON TOTAL
PROPORTION OF THE THREE
SEGMENTS. AND BASICALLY AT THE
C. C. C. C. S. U. N. USED
EIGHTY ODD STUDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE A STATE FUNDED WORK
STUDY A SUPPORT PROGRAM AND
THAT PROGRAM WOULD FOCUS ON
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED BACKGROUND.
LOW INCOME FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESS YOUTH. AND
SPECIFICALLY PRIORITIZE STEM
MAJORS THE IDEA IS THAT THE
STATE FUNDED VERSION OF FEDERAL
WORK STUDY ONE JUST PROVIDE AN
HOURLY WAGE WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
LONG TERM CAREER DEVELOPMENT BY
LINKING THE JOB TO YOUR YOUR
ACADEMIC PROGRAM. WELL THE LAST
THE PROPOSAL FOR YOU SEE IS TO
ELIMINATE THE USE YOUR PUPPY A.
N. R. AND YOU SEE PATH LINE
ITEM AND TO CONSOLIDATE THAT
BACK WITH THE MAIN. LINE ITEM
WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING TO WHO.
ARE PROVISIONS THAT WOULD
ENSURE TE TRANSPARENCY AND
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS THAT THE SEPARATE
LINE ITEM ALLOWED FOR- WE'RE
TRYING TO PRESERVE THAT WITH
THE PROPOSED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE- AND I AM HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU L. L.
CONSEJERO DELEGADO A GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE- BEFORE I
DIVE INTO THE UC ITEMS I JUST
WANTED TO TOUCH ON A THEME THAT
YOU'LL JURISTIC- NOTE
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING TODAY
AND THAT IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SUBMITTED A
LOT OF PROPOSALS TO
LEGISLATURES ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. BUT IN MANY
CASES THERE IS- IT'S PROVIDED
LITTLE INFORMATION ON THESE
PROPOSALS. AND EVEN MORE
INFORMATION EXISTS OF MUCH OF
THE INFORMATION IS PRELIMINARY
OR INCOMPLETE. I DON'T KNOW
MOSTLY THINK THERE ARE MANY
PROPOSALS WHERE- YOU COULD
START MAKING DECISIONS ARE
WEIGHING YOUR OPTIONS- WITHOUT
MUCH MORE INFORMATION. EITHER
BECAUSE THE PRO PROPOSALS HAVE
MERIT OR- THEY DON'T HAVE MUCH
MERIT YOU COULD CONSIDER
REJECTING THEM OR YOU COULD
CONSIDER SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT THEY RATES. THEN THERE ARE
THE PROPOSAL'S WHERE WE THINK
THAT YOU COULD BE REASONABLE
CONCEPT BUT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
GET MORE INFORMATION BEFORE YOU
MAKE YOUR FINAL BUDGET
DECISIONS. AND IF YOU LOOK
THROUGH THE UC PACKAGE WE THINK
THAT THEY'RE A MIX OF THOSE
EXACT KIND OF PROPOSALS-
INTERVIEW SHE ITEM HERE- FOR
THE SAKE OF TIME I'M GOING TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON FOUR KEY
ISSUES. I DON'T GO IN ORDER AS
YOU SEE THEM HERE ON THE AGENDA.
SORTING ON PAGE THREE OF THE
FIRST ISSUE I WANT TO TOUCH ON
IS BASE SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AGAIN AS
THE ADMINISTRATION NOTED THERE
ARE THEY ARE PROPOSING TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL 2% BASED
INCREASED YOU SEE LIKE IT'S
THEIR TOTAL BASE INCREASE TO
FIVE PERCENT. AND THAT'S ON TOP
OF RESTORATION FUNDS THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDED TO YOU SEE. I'M
UNDER THE FEBRUARY GREEN ONES.
OVERALL WE THINK IT'S
REASONABLE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE. ON SOME BASIS
ADDITIONAL BASE SUPPORT YOU SEE
ABOVE RESTORATION. YOU SEE
FACES COST PRESSURES EVER YOU
HEARD THIS YOU'RE CERTAINLY A
DIFFERENCE- IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
THE SUPPORT WE THINK A
REASONABLE STARTING POINT. A
COULD BE SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S- A LITTLE OVER
TWO PERCENT. WOULD COVER OF THE
SORT OF BASIC ESSENTIALS IT
WOULD COVER- PLATE THAT EFFECT
COST INCREASES. DEBT SERVICE
FOR EXAMPLE. ON THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CAN PROVIDE. FUNDING
ABOVE THAT- FOR EXAMPLE BY
ADOPTING THE PROPOSED 3% FROM
JANUARY OR 5% OF THE REVISION.
PROVIDING A LARGER BASE
INCREASE WITH ANOTHER YOU SEE
PRIORITIES FOR EXAMPLE EMPLOYEE
SALARY INCREASES- IT WOULD
ENHANCE STUDENT SERVICES. ABOUT
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD HAVE
FLEXIBILITY TO WEIGH THOSE
PRIORITIES SO IF THERE ARE ANY
PARTICULAR PRIORITIES THE
LEGISLATURE. I WANT TO ENSURE
YOU SEE SUPPORTING IT WE
RECOMMEND SPECIFYING THAT THE
BUDGET ACT. SURE WANT TO TOUCH
ON IS THAT SECOND ISSUE THAT'S
ON PAGE THREE WHICH IS LEARNING
ALIGNED STUDENT FINANCE. ARE WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF CONCERNS OF
THIS PROPOSAL- ONE CONCERN WE
HAVE IS WITH THE PROPOSED
FUNDING APPROACH. WHICH WERE
INVEST THE PROPOSED FUNDS- ANY
USING DOMINANCE. ANNADEL
MONTHS- INVEST FUNDS IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT ASSETS
INCLUDING EQUITIES. THAT MAKES
THEM SUBJECT TO MORE RISK AND
MORE VOLATILITY OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THE PROPOSAL
WOULD- FUNDED THESE NEW STUDENT
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. ARE
FROM THE ON GOING PROCEEDS FROM
THESE INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES.
AND AS SUCH MAY BE SUBJECT TO
SOME VOLATILITY. WE THINK THAT
WOULD MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
BOTH CAMPUSES AND STUDENTS THE
PLAN FOR THE UPCOMING YEAR. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO RAISES A NUMBER
OF OUR KEY QUESTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT THE ROLE WOULD BE
OF EMPLOYERS AND SUPPORTING
THESE OPPOSITION ROBERT
KENNEDY'S- ALONG WITH THE STATE.
BECAUSE THESE QUESTIONS ARE SO
FUNDAMENTAL IN THIS PROPOSALS
COMING- SO LATE IN THE PROCESS
WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL. SURE I WANTEDTO
TOUCH ON ARE THESE MANY OTHER
ONE TIME PROPOSALS THAT UC'S
STARTING ON PAGE THREE AND
CONTINUING ON THE PAGE FOR. ALL
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO FIND- MANY DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES ARE FOR EXAMPLE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. OUR
RESEARCH ON- NEW WAYS TO ENGAGE
AT FIRST DIDN'T HAVE MIGHT HAVE
THE SPECS YEAH. OUR RESEARCH ON
ALTERNATIVE NEEDS OUTRAGED
ANIMAL SHELTERS. THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE PRO- IN ALLOWS
STATE TO COVER MANY DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES. BUT ALSO SPREAD
RESOURCES THIN ACROSS ALL THE
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES AND
POTENTIALLY UNDERMINES THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS ANY OF THEM. I DON'T
ALTERNATIVE APPROACH
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER HERE
IS TO BE MORE STRATEGIC AND
FOCUS ON A FEW KEY PRIORITIES
PARTICULARLY PRIORITIES THAT
HAVE A CERTAIN- STATE BENEFITS.
OF FOR EXAMPLE AND YOU'VE
YOU'VE HEARD US MENTION THIS A
LOT SO I WON'T- WHAT KIND OF
THIS TOO MUCH BUT WE THINK
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS A
REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE OF A OF A
PRIORITY THAT PROVIDES CERTAIN
BENEFITS TO THE STATE. IT AND
COVERS PROJECTS THAT WITH
INCREASING COSTS IN FUTURE
YEARS HELPS ADDRESS A BUDGET
RESILIENCY FOR BOTH YOU SEE AND
THE STATE'S. AND IN THE FINAL
PROPOSAL I WANT TO TOUCH ON IS
OUR LOW SECOND THE LAST ONE
THERE ON PAGE FOUR WHICH IS FOR
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT LINE
ITEM. NOW YOU SEE- HISTORICALLY
HAS HAD THE ABILITY TO FIND THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT. ALL
BUT A FEW YEARS AGO THE STATE
CREATED A LINE ITEM
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE OFFICE OF
PRESIDENT WITH THE INTENTION OF
ENHANCING OVERSIGHT OVER THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
BUDGET AND ALSO- INSERTING MORE
CONTROL OVER ITS OPERATIONS.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
PROPOSING TO RETURN TO THAT
PREVIOUS SYSTEM AND GIVING YOU
SEE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES. WE ARE
CERTAIN ADVANTAGES TO
PRESERVING THE LINE ITEM OF FOR
WHEN WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
TARGET FUNDING DIFFERENTLY TO
CAMPUS IT WAS WORTH AS THE
OFFICE OF PRESIDENT. THERE ARE
SOME COST PRESSURES THAT ARE
SHARED BOTH BY THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT IN CAMPUSES FOR
EXAMPLE COMPENSATION INCREASES.
BUT THERE ALSO ARE SOME
DIFFERENT COST PRESSURES FOR
EXAMPLE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
STUDENT SERVICES THESE TEND TO
BE MORE CONCENTRATED ON THE
CAMPUSES. WE ALSO THINK IT ARE
PRESERVING THE LINE ITEM
ENHANCES TRANSPARENCY THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING.
ADDITIONAL REPORTING WE THINK
THAT RECORDING MAKES SENSE WE
RECOMMEND YOU ADOPT THE REPORTS.
FOR IT LINE ITEM OF PRESERVES
EVEN ADDITIONAL. AND THAT IT
CLARIFIES THE AMOUNT OF STATE
THAT'S GOING FOR THIS PARTIES.
SO WE DON'T RECKON AGAINST
ELIMINATING A LINE ITEM WOULD
YOU RECOMMEND ONE MODIFICATION
WHICH IS THAT IN THE LINE ITEM
THERE IS A CENTRAL
ADMINISTRATIVE PROGRAM LOOK FOR
JOBS YOU SEE CALF IT'S A
PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN HURT BY
THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE. EACH
PARTICULAR PROGRAM WE THINK
THAT IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
RETURN THE FUNDS OF THE
CAMPUSES AND HAVE A PROGRAM
SUPPORTED BY A ON ASSESSMENT A
CHARGE ON THE CAMPUSES. WE
THINK THAT WOULD LEND IT
STARTED GREATER EFFECTIVENESS
AND EFFICIENCY OF THE PROGRAM-
OF TIME ALL MY COMMENTS THERE
BUT I HAPPY TO ELABORATE ON
THESE ISSUES DURING THE- DAY.
OKAY THANK YOU THE UNIVERSITY
RESPONSE. YOUR PRESENTATION
WITH. GOOD MORNING CARE MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M SAY EVER TENANTS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I WON'T
COMMENT ON ALL OF THE ITEMS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
APPRECIATES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING A 5% BASED BUDGET
INCREASE THE UC OPERATING
BUDGET IN ADDITION TO THE FULL
BASED BUDGET RESTORATION THAT
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE CREATURE IN
FEBRUARY. YOU SEE CONTINUES TO
REQUEST HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING AND
THIRTY MILLION AND ONE TIME
OPERATIONAL INVESTMENTS IN
ADDITION TO THE MAY BE VICE.
ARE YOU SEE REGION'S REQUESTED
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION
TO SUSTAIN CAMPUS OPERATIONS
AND PROVIDE POLICY COVERED
STAFF AND FACULTY. A 3% SALARY
ADJUSTMENT. WE CONTINUE TO
REQUEST EIGHTY THREE MILLION IN
ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MEET THESE GOALS
FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. OUR
DESIRE TO PROVIDE A SALARY
ADJUSTMENTS ARE POLICY COVERED
STAFF IS DRIVEN BY WANTING
SALARIES TO KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION. UC CAMPUSES
CONTRIBUTE GREATLY TO THEIR
LOCAL ECONOMIES AND IS THE
THIRD LARGEST EMPLOYER IN THE
STATE IT IS IMPORTANT WE ENSURE
THE WELLBEING OF OUR EMPLOYEES.
YOU SEE COULD HAVE USED TO
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE TARGETED INVESTMENTS IN
OUR STUDENTS INCLUDING THIRTY
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING. TO
BEGIN CLOSING GRADUATION EQUITY
GAPS ALONG WITH MORE TIME TO
ACHIEVE THE RESULTS. THIS
INCREASES THROUGHPUT OF
STUDENTS AND A LOT OF STUDENT
ROLE LARGER INCOMING
UNDERGRADUATE COHORTS. AND
FORTY THREE MILLION AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN BONNER PULL
STUDENTS INCLUDING EXPANSION OF
THE SUCCESSFUL SAVE A PROGRAM
THAT PREPARES UNDERSERVED.
STUDENTS FOR UNIVERSITY
EDUCATION. FOR TIME ABOUT WE
REQUEST THIRTY MIL TO ADVANCE
REPATRIATION OF PROBABLE
REMAINS OUR STUDENTS MENTAL
HEALTH TELEHEALTH CAPABILITIES
AND ONGOING TRAINING. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL PROPOSED INVESTMENT OF
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TOWARDS UC'S DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY PROJECT.
IN ADDITION THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE YOU SEE HAS
BILLIONS AND SEISMIC RENOVATION
NEEDS AND BUILDING UPGRADES. WE
SUBMITTED A ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR LIST OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE GOVERNOR IF THE
COMMITTEE HAS AVAILABLE FUNDING
ALLOCATE TOWARDS THESE PURPOSES.
THE MAYOR REVISION DIRECTS YOU
SEE TO MEDICAL LEARNING ALIGNED
INDICTMENT FOR THE STATE. THE
PROPOSED OR POSSIBLE TO CREATE
A STATE FUNDED LEARNING ALIGNED
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM WOULD HELP
INCENTIVIZE MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR STUDENTS. THE FIRST PART OF
CREATING A DEBT FREE PATH IS
MORE FINANCIAL AID BUT THE
SECOND PART IS CREATING
MEANINGFUL MEANINGFUL WORK FOR
STUDENTS TO SATISFY THE WORK
STUDY COMPONENT OF ANY
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE. YOU SEE
HAS A PROCESS IN PLACE FOR
MANAGING AFFILIATED ENDOWMENTS.
BECAUSE ALL THE GOVERNMENT
EARNINGS ARE PAID OUT AT THE
END OF JUNE EACH YEAR THE FIRST
PAYMENT TO CAMPUSES WILL TAKE
PLACE IN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I DO WANT TO EXPRESS A
CAUTION THAT THE STOCK MARKET
CAN LOSE VALUE MEANING THAT
THEY INVESTED IN GOVERNMENT
PRINCIPLE AND DECREASE IN VALUE
TO THE DOCTORS OUTSIDE OF UC'S
CONTROL. DURING THE YEARS WHEN
THE INVESTMENT VALUE TO CLIENTS
THE PAYOUT THAT THE PROGRAM
WOULD ALSO DECLINE. AND FINALLY
BEGIN OVERSEE OF CALIFORNIA
APPRECIATES THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZING THE DIFFICULTIES
BALK UC OPERATIONS. AS A RESULT
OF USING A LINE ITEM
APPROPRIATION FOR THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS THE
CHANGING FUNDING METHODOLOGY
ONLY. IT DOES NOT RESULT IN
MORE FUNDING TO USE YOUR P. AT
THE EXTENSIVE BUDGET REFORMS
USE THE UNDER TALKED TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE BY THE STATE CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN WILL STAY
IN PLACE. THE PROPOSAL WILL
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
LACK OF FLEXIBILITY WITH THE
LINE ITEM CREATED FOR EXAMPLE
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
DIRECT LINE ITEM RESULTED IN
THE UC HOPE YOU BUDGET BEING
FLAT OR DECREASING SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. THIS LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY AND ABILITY TO
RESPOND QUICKLY WAS HIGHLIGHTED
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FOR
EXAMPLE BUT HOSPITALS OPERATING
IN CRISIS MODE THERE WAS NEED
FOR SYSTEM WIDE CHIEF CLINICAL
OFFICER RECORDED MEDICAL
RESPONSE TESTING AND
VACCINATION. IN ORDER TO HIRE
DISPOSITION YOU SEE WHAT WE HAD
TO TERMINATE OTHER EMPLOYEES
YOU'RE FREE UP THE FUNDS FOR
THE CRITICAL FUNCTION. THE SLOW%
DOWN HIRING BY MONTHS AND MEANT
THE LOSS OF EMPLOYEES CONDUCTED
OTHER WORK FOR THE SYSTEM. U.
ZERO P. COULD NOT USE FEDERAL
STIMULUSFUNDS FOR THIS
EMERGENCY BECAUSE AS A SEPARATE
LINE ITEM WE COULD NOT RECEIVE
THESE FUNDS FROM THE CAMPUS AS-
TRANSITIONING TO A NEW FUNDING
METHODOLOGY WILL ALLEVIATE
THESE PROBLEMS BUT THE LONG
LIST OF IMPLEMENTED REFORMS
WILL STAY IN PLACE. EXECUTIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE COMPOSED OF
CHANCELLORS VICE CHANCELLORS OF
FINANCE AND OTHER CAMPUS
LEADERS TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
THE PRESIDENT I USED TO BE
PROGRAMS EXPENDITURES. WILL
CONTINUE PROVIDING CAMPUS.
INPUT TO USE YOUR P. FINANCES.
THANK REPORT. THAT WILL STAND
IN YOUR OKAY RESERVE THAT MOST
OF AND DOC. YOU SEE OP RESERVES
ARE NOT REPORTED QUARTERLY TO
THE UC REGENTS ALONG WITH
BUDGET AMOUNTS TO ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES. THESE PUBLIC
QUARTERLY PRESENTATIONS WILL
CONTINUE UNCHANGED. YOU SEE
OKAY UNLIMITED AN ENTIRE NEW
BUDGET AND PLANNING SYSTEM.
ORACLE CROP CLOUD FINANCIAL
SYSTEM PROVIDES YOU SEE OP WITH
THE GENERAL LEDGER ALLOWS
TRACKING OF PLANNED BUDGETS AND
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES WITH FAR
GREATER EASE. USING THIS
ENHANCED TRACKING SYSTEM YOU
SEE OKAY NOW USES ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES AND FORECASTING.
PROVIDING GREATER ACCURACY
THESE REPORTS WILL STAY EVEN.
AS A DIFFERENT FUNDING
METHODOLOGIES ABOUT THAT. I
HELPFUL THAT WORK ON INCLUDED.
REVIEW EACH YOU SEE OKAY FUND
AND USE. THERE ALSO WAS AN
EXTENSIVE PROCESS TO DOCUMENT
EACH PROGRAM AN INITIATIVE AND
PROVIDE CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF
EACH. AMONG THE CHANGES FROM
THE LINE ITEM WAS THE
ELIMINATION OF UC OKAY
UNALLOCATED RESERVES. OVER
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX MILLION HAS
BEEN PROVIDED BY UC OAKLEY THE
CAMPUSES LEAVING USED TO HELP
YOU WITH THAT UNALLOCATED
RESERVE OF ZERO BY JUNE TWENTY
NINETEEN. THIS DID CAUSE
DIFFICULTIES IN RESPONDING TO
THE PANDEMIC WOULD USE YOUR P.
COULD NOT BE NIMBLE IN
RESPONDING TO THE APPALLING
CAMPUS NEEDS. THESE REFORMS
MEANS THAT YOU STILL BE BUDGET
TODAY IS NOT TO USE YOUR BE
BUDGET OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
TRANSPARENCY DOCUMENTATION AND
DECISION MAKING HAVE ALL
CHANGED THESE IMPORTANT CHANGES
WILL REMAIN EVEN AS THE FUNDING
MECHANISM CHANGES. I ASK THAT
YOU APPROVED THE CHANGE THAT.
YOU USE YOUR P. FUNDING
METHODOLOGY. AND IN CLOSING I
WANT TO SAY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED FOR TAR ONE
AND- YOU SEE AN I'M AVAIL. I
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU BUT
AND NOW WILL HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS. YOU START OFF FOR
MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
MEDINA. WELL I ALSO WANT TO
JOIN IN AND- EXPRESSING- MY
HAPPINESS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THIS YEAR AND HIGHER
EDUCATION AND UC- I WAS VERY-
GLAD TO SEE ALLOCATION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE LABOR
CENTER IN- LOS ANGELES IN
DOWNTOWN LA- IN CONJUNCTION
WITH UCLA. I THINK THE ROLE OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE COMMUNITY IS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE AND PART OF THAT
ROLE IS THE RESEARCH THAT IS
DONE BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN THAT LIGHT I
WANNA EXPRESS THAT I VERY MUCH
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO
THE UCLA LATINO POLICY AND
POLITICS INITIATIVE WHICH IS
NOT REFLECTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- LATINO POLICY AND
POLITICS INITIATIVE AND THE
WORK THAT THEY ARE DOING AT
UCLA IS IMPORTANT WORK. OF WORK
THAT IT IS- SUPPORTED AND DEEM-
IMPORTANT BY THE LATINO CAUCUS
I HAVEN'T OF IN FRONT OF ME A
LETTER SIGNED BY OUR CHAIR MY
DEAL AND IT WOULD ALSO AND THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
ROBERT RIVAS- THEY'VE THEY'VE
BEEN DOING. GREAT WORK AND- IT
IS A SENSE THAT THEY BE GIVEN
THE- THREE MILLION. TO TO
CONTINUE THE WORK THEY'RE
DOING. SO JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS THAT AND HOPE TO SEE
THAT IN THE IN THE FINAL BUT-
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA. SOME
ARRESTS THANK YOU MISTER DO
WANT TO JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM RIVERSIDE THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT- TOPIC AT THE UCLA
LATINO POLICY AND POLITICS
POLITICS INITIATIVE HAS
RECEIVED FUNDING IN THE PAST IT
WAS PROVIDED EXCELLENT- POLICY
REPORTS- IT IT IT WITH THAT THE
REQUEST NOW IS TO HAVE THIS
FUNDED ANNUALLY- THREE MILLION
DOLLAR- AMOUNT AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING TO REQUESTED ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS- THE POLICIES OF
THAT THAT THEY HAVE DEALT WITH-
ON CRITICAL ISSUES THAT AFFECT
THE LATINO COMMUNITY SUCH AS-
COVERED NINETEEN HEALTH.
EDUCATION VOTING RIGHTS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT LABOR AND
SO MUCH MORE SO I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN MAKING THAT
SPECIFIC REQUEST WHICH WAS
INCLUDED LAST TIME AND SHOULD
BE INCLUDED THIS TIME AND ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK. I WANT TO
FOCUS ON- SOME OTHER LARGER YOU
SEE ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO US SO WE HAVE SENSUALLY A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
MILLION I'M GOING HERE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
FOCUS ON UC'S PRIORITIES BUT-
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES
AS FAR AS ENROLLMENT GROWTH-
MAY SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD
BUT THAT'S THE ONE ISSUE WE
HEAR MOST WE GO BACK HOME TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. IS ACCESS TO
THE TO THE YOU SEE SO YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY- MISTER MEDINA WHAT
IS IT THREE MILLION FOR THE
REQUEST FOR LATINO CENTER
POTENTIALLY WE COULD TAKE OUT
OF THE EARMARKED FOR THE UC AND
FOCUSED ON OUR PRIORITIES AS
WELL AS ISSUES LIKE ENROLLMENT
GROW SO WHY WOULD WHY WOULD WE
AS A LEGISLATURE FULLY FIND
THIS- BLANK CHECK FOR A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE MILLION
WITHOUT HAVING ANY COMMITMENT
FOR EXPANDING ENROLLMENT AND
WHAT IS THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
TARGET THAT- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- IS. IS- IT IS
LOOKING TO- PROMOTES WITH THIS
INCREASE LET ME LET ME FIRST
ASK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS
QUESTION- BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
YOU SEE ANSWER ME VERY
UNSATISFACTORY- MISTER PARTNER
FINANCE- WHY. DO WE NOT HAVE A
ROMAN TARGET. WITH THE MONIES
THAT YOU PROPOSE IN THE IN THE
BUDGET. THE QUESTION SURE
MCCARTY. SO THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION DOES NOT SPECIFY
ENROLLMENT TARGETS AS YOU
MENTIONED FOR EITHER UC OR CSU.
WE RECOGNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT ROLE MEANT AT BOTH UC
AND CSU OUR PROPERTY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE'RE OPEN TO
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS. OKAY SO
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WITH
WITH YOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THREE PROPOSED MILLION DOLLAR-
ALLOCATION. WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR-
THOUGHTS FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH-
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS ARE
WE NEED THAT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TO PAY FOR OUR BASED COST
INCREASES ON OUR CAMPUS AS IT
WILL GO TOWARDS THINGS LIKE
COVERING A RETIREMENT. AND
HEALTH CARE COST INCREASES THAT
WILL GO TOWARDS. PARENTS IT'LL
GO TO PROVIDING SALARY
INCREASES ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
LOWEST PAID EMPLOYEES THAT'S
WHERE WE WOULD START- IT'LL GO
TOWARD BOND- FINANCING COST
INCREASES SO ARTIFACT FUNDING
WE DONT HAVE AVAILABLE FUNDING
TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT- WE ARE
ABLE TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT IF
YOU WERE TO PROVIDE US WITH.
FULL MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION FOR NEW STUDENTS WE
WOULD REQUEST- THE FULL
MARGINAL COST AND WE CAN ENROLL
MORE STUDENTS. THANK YOU. SO
THE- CAN YOU GO OVER THE THEIR
MARGINAL COST REQUEST AGAIN.
THAT CERTAINLY SO FOR EACH OF
STATE SUPPORTED STUDENT WE HAVE
AN ESTIMATED COST OF HOW MUCH
IT COSTS TO EDUCATE THAT
STUDENT- THE STUDENTS TUITION
AND FEES COVER A PORTION OF
THAT AND THEN WE REQUEST THE
STATE COVERED THE REMAINING
PORTION OF. THOSE FUNDS ARE
USED TO HIRE FACULTY AND OF
STUDENTS SUPPORT SERVICES STAFF
OR THE CAMPUSES. ARTICULATE THE
MARGINAL COST FOR CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES IS TEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
DOLLARS. YES SO YOU'RE SAYING
WE UNDERSTAND THE MARGINAL COST
IS ROUGHLY TEN THOUSAND PER
STUDENT YOU'RE SAYING. IF THERE
IF THERE WAS ANY ADDITIONAL
MONEY ABOVE THE ONE SEVENTY
THREE MILLION FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AT TEN THOUSAND PER
STUDENT. YOU WOULD FOCUS ON
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. THAT THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS CORRECT
THAT IS CORRECT SIR WE CAN
INCREASE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
ENROLLMENT FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IF YOU'LL GIVE US
ADDITIONAL FUNDING YEAH AT THE
MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION
FOR STUDENTS GAS AND ALL I SAY
IS THAT THAT THAT THIS WEEKEND.
WHEN I GO TO THE MY LITTLE
LEAGUE GAME WHEN MR- GALLAGHER
GOES TO THAT TO THAT FARM
WHATEVER YOU HAVE UP THERE AND-
IN YUBA COUNTY WITH MR- THE
DONALD GOES TO THE LONG BEACH
GRAND PRIX AND YOU GO TO THAT
TINY TOTS PROGRAM IN- VALENCIA
YOU MISTER MEDINA GOES TO UC
RIVERSIDE YOU GO TO SOME TAX
SOMETHING RATHER IN. SILICON
VALLEY IN THIS RACE GOES TO THE
DESK- THESE FARMERS MARKET IN
DOWNTOWN SAN BERNARDINO OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE GONNA SAY YOU
HAVE GIVEN US THE YOU DON'T
HAVE ONE NEW SLOT FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA KIDS TO GO TO
UNIVERSITY. AND WE'RE GIVING
YOU TWO HUNDRED MILLION DLLARS
IN NEW MONEY TO FOCUS ROUGHLY.
ONE SEVENTY THREE TO YOUR
PRIORITIES. FORGIVING HUNDRED
OF MILLION DOLLARS IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE GRANTS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. AND THERE'S A BIG
LAUNDRY LIST OF STUFF THAT YOU
DEEM IMPORTANT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY BUT OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE SAYING NOW. THAT'S NOT OUR
PRIORITY SO THIS IS. A
UNACCEPTABLE. THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE A CLEAR CUT. ENROLLMENT
TARGET WITH EXISTING MONEY I
KNOW YOU ALWAYS WANT MORE AND
MORE AND MORE BUT THESE ARE
THESE ARE THE PRIORITIES OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THESE ARE.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PRIORITIES- AT THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT IVORY TOWER BUT
DON'T REFLECT OUR CONSTITUENTS
VALUES. RESPONSE. I THINK THAT
OUR STUDENTS WOULD WANT THE
UNIVERSITY TO HAVE HIGH QUALITY
AND AS OF THE THIRD LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HELP OUR
STAFF SALARIES KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION SO I THINK THE
INTEREST OF THE UNIVERSITY AND
THE STATE ARE VERY MUCH ALIGNED
AND MAKING CERTAIN THAT THE
BASE BUDGET OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
HEALTHY. WE CAN INCREASE
ENROLLMENT FOR THIS FALL WE HAD
A 13% INCREASE IN CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATE APPLICATIONS WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT WEIGHTLESS
WITH HIGHLY QUALIFIED STUDENTS.
IF WE HAD THE FUNDING WE CAN
PULL THOSE STUDENTS AND ENROLL
THEM THIS FALL SO WE CAN ALIGN
OUR PRIORITIES- SHOULD THERE BE
FUNDING FOR IT. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT REGARDING OUR
INITIATIVE- THE FRAMEWORK
TWENTY THIRTY TO GET STUDENTS
TO GRADUATE FASTER. WE HAVE SO
MANY PELL GRANT ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS THAT IF WE GET THEM TO
GRADUATE AT THE SAME TIME AS
NON ALL ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. WE
COULD INCREASE THROUGHPUT BY
MORE THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS EACH YEAR THAT WOULD
BE AN INCREASE AT THE
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
CLASSES THAT WE'RE TAKING AND
SO THERE'S THAT INVESTMENT
WHILE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S NOT AN
INVESTMENT ENROLLMENT BECAUSE
IT'S TALKING ABOUT STUDENT
SUCCESS. IT ACTUALLY ULTIMATELY.
IS AN ENROLLMENT INVESTMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU LET ME PIVOT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THAT THE LAST- ISSUE ON THE
AGENDA. IS ONE THAT'S BEEN- OF
ITS IMPORTANCE TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR NUMBER OF YEARS
AND THAT'S- ACCESS TO OUR TO
OUR HIGHLY COVETED CAMPUSES YOU
KNOW YOU SEE THE- NINE- STE YOU
KNOW NINE CAMPUS UNDERGRADUATE-
INSTITUTION. THEN OF THE NINE
CAMPUSES- YOU KNOW THREE ARE
REALLY THAT THE MARQUEE AS FAR
AS ACCESO TWEETS WHICHEVER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CAN YOU
START TALKING SO WE CAN SEE
THAT. YEAH DID YOU HAVE A YES
EPIC YEAH YES HAVE THE SAY ONE
WORD TO GET YOUR FEET YOU'RE AT
UP THERE YOUR BRAND. SO- IT'S I
KNOW A PRIORITY OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND FRANKLY NOW THE SENATE IS
PUSHING HARD ON THIS AS FAR AS
THE NON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT. I
KNOW THE CAMPUSES OF SAN DIEGO.
BERKELEY IN LA WILL SAY MORE
INTERNATIONAL. AND NON RAT AND
NOT A NON CALIFORNIAN WEALTHY
STUDENTS. EXPAND ACCESS TO
THOSE CAMPUSES BUT- YOU KNOW
THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS THAT
THOSE. AT THOSE- PREMIERE
CAMPUSES IS JUST THROUGH THE
ROOF. AND IT'S HARDEST TO SHOW
THAT THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS SO. AS WE KNOW IT
HERE WE DO HAVE- SOMEONE SEVEN
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME RESOURCES
SO. IS IT SAID ALL A PRIORITY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION. TO LOWER
THE- THERE THE RATIO. AT THOSE
THAT THOSE THREE SPECIALLY
THOSE THREE CAMPUSES I KNOW
THAT CAMPUS IS LIKE RIVERSIDE
OTHERS ATTEMPTING TO GROW UP.
SANTA CRUZ BUT OF THOSE THREE
IT'S BECOME IT'S BECOME.
INCREASINGLY. TICKED UP A
PROBLEM. WE'RE BURNSIDE OFF
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS. SO
WHAT'S YOURS LET ME STAY ON ON
AGAIN ON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
HERE MINISTRATION IS OPEN TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION WE KNOW
THAT'S A LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY
IN TERMS OF NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT. THAT
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT WENT
DOWNTOWN AND THEREFORE ON
RESIDENT TUITION WENT DOWN THAT
WOULD CREATE SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURE ON THE STATE TO BACK
FILL THAT. YEAH I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT'S TRUE THAT NON RESIDENT-
APPLICATIONS WENT DOWN BUT THEY
WENT DOWN FROM LIKE SIXTY
THOUSAND TO FIFTY FIVE I'M NOT
SURE THE NUMBER STILL SLIGHTLY
DOWN AND THE NUMBER OF SLOTS
YOU HAD FOR NON RESIDENTS WAS
STILL. YOU KNOW YOU HAD FOUR
MORE TIMES APPLICATIONS IF I
RECALL THAN SLOTS AVAILABLE FOR
NON RESIDENTS SO THERE'S STILL
A TREMENDOUS DEMAND IN
INTERNATIONAL EVEN DURING
COVERED EVEN WHEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS YOU KNOW MAKING
THAT YOU KNOW HARDER AND LESS
ATTRACTIVE FOR INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS TO COME. TO AMERICA TO
STUDY. YOU'RE STILL A HUGE HUGE
DEMAND- FOR INTERNATIONAL BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY ARE ARE YOU
WILLING TO LOWER THE RATIO AT
THE THREE PREMIERE CAMPUSES. SO
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WHO ARE GRADUATING FOUR POINT
FIVE GPAS AND- AND DOING VERY
WELL CAN CAN BE MORE VIABLE.
FOR OUR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FLAGSHIP CAMPUSES.
SO IF YOU IF THERE'S A SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL THAT COMES MORE THAN
WE CAN. CONSIDER THAT AND I CAN
TAKE IT BACK TO MANAGEMENT FOR
CONSIDERATION BUT AGAIN I WOULD
NOTE THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT. A
NON RESIDENT TUITION I WENT
DOWN FOR THE UC SYSTEM THAT
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURE ON THE STATE TOBACCO
YEAH AND ONE THING IS THAT- I
DON'T KNOW FOR CHARGING ENOUGH
IN NON RESIDENT TUITION.
CHARGING MORE NONRESIDENT
TUITION. I THINK IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER. HELP
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE TRYING TO
PAY FOR COLLEGE I WANT TO PIVOT
NOW TO THIS- TO THIS LEARNING
ALIGNED STUDENT EMPLOYMENT I.
SENSUALLY LIKE STATE FUNDED
INTERNSHIPS AS KIND OF WHAT I.
SEE IT AS- SO ONE IS- IS IT HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT JUST PROVIDING A
BUNCH TO. FREE LABOR TO. FROM
TO TINA TECH COMPANIES AND
OTHER INTERNATIONAL COMPANIES
ARE JUST WANT TO HAVE. AN
OPPORTUNE HAVE FREE WORKERS
RIGHT AND THEN TO- HOW TO BE A
READ IS THIS MEANS TESTED. ARE
WE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO BENEFIT FROM THIS
ARE YOU YOU KNOW PELL
RECIPIENTS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE
FOCUS ON WHO YEAH SO THOSE.
YEAH I THINK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS THE AND WE KNOW WHAT
THE CONCERN IS AND THE CONCERN
ABOUT POTENTIALLY FREE LABOR
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL SPECIFIES THAT THE IN
THERE A CAMPUS AND- WENT CREEK
IN AGREEMENT WITH AN EMPLOYER.
WOULD FIRST OF PRIORITIZE AND
TRY TO TRY TO GET IN THAT COULD
CONTRIBUTE FINANCIALLY TO THE
HOURLY WAGE AVE- STUDENT PLOY
AND IT HAS A LITTLE SECOND PART
AS FAR AS- WILL BE A
REQUIREMENT FOR INCOME YEAH
THEY'RE AND THEY'RE- TRAILER
BILL ALSO SPECIFIES THAT THAT
THIS IS A LOW INCOME TARGETED-
PROGRAM. AS WELL THE OTHER
CATEGORIES BEING- FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESS USE BUTTE A BIGGER
UMBRELLA OF UNDERREPRESENTED
BACKGROUND SO IT IS A- TARGETED.
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA YEAH I
DON'T THINK THIS IS A UP SINCE
THAT TERRIBLE IDEA BUT I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF DETAILS NEED
TO BE SORTED OUT AS WELL AS WE
NEED TO. TO RECONCILE THIS WITH
OUR OTHER PRIORITIES- LIKE YOU
KNOW WHAT I SPENT THE FIRST
PART OF MY QUESTIONING AND
COMMENTS ABOUT AS FAR AS OF
OVERALL- ACCESS SO- AND THEN
WERE IN REGARDS TO THE- THE
LINE ITEM. YOU KNOW. WHAT WAS
WILL YOU KNOW TAKE THAT IN
CONSIDERATION. NOT CERTAIN THAT
IT'S THAT IT'S TIME FOR THAT
ESPECIALLY- IN LIGHT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR STATE
AUDITOR THAT THIS IS A SOUND
POLICY SO. THAT'S IT FOR NOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. YEAH I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHICO'S- ALMA
MATER. UC BERKELEY WAS RECENTLY
RECOGNIZED AS THE NUMBER ONE.
PUBLIC INSTITUTION. IN THE
UNITED STATES AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE- THE TO THE POINT THAT
OUR CHAIRS MAKING. IT WOULD
SEEM LIKE TO ME THAT YOU SEE
SHOULD NOT HAVE A PROBLEM. IN
BOTH MAINTAINING THE HIGH
QUALITY THAT WE EXPECT. FROM UP
THE PREMIER INSTITUTION AND AT
THE SAME TIME MAKING ROOM. FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND- AND I
JUST WANT TO- MENTION. IT'S PUT
ON THE TABLE THE IDEA THAT WE
ARE A COUPLE YEARS AGO FROM THE
L. A. O. AND THAT IS TO PROVIDE
METRICS. TO YOU SEE. UNFUNDED
AT AND THE IDEA THAT YOU SEE
YOU WOULD HAVE TO MEET. CERTAIN
METRICS THAT WE PROPOSE SO THAT
IT WOULD INDEED BE MISTER
CHAIR. RIGHT THE PRIORITIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND THAT YOU
SEE WOULD HAVE TO MEET THOSE
GOALS- IN ORDER. TO RECEIVE THE
FUNDING THE CONTINUES FUNDING
THAT WERE GIVEN SO JUST JUST
PUT NOT ON THE TABLE- AS AS
IDEA THAT WE HEARD A COUPLE
YEARS BACK- AND- MAKING THE
POINT THAT IT MAY BE GOOD TO
REVISIT THAT. MOVING FORWARD.
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
DONALD YES THANK YOU HAVE A
THAT MAYBE I BELIEVE THIS-
QUESTION BE FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WHAT IS THE- UC
BERKELEY ALTERNATIVE MEATS LAB.
WE GO. SO ALL RESTATE WHAT THE
INVESTMENT IS AND THEN PERHAPS
MY COLLEAGUE MISPERTON CAN
SPEAK TO MORE SPECIFICALLY BUT
THE PROPOSAL IS JUST A GENERAL
ONE MILLION US ONE TIME SUPPORT
FOR THE ALTERNATIVE MEATS LAB-
ALL ALL DEFERRED TO HER. YEAH
MAYBE JUST TELL ME WHAT. WHAT
THE MEAT LAB DOES. SAVER CAN
AND GET A RECEIPT OF CALIFORNIA
AT THE UC BERKELEY ALTERNATIVE
MEAT LAB RESEARCHERS ARE PLANT
BASED ALTERNATIVES TO MEAT
PRODUCTS- AND WORKS WITH
ENTREPRENEURS TO TRY TO BRING
THOSE TO MARKET THE INTENT HERE
IS TO REDUCE OUR IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE DUE TO. MASS
ANIMAL FARMING. OKAY THANK YOU
I GUESS IT WOULDN'T BE MEET THE
OFFICE PLANTS BUT OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN I JUST HAVE
ANOTHER BREAK A COMMONER QUITE
WELL WE'RE PROBABLY A QUESTION
FOR THE UC AT ITS FACILITIES
NOT ALWAYS THE MOST EXCITING
TOPIC IN THIS ROOM BUT
FACILITIES ARE IMPORTANT. WELL
LAST YEAR WE HAD A SCHOOL BOND
THAT FAILED AND IT FAILED FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS- MS CALL
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THAT
CONFUSE THE VOTERS. I HAD SOME
THINGS THAT THE PEOPLE DIDN'T
LIKE MAYBE THE DOLLAR THRESHOLD
WAS TOO HIGH. BUT ALSO RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE DIDN'T RECEIVE
AS MUCH SUPPORT AS BECAUSE
HIGHER EDUCATION. WAS IN THAT
THAT BOND. SO I WENT OUT AND
DID SOME RESEARCH AND WHAT I
FOUND WAS THAT IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THERE WAS ACTUALLY AN
AGREEMENT STAKEHOLDERS CAME
TOGETHER. AND SAID HEY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO PUT YOU IN THE
NEXT SCHOOL BOND. BUT WE ARE
GOING TO GIVE YOU TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR EACH
SEGMENT TO UNDER MILLION
DOLLARS HERE. WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO LET YOURSELF BOND FOR YOUR
FAILITIES TO A MILLION DOLLARS
HERE. AND GET A CELLPHONE. SO
AS WE GO FORWARD- MY QUESTION
FOR YOU IS DO YOU DO YOU WANT
TO CONTINUE ON THE PATH OF SELF%
BONDING IN THE IN THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION. OR DO YOU WANT TO
BE IN A FUTURE SCHOOL FUNDING
HE REALLY CAN'T I CAN'T
ADVOCATE FOR BOTH- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I WOULD RATHER
TAKE. THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION A
YEAR. AND THE ABILITY TO SELF
ON BIGGEST ARGUABLY. YOUR
FACILITIES- HAVE DONE BETTER
UNDER THAT MODEL THEN GOING
FORWARD. IN A SCHOOL BOND ONLY
MODEL CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- OF.
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO YOU SEE.
WHAT THE COVERED THE PRIOR
STATE G. WILL BOND PAYMENTS
THAT WERE ALSO TRANSFERRED TO
UC. WE REFINANCE THOSE AND NOW
COVERED THOSE FROM OUR OWN
BUDGET. WHEN I TALKED ABOUT OUR
BASE BUDGET HAVING OF BONDS.
ALSO INCREASES. I WAS REFERRING
TO THIS PROCESS- REPEAT WHAT'S
CALLED AB NINETY FOUR PROCESS.
YOU SEE IS ABLE TO CONSTRUCT
OUR OWN BUILDINGS YOU SEEN OUR
STATE APPROPRIATION AS THE
COLLATERAL. WE ARE NOW
EXPERIENCING ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN COST
INCREASES DUE TO THE BUILDINGS
WE ARE BUILDING. SO THAT
PROCESS IS WORKING FOR US. WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO- DO SOME
SEISMIC MAKE RENOVATIONS AND
CONSTRUCTS SOME BUILDINGS. BUT
IT IS QUITE EXPENSIVE AND
PLACES. ACOSTA STRAIN. ON THE
FUNDING WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TO THE CAMPUSES. IN ORDER TO-
COVER THEIR COST INCREASES. SO
WE WOULD PREFER A STATE. NEW
STATE YOUR BOND. TO HELP US
WITH. OUR MASSIVE SEISMIC.
RENOVATION NEEDS WE HAVE ABOUT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN SEISMIC
RENOVATION NEEDS. THAT WE COULD
GET GOING ON. TOMORROW IF WE
HAD THE MONEY. SO YOU WANT.
OKAY SO DO YOU WANT TO GO WITH
THE CURRENT MODEL WHERE YOU DO
RECEIVE THOSE DOLLARS. AND YOU
ARE DO YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SELF MONITOR YOU WANTED
STATEWIDE G. OF. ON OF ONE OR
THE OTHER BECAUSE I CAN'T- ASK
MY- I CAN'T. FOR BOTH. SO WHICH
WOULD YOU PREFER YOU HAVE ANY
TODAY IF YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER TODAY THAT'S FINE. WE
WOULD RATHER NOT CHOOSE BETWEEN
THE TWO PROCESSES TODAY IF I
COULD GET BACK TO YOU SIR THAT
WOULD BE OPTIMAL WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY PREFER BOTH. BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE NOT- AT THIS
POINT. THEY THINK THAT'S
FEASIBLE. DR EIGHT YET THAT IS
CORRECT AND THAT THAT AS FOR
THE REASONS I'VE LAID OUT WANT
TO SUPPORT YOU ON THE FACILITY
SIDE I THINK SOME THE CHANGES
WE'VE MADE. HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
BETTER THAN THE UC RE THAT
RELYING ON STATE BOND MONEY-
FOR THE INSTITUTION AS YOU HAVE
LAID OUT- SO I THINK I THINK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER AND
THEN MISLED US. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT UP THE FARM-
BECAUSE THAT THAT'S A GOOD
SEGUE INTO WHAT I WANT TO ASK
ABOUT IN THIS BUDGET- MANY MAY
NOT KNOW ABOUT THE- UC.
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES PROGRAM. THAT'S
OPERATED THROUGH THIS YOU SEE
BUDGET- BEEN A VERY IMPORTANT
RESOURCE FOR DECADES IN HELPING
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- THE
LATEST SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE IN
HELPING FARMERS. GROW THE
SAFEST- YOU KNOW MOST RESILIENT
AND PLENTIFUL CROPS AND IS IN
THE WORLD- BEEN A HUGE BENEFIT.
I IN THIS BUDGET RIGHT NOW WE
ARE TAKING THAT LINE ITEM OUT
OF THE BUDGET I THINK FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER AND LUMPING IT
IN TOGETHER. WITH THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT- BUDGET. I
HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT RIGHT NOW IN IN MY
DISTRICT ALONE WE HAVE OVER
THIRTEEN CRITICAL POSITIONS
THAT ARE VACANT- RIGHT NOW
THESE ARE THINGS SUCH AS AN
IRRIGATION SPECIALIST ORCHARD
IST INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT.
A RICE AND SMALL FARMING
VILLAGE CROP SPECIALISTS IN
PLACES LIKE COLUSA SHASTA TO
HEMA. BUTTE AND YUBA COUNTIES
WE ALSO HAVE NO ADVISER RIGHT
NOW FOR THE FOUR H. PROGRAM AND
MANY MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH FOR
AGES YOU KNOW USED IN
AGRICULTURE- PROGRAM THAT HAS
BEEN YOU KNOW VERY GOOD FOR OUR
FOR OUR YOUTH IN TERMS OF
BUILDING LEADERSHIP SKILLS BUT
ALSO. YOU KNOW BILLION THAT
NEXT GENERATION OF FARMERS- AND
AGRICULTURALIST AND BILLION
THAT KNOWLEDGE BASE THAT WE
CONSTANTLY NEED TO- TO GROW-
RIGHT NOW I HAVE NO NO ADVISER
THERE AT ALL FOR BUTTE AND
GLENN COUNTIES WHICH HAVE SOME
OF THE LARGEST FOUR EIGHT
CHAPTERS IN THE- IN THE STATE-
ALSO WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION TALKS A LOT
ABOUT GOALS IN TERMS OF CLIMATE
RESILIENCE. PEST MANAGEMENT
IRRIGATION PRODUCTION
EFFICIENCY. ON FARMS IN THE
NEED. TO SUPPORT NEW AND
BEGINNING. FARMERS AND
RANCHERS- THIS IS A RESOURCE
THAT DOES ALL THOSE THINGS- THE
UC ANR- PROGRAM. SO I HAVE A
REAL CONCERN ABOUT IF WE REMOVE
THIS LINE ITEM COMPLETELY AND
PUT THE DISCRETION COMPLETELY.
UNDER THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT IS THIS PROGRAM GOING
TO CONTINUE- HAVE VERY STRONG
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT AND HOWCAN
WE AS A LEGISLATURE ENSURE
THAT- THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
GOING INTO THIS IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE DIRECTED TO- THIS
PROGRAM. WITHOUT HAVING A
DIRECT LINE ITEM I DON'T SEE
HOW WE CAN- I WOULD JUST ASK
FIRST TO THE UC. WHAT'S YOUR
COMMITMENT. TO CONTINUE THIS
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF REAL
DOLLARS- IF THIS LINE ITEM IS
TAKEN OUT. AND IS INSTEAD KIND
OF LUMPED INTO THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT- BUDGET ITEM.
THANK YOU SIR FOR THE QUESTION-
SO FIRST I WANT TO COMMENT THAT
THE UC ANR BUDGET HAS BEEN PART
OF THE U. C. O. P. OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT FOR MANY MANY
DECADES- THEY DID NOT GET THEIR
OWN LINE ITEM UNTIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- IF THE LINE ITEM. IS
ELIMINATED THEIR SEVERAL WAYS
THAT WE CAN ENSURE UC ANR
RECEIVES THE FUNDING THAT THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO PROPERLY SERVE
THE STATE. ONE OF THE SAYS WE
HAVE A SYSTEM CALLED SET ASIDES
FROM OUR CAMPUS ALLOCATION.
THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO THE
GOVERNOR- AND TO THE STATE IN
GENERAL THAT WE- TAKE SORT OF
OFF THE TOP. OF THE- GENERAL
ALLOCATION TO THE CAMPUS AS WE
CURRENTLY FUND THE AGRICULTURAL
EXPERIMENT STATIONS IN THIS
MATTER. THAT'S TO ENSURE THAT
THEY GET THEIR FUNDING EVERY
YEAR AND THAT THEY GROW WITH A
COLA REGARDLESS OF WHAT ELSE
MAY HAPPEN. THE WEEKEND FUND UC
ANR IN THAT MATTER YOU CAN ALSO
PUT IN SOME BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THE
INCREASES. OR THE TOTAL AMOUNT.
OF THE UC BUDGET THAT SHOULD GO
TO UC ANR. I KNOW THAT THE
SENATE IS VERY INTERESTED IN
INCREASING DO YOU SEE IT IN OUR
BUDGET- AND I AM WORKING WITH
THEM ON SOME LANGUAGE THAT CAN
BE PUT INTO THE BUDGET TO
ENSURE THAT. THEIR INVESTMENTS
GET PUT. INTO PLACE WHERE- THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS THEM TO BE.
YEAH AND YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT
TWENTY TEAM IS THE FIRST BUT
THAT WAS ALSO PART OF OUR
TRANSPARENCY WITH YOU SEE
OPERATE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT MONEY THAT
WAS. YOU KNOW BEING SQUIRRELED
AWAY THAT NOBODY KNEW ABOUT-
AND HOW TRANSPARENCY TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE. THAT MONEY IS
GOING- L. A. BY THE WAY
RECOMMENDS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
KEEP- YOU SEE A AND R. AS A
SEPARATE. LINE ITEM SO I THINK
WE SHOULD. ENSURE THAT WE DO
THAT IN THIS BUDGET PROCESS- IN
A SURE THAT WE KEEP. FINDING
WHAT I THINK IS A REALLY VITAL
TOOL- YOU KNOW FOR AGRICULTURE-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- AND AGAIN
THESE OPERATE NOT JUST OF MY
DISTRICT THERE- IT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND- GIVING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT HELPING- NEAR. NEW
FARMERS WHO ARE COMING IN THE
INDUSTRY- MANY MINORITY FARMERS
WHO ARE COMING INTO THE
INDUSTRY- SO WE NEED TO ENSURE
THIS PROGRAM- IS SUFFICIENTLY
FUNDED AND- AND THE POSITIONS
ARE FILLED. YOU KNOW LIKE I
SAID WE HAVE POSITIONS THAT
AREN'T EVEN BEING FILLED- RIGHT
NOW SO THAT WOULD BE MY- MY BIG
CONCERN WITH THIS BUDGET SO FAR
SO OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER IS THE ONLY MEMBER OF
AYE IT AT US. JUST TO CONTINUE
ON THIS QUESTIONING OF THIS-
THIS LINE ITEM SET SEPARATION
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION. DO YOU
HAVE AN EXAMPLE TO POINT TO
THAT SUGGESTS THAT THE CURRENT
BUDGETING STRUCTURE HINDERS YOU
YOU WITH THESE OPERATIONS UC'S
OPERATIONS. QUESTION. BUT I
WOULD I WOULD RESTATED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ARE WRAPPED
CAL IS TO ENSURE FLEXIBILITY
FALSO PRESERVING THE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. THROUGH BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ALL POINT TO- BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES TO ATTEND IN HER
OPENING REMARKS DID MENTION
THAT THIS PAST YEAR. DURING THE
PANDEMIC THERE WAS A SPECIFIC
SITUATION WITH FEDERAL
RESOURCES THAT. PREVENTED YOU
COPD FROM FROM EASILY- WORKING
THROUGH WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN A
MUCH MORE STUPID OPERATIONAL-
SYSTEM IN SORT OF ABSORBING AND
USING RESOURCES THAT BENEFIT
ALL THE CAMPUSES AND THEREFORE
YOU SEE STUDENTS SOUGHT A
LETTER ELABORATED SHE- IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN HEARING
MORE ABOUT THAT SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE BUT THE OVERALL
RATIONALE IS THE- WHAT WHAT'S
WHAT'S- HAPPENED FLEXIBILITY.
BUT THAT ALSO PRESERVE THE
TRANSPARENCY. FOR THE L. L.
AWAY AND THIS. SO FAR WE HEARD
ARE YOU SEE BRING UP THIS
EXAMPLE YESTERDAY TO EAT WE'D
BE HAPPY TO CIRCLE BACK WITH
STOCKTON FOLLOW UP ON THIS YOU
KNOW GENERALLY ON THE MORE
LIGHT ITEMS YOU ADD IN THE
BUDGET THE LESS FLEXIBILITY
THERE IS THAT IS A- BASIC TRADE
OFF THAT THE LEGISLATURE FACES
WHATEVER IT. IS CONSIDERING
ADDING OR SUBTRACTING LINE
ITEMS ON THERE ARE TOOLS
SOMETIMES THAT ALLOW THE- THERE
ARE TOOLS IN THE IN THE BUDGET
THAT SOMETIMES A LOT FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY- SO
AGAIN I. AT WHETHER OR NOT THIS
ONE EXAMPLE BIRDS COMPLETELY
ELIMINATING THE LINE ITEM OR
CONSIDERING OCCUR BUDGET TOOLS
THESE ARE THINGS WE BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP ON. LOOKING TO STAFF.
OKAY S. R. ONE ONE MORE
QUESTION HERE- AND JUST TO RE
VISIT THE MAY REVISION AND THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION- TO
ESTABLISH THE ENDOWMENT FOR
LEARNING ONLINE EMPLOYMENT- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
TAXPAYERS DIDN'T SIGN UP. TO
CONTRIBUTE TO UC'S INVESTMENT
PORTFOLIO WHEN THEY PAY TAXES
THIS YEAR. AND RATHER THAN
LOOKING AT THESE FUNDS THAT ARE
IN AND DOWN MA'AM THESE THE
STATE SHOULD CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVES THAT HAVE THE
GREATEST IMPACT. ON STUDENT
ACCESS AND SUCCESS. OR REDUCE
LONG TERM DEPTH AND OR TO
REDUCE LONG TERM DOESN'T
LIABILITIES SO I'M JUST. TO THE
UC'S WHAT ONE TIME INVESTMENT.
DID YOU SEE IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING THE GREATEST IMPACT ON
STUDENT SUCCESS. ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS ARE OFTEN- A LITTLE
DIFFICULT AND STUDENT SUCCESS
TERMS BUT SOME OF THAT- SOME OF
THE ONES THAT WE WOULD LIKE.
ARE THINGS LIKE HELPING TO
ESTABLISH CENTERS ON THE
CAMPUSES FOR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND STUDENTS IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION AND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS TO HELP THEM SUCCEED.
WE COULD GET STARTED ON- SUMMER
BRIDGE PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO BE EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE. IN HELPING STUDENTS
FROM DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS
GET THIRD JUMP STARTED ON THEIR
COLLEGE CAREER THEY COME TO THE
UC CAMPUS FOR THE SUMMER AS A
COHORT DAY TAKE CLASSES
TOGETHER TO GET MENTORING AND
TRAINING. AND THEN THEY'RE
READY TO THROW IN THE FALL- AND
PROCEED WITH THEIR MAJORS SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL BE VERY
VERY HELPFUL- IN ADDITION A ONE
TIME INVESTMENT IN CAPITAL
OUTLAYS BUT HELP IS. EITHER
CONSTRUCT NEW CLASSROOMS WHICH
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR
FUTURE ENROLLMENT EXPANSION OF
SEISMIC RENOVATIONS AND ALSO
POSSIBLE LAND ACQUISITION OF
NEW PROPERTIES FOR POTENTIAL
FUTURE CAMPUS EXPANSIONS.
SHOULD. THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
BECOME AVAILABLE. AND YOU SEE
HOW HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION
IN ASSETS UNDER MANAGEMENT AS
OF AUGUST IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
I CAN IMAGINE THAT THE BALANCE
IS LIKELY GROWN SINCE THEN I
WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHAT- WHAT
THAT GROWTH LOOKS LIKE AND HAS
THE UC CONSIDERED USING THEIR
EARNINGS. FROM THE INVESTMENTS
TO FUND- WORK STUDY PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION OF
THE CURRENT ASSETS UNDER
MANAGEMENT. THANK YOU SEE THE
BOSTON OFFICE ARE APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT IS OUR RETIREMENT
PROGRAMS. AND THOSE- INVESTMENT
RETURNS MUST BE RETURNED TO THE
RETIREMENT PROGRAM SO THAT
FUNDS. ARE EMPLOYEES FUTURE- WE
ALSO HAVE RESTRICTED
ENDOWMENTS- MORE THAN 80% OF
OUR ENDOWMENTS ARE RESTRICTED
BASED ON DONOR CRITERIA AND WE
CANNOT TAKE THE- WE CANNOT TAKE
THE PROCEEDS FROM THOSE AND USE
THEM FOR OTHER PURPOSES OTHER
THAN THE ORIGINAL INDICTMENT
PURPOSE. WE HAVE NOT- A WITHIN
YOU SEE THOUGHT ABOUT STARTING
OUR OWN WORK STUDY PROGRAM YET-
THIS PROPOSAL CAME FROM THE
GOVERNOR IT'S VERY INTRIGUING
THE CURRENT NUMBER OF FEDERAL
WORK STUDIES OF POSSESSIONS IS
LIMITED- BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING SO WHAT THE FUNDING IS
GONE THERE'S NO MORE. WORK
STUDY POSITION SO THIS WOULD
HELP EXPAND THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
WORK STUDY POSITIONS AVAILABLE.
TO OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACE. THANK YOU MR UP I
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE ONE TIME
FUNDING- CLEARLY THAT THE STATE
HAS SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
THIS YEAR I AM CONCERNED AND I
DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
CHAIRS AND QUESTIONS REGARDING.
THERE BEING NO ENROLLMENT
TARGET NO INCREASE IN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS BEING
ADMITTED. HOW CAN THE STATE USE
THE ONE TIME FUNDING TO EXPAND
THE CAPACITY OF UC'S AND WHY
ISN'T THE ADMINISTRATION
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE OF EXPANDING. THE
CAPACITY EXPANDING ENROLLMENT
SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR CALIFORNIA
APPLICANTS. SURE THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ALL JUST RESTATE
THAT ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
HAPPEN ENROLLMENT TARGET IN THE
MAY REVISE BUT THE TEXTURE OF
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE ARE GOING
FORWARD INTERESTED IN WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WE KNOW
THIS IS A PRIORITY. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. CAN
YOU TELL US SPECIFICALLY WHAT
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING-
RECOGNIZING- AND YOU'VE HEARD
FROM THE COOK MY COLLEAGUES
WHAT AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY THAT
IS AND HAS BEEN IT ISN'T JUST
THIS YEAR- THE- HOW DO YOU
ENVISION THIS CONVERSATION
GOING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE HOW WE'RE GOING TO
INCREASE THE UC CAPACITY- FOR
OUR- WEEKLY AGAIN FOR
CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS. YES THEY
PREDICT THE FOLLOW UP I CAN
JUST SPECIFY THAT THE KEY TO
GOING FORWARD IS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE TO WORK WITH THE UC
THIS WILL ALSO GO FOR THE CSU.
ON WHAT ENROLLMENT TARGETS
COULD LOOK LIKE NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE SO WE WANT TO DO THIS IN
DISCUSSION WITH THE SEGMENTS
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I DO
KNOW THAT IF I MAY USE THAT AS
A FOLLOW UP. THERE ARE SOME
UNITS UNIVERSITIES IT SOME UC'S
WHO HAVE. BEEN VERY SPECIFIC
AND INTENTIONAL ABOUT
INCREASING THE ENROLLMENT OF
LOCAL STUDENTS SANDED MINORITY
STUDENTS. UNIVERSITIES UC'S
LIKE YOU SEE ARE VERY
SPECIFICALLY WHO HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS REGARD. I
THINK THAT- TO FIND SOME OF
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN THAT REGARD WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE- THE- ART I KNOW
THERE'S ANOTHER WORD BUT THE
LEAD TO- UC'S LIKE BERKELEY.
BUT I THINK IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THOSE THAT ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
FOR CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS THEN
WE LOOK NEED TO LOOK TO THE
MODELS LIKE. YOU SEE OUR TO SEE
WHAT IT IS THAT THEY ARE DOING
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO MODEL OTHER
ENROLLMENT GOALS- ED TARGETS-
IT'S EASY TO MODEL THEM TO. TO
UC'S LIKE YOU SEE ARE SO THANK.
YOU SO MUCH. OKAY I THINK THAT
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS WE
WILL HOLD. THIS ISSUE OVER AND
PROCEED NOW TO THE C.
A FINANCE.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND AFFILIATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE ME
REVISION PROVIDE NINETY NINE
POINT FOUR MILLION ONGOING AND
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION A ONE TIME JOURNAL FIND
RESOURCES TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WHICH
INCLUDES- BASE OF IMITATION OF
SEVENTY FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. THE MAJOR
REVISION ALSO PROVIDES THE
FOLLOWING INVESTMENTS TO THE
CSU FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION I'M
GOING TRYING TO FIND TO SUPPORT
TRANSITIONING CSU HUMBOLDT TO A
POLITECNICO OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO ITS SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CSU NORTHRIDGE
CENTER FOR EQUITY IN INNOVATION
AND TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
FERTILE CORONAVIRUS CAPITAL
PROJECT FUNDS THROUGH THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO SUPPORT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS
THE REMOVAL OF THE SUSPENSION
DATE FOR SUMMER TERM FINANCIAL
AID THEREBY CONSUMING THE SIX
MILLION ANNUAL AUGMENTATION FOR
THE PROGRAM ON AN ONGOING BASIS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU L. L. MORNING CANNOT.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS FORECASTS.
YEAH BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR SEE
IF YOU AN AMERICAN AND
BEGINNING A DEBATE SOMETHING.
MANY OF THE COMMENTS THAT
COLLEGES THAT PROVIDE A IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL IN THE SEE A
HERE AS WELL. SO TO YOU SEE IF
YOU THAT THAT OPERATING COSTING.
INSPECTIONS AND HEALTH BENEFITS.
AND COSTS ARE ASKED TO TOTAL
FIFTY NOTHING. WHICH OF A ONE
POINT FIVE PRESS. OF THE NATION
ADDRESS COUNTER LEVEL WE
RECOMMEND PROVIDE ADMIN THE
MATTER YES YEAR. HUMBOLDT STATE
INTO A POLYTECHNIC STATE THIS
TRANSITION WOULD HAVE NOTABLE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE CAMPUS IN
TERMS OF ITS COURSE OFFERINGS
RATIONS POTENTIALLY SYMBOL
NINTENDO ROLE WITHIN THE
BROADER SIXTY FIFTY. CURRENTLY
THE CAMPUS IS UNDER WITHOUT
STOPPING IT AN ACADEMIC PLAN
FOR EXTRA. WHAT WILL BE OF
EXPECT TO BE. THREE BILLION THE-
WHEN IT WOULD BE PREMATURE TO
FUND THE TRANSACTION THE NOT
STUDY FREEDOM AND THE FAVORABLE
FOR REVIEW. NO COMMENTS TO THE
CAPITAL. THAT THE FORM THIRTY
THREE MILLION TIME. BACKGROUND
WOULD GO TOWARDS HOUSING
PROJECT THAT WE BE AT DEPARTURE
THE CURRENT THE FUNDING THANKS
THE LADIES ON UNIVERSITIES. IN
ADDITION A PORTION OF THE FOR
APPROACH EXPANDING ITS SPACE.
CAMP OF RELATIVELY WELL YOU
KNOW I RATE FOR ITS EXISTING IN
TEACHING MORE. BUT JUST LIKE.
LIKE THE ONE TO CONSIDER IT
THAT WAY TOO ME THIS PROPOSAL.
PERHAPS AT A LATER DATE. I JUST
PREFER SPEAKING THAT OTHERS
MANNER PROPOSED. IS ABOUT WHAT
BRING THAT AMOUNT PROVIDE FOR
DIFFERENT SINCE YOU SEE IT
THREE AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TIME. EVEN IF YEAR IS
IDENTIFIED IN. BACKLOG TOTALING
FOUR BILL. AND. IT RAINSTORM
HERE. SO RIGHT I THINK YOUR-
YOU'RE ON MUTE SO CAN YOU TRY
TO DRESS THE. HE'S TALKING. THE
RAIN WE START WE CAN SEE YOU
TALKING OUR OUR TECH PEOPLE CAN
SEE YOU TALKING BUT NO AUDIO SO
YOU'RE NOT KICKING ON TO THE
SCREEN HERE. SPEAKING TRY TO-
START OVER. A. B. LOG OFF AND
LOG BACK ON. OKAY WHAT WHILE
RYAN IS- TRYING TO COME BACK-
JUST TO BEAT THE IN A FAIR AND
IT'S THE SAME ISSUE THAT WE
PUSHED BACK ON YOU SEE AN
APARTMENT OF FINANCE ON SO
WE'LL DO THE SAME HERE FOR CSU.
AND THAT IS ACCESS ENROLLMENT
WE STILL HAVE THE SAME.
CHALLENGES THAT MANY OF OUR CS
YOU CAN'T. I THINK POLY SAN
OBISPO. LONG BEACH DIEGO. TEN-
AMONG OTHERS. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON-
ON HOW. IN A TARGET WEEK. CSU
ROUGHLY HUNDRED SIX MILLION-
KNOWS IT. COMMA BLAME CHECK.
BUT DON'T VOTE ON. THE TOP-
ISSUES WE HEAR CROSSES TO FROM
OUR- CONSTITUENTS AS- TO THE
SEA SAYS. AT THANK YOU A CALL
THE- THIS IS- JOE WE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THEY ME AS MY
COLLEAGUE FOR A OVERSEEING THE
UNIVERSE OF BUDGET OTHER
REVISION NOT SERVICE BROWN CAR
FOR BY YOU WHEN YOU SEE. AND
WHILE WE WERE THAT CAL RESIDENT
ROMANCE AT CS AND UC IS A
PRIORITY THE LETTER. WHERE OPEN
TO FURTHER DISCUSS AS WE
PROCEED THE BUDGET PROCESS AT
THE MINISTRY IT IS INTO- IT
WILL WITH BOTH CSU SEE ON WHAT
ROOM TARGETS COULD LOOK LIKE
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE AS PART
OF THE DAY. OF FOR THE THANK
YOU. OKAY DO WE HAVE AT CSU NOW
AVAILABLE RAINSTORM. OKAY. TELL
LET'S GO BACK IN THE MEANTIME
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN
YOU RESPOND TO THE- THAT THE
POLYTECHNIC UNIVERSITY-
PROPOSAL- OBVIOUSLY THAT HAVING
ANOTHER POLITECNICA NEVER CITY-
IS A POSITIVE THING IN THE CSU
SYSTEM WE DO HAVE ONE AT CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO WHICH IS
YOU KNOW IMPACTED IN HUGE
DEMAND. THAT THEY CAL POLY NOT
TOO FAR FROM PRAMANA NOT TOO
FAR FROM HERE IN ENGLAND EMPIRE
IS A COP CAL POLY IT'S BEEN
AROUND FOR DECADES AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IT DOESN'T HAVE
THE DEMAND- AS FAR AS THE
APPLICATION SO WHAT MAKES US
THINK THAT THIS ONE. YOU KNOW
AND A NEARLY HALF A BILL
DOLLARS INFUSION. WILL WILL
PRODUCE THE SAME OUTCOMES THAT
WE SEE IT CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AS THE MINISTER SHOULD
LEAVE THAT CSU IS A UNIQUELY
SITUATED TO PROVIDE AN
AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR US THEN
ENHANCE EDUCATION WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROMOTING
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH STEM ORIENTED
JOBS IN THE REGION- GIVEN THE
ABSENCE OF A POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY IN THE FAR NORTH
COASTAL REGION. OF THE STATE
AND HUBBLE STATES CURRENT ROLE
AS PRODUCER OF THE THIRD
HIGHEST NUMBER OF STEM
UNDERGRADUATES AND THIS UC
SYSTEM AT AS YOU MENTIONED
AFTER CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO
AS WELL CAL POLY POMONA- THE
MAY REVISION AS INVESTMENT.
CONSISTING OF ALL THE LINES
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION OVERALL
FOCUS ON MEETING WORKFORCE
NEEDS AND RECOGNIZING
OPPORTUNITIES AMONG REGIONS OF
ALL. CALIFORNIA. OKAY. MISTER
MISTER TAKE YOU MISTER MEDIA
YEAH ON THE ON THE- TRANSITION
TO A POLITECHNIKA RECEDED AT
CSU HUMBOLDT- I YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S AN EXCITING-
MOVEMENT ON ON THE PART OF THE
GOVERNOR I KNOW THAT IT WILL
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON TAT
REGION- HAVING VISITED. CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO SEVERAL
TIMES AND- KNOWING THE GREAT
WORK THAT IS DONE THERE AND
THE- YOU KNOW THE QUALITY. OF-
OF THEIR EDUCATION- ESPECIALLY
IN THE SCIENCES. ENGINEERING
I'M SURE HUMBOLDT WOULD DO THE
SAME. THAT AND THIS QUESTION
MAY BE BETTER DIRECTED TO- CSU
AND THE MR STARR BUT BUT ONE
QUESTION THAT THE RAISES IT IN
MY MIND IS THE DIVERSITY. OF-
OF- BOTH CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND WONDERING- WHAT
WOULD MEASURES WILL BE TAKEN TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MORE
DIVERSITY- WOULD WOULD- OCCUR
AT CSU HUMBOLDT. A GIVEN ITS
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION. AND HOW WE
CAN ENSURE. MORE DIVERSITY IN
THOSE KIND OF SCIENTIFIC
ENGINEERING PROGRAMS STEM
FIELDS- AND IT CERTAINLY
MEASURE SHOULD BE TAKEN AT THE
OUTSET TO. TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION. THIS STABBED A
SHIPMENT OF- A THIRD
POLYTECHNIC. NOT QUITE IS
PROBABLY BETTER DIRECTED TO-
SEE ISSUE. OKAY ADMINISTERS ARM
WITH US YET. THIS IS MY CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW X. OKAY GREAT I
LOVE THE FACT THAT THE- SOUNDS
WORK FOR THIS MORNING AND NOW
NOW I SOMEBODY BAD MY APOLOGIES
FOR MISSING OUT BOB THINK OF A
BECAUSE IT YEAH YOU NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TO TWENTY ONE SO
YEAH MY APOLOGIES MA'AM ARE FOR
THAT- I'M SO- MR MEDINA I WAS
UNABLE TO HEAR THE BIGELOW. I
THANK I CAN READ IT LET ME
REPEAT IT- KNOW JUST A
RECOGNIZE THE TRANS TO A THIRD
OF AT CSU HUMBOLDT IS EXCITING
THAT IT CERTAINLY WOULD US- IN
ON THE READ. OF THE RE- HAVING
VISIT CAL SAN LUIS OBISPO NO I
KNOW THE HYPE. NO THE HIGH IT
STANDARDS OF CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO- MY QUESTION WAS ABOUT
DIVERSITY- YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THAT THAT CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO- AS MANY PROGRAMS IN
PLACE TO TRY TO WORK ON- AND
IMPROVING THEIR DIVERSITY AND I
JUST. ASKING BUT WHAT MEASURES
WOULD BE IN PLACE AT HUMBOLDT
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY GIVEN ITS
YOU KNOW IT'S SOMEWHAT
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION- AWAY FROM
YOU KNOW POPULATION CENTERS UP
SO WHAT MEASURES MIGHT BE IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
DIVERSITY IS REFLECTED AT. THE
TO THIS THIRD POLITECNICA. WITH
THE SYSTEM. WELL A COUPLE OF
THINGS- FIRST FOREMOST AT THE
UNIVERSITY. LOCALLY. SEVEN
OVERALL IT'S POPULATION US-
SEVENTEEN PER OF ITS US BODY
YES FOR THE LOCAL. IT MEANS
THAT EIGHTY THREE PER OF IT OF
THE STUDENTS COME OTHER. OPERA
OF THE BIGGEST DRAW FROM SO CAL.
SO WITH US- CAL BEING A REALLY
DIVERSE AREA ALREADY. YOU CAN
SEE THAT THE OTHER THING TOO IS
THAT I BELIEVE 50% OF. STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND HSE RIGHT NOW ARE
YOU AROUND AND- PERSON
GENERATION TO IT TO ATTEND
UNIVERSITY SO DIVERSITY IS
THERE- SO- I THINK IT'S OF
GOING FORWARD. THAT'S IT'S ONE
OF THE CORE- THE COURT ISSUES
IS OF COURSE FOR THE UNIVERSITY
HAS SAID IS GRADUATE ISSUE. AND
ALSO. THAT GAPS THAT ARE BEACH
ARGUE HANDS. AND AS WELL AS OUR
FELLOW WHICH WILL STAY. WHEN
HAVE AN OP. I LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO TELL TO. BROWN BACK AND MY
CALL AND THEN I CAN- MAYBE MORE
HEALTH TO THE CAN AFFECT IF YOU
WANT MY- BETTER BUT I WANT TO
BE ABLE TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
SIR. THANK YOU YEAH SO MAYBE
WRITTEN REFER. MAYBE MR STARKEY
YOU GO BACK AND FOCUS ON YOUR-
YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION ON THE
NAY RIVAS REAL QUICK. RATE AND
IT WILL BE VERY LONG- SO AGAIN
I'M RIGHTS FOR A- FOR BUDGET
PROMISE ISSUE- I WANNA. TOUCH
ON THREE ISSUE FIRST THE BASE
AUGMENT. THAT I'M HUMBLE. AND
THEN ON A DEFERRED. FIRST LET'S
WITH THE BASED ON. I WANT TO
SAY THE WE TO SEIZE YOUR OF
EVERYTHING. TO THE GUY FOR THE-
OF THAT TO NINETY NINE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET CUTS LAST YEAR.
IN PROVIDING THAT I KNOW.
SEVENTY FOUR FOUR DOLLAR TO OUR-
THAT'S GOING TO HELP ELIMINATE
OUR EQUITY GAPS THROUGH.
CONNECTED TWENTY TWENTY. IT'S
GOING ADDRESS OTHER MANY
BECAUSE INCREASE LIKE. I.
HEALTH COSTING. SO THAT ALL
THREE OF. ELEMENTS THE REST
GRANT AND- IN METRO COSTS. ARE
ARE. CHARTER OUR BUDGET. AND
THE- SO FAR HAS HAS BEEN
SUPPORTED. SIGNIFICANTLY THAT.
IT'S GONNA EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS WHILE ADDRESSING
OUR EQUITY GAPS WE JUST SPOKE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. IT'S
GOING TO INVEST IN ENHANCING
CLIMATE RESILIENCE RESEARCH AND
REVITALIZED THAT IN NORTHERN
NORTH COAST ECONOMY. MY THIRD-
ELEMENT I WANTED TO TOUCH
BRIEFLY ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NOW YOUR MEMBERS ARE BUDGET
REQUEST INCLUDED- I REQUEST FOR
RECURRING FUNDING. FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND CAPITAL NEEDS OF
UNIVERSITY. AND THIS SPRING
BECAUSE OF THE- THE AMOUNT OF
ONE TIME FUNDING THAT WE SAW
COMING AVAILABLE. WE SHIFTED TO
A APPROACH OF REQUESTING A ONE
TIME FUNDING WHICH WE THINK
WOULD BE A MUCH MUCH MORE-
ACHIEVABLE. THE WAY THAT THE
STATE IS LINED UP. SO FIRST WE
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
HIS PROPOSAL- GET BOTH TO YOU
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS TO
ADDRESS ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
BUT WE ALSO WERE GONNA URGE YOU
AS LEGISLATOR ADDED ADDITIONAL
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION WE'VE
THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM. FROM
THE CSU ALL SPRING HERE. OF
ADDITIONAL NEEDS THAT WE THINK
THAT THE STATE. WOULD BE. WE
THINK WOULD BE A GOOD
INVESTMENT IN THE IN THE
UNIVERSITY. WHAT THAT'LL DO IS
THAT'LL HELP US ELIMINATE A BIG
CHUNKS OF OUR BACKLOG OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
WILL ALSO HELP WITH
ENROLLMENTS- SOME OF OUR
HOUSING NEEDS OWNERS CAMPUSES
AS WELL AS AIR RECIRCULATION
UPGRADES AS WE KNOW FROM COVE
IT. AND SOME OTHER VITAL
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE SO THAT'S
THE THAT TO TALLY OF MY OPENING
COMMENTS IN A- BIG WAY THROUGH
THE CSU DISCUSSION. OKAY THANK
YOU. THE OPEN UP TO FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. I ASKED
EARLIER- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BEFORE YOU GOT ON THERE
RYAN- WHERE WE'RE GIVING YOU A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS AND GO AND SAY A BLANK
CHECK WITHOUT ANY TARGET FOR
ENROLLMENT AT SAID THAT CONCERN
FOR US JUST LIKE I TOLD. YOU
SEE EARLIER TODAY SO- WHAT'S
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT YOU THESE
ARE YOUR PRIORITIES BUT THEY
DON'T REFLECT OUR PRIORITIES
THAT WE HEAR. AND GRANTED
YOU'RE YOU SAY YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THE EXISTING STUDENTS
HAVE A GOOD EXPERIENCE AT THE
CSU. BUT RIGHT WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE YOU KNOW
LITTLE BROTHER AND SISTER. AND
COUSINS AND NEIGHBORS AND
LITTLE LEAGUE TEAMMATES SINCE
HIGH SCHOOL CLASSMATES GET
INTO. SO HOW ARE GOING TO HELP
THEM. ALL RIGHT WELL WELL FIRST
AND FOREMOST- IF YOU LOOK AT
OUR BUDGET REQUEST THAT WE'VE
BEEN SHARING SINCE LAST FALL.
REALLY THE FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENT
OF THIS IS THE GRANT INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. NOW THE
REAL KEY HERE IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR CURRENT
STUDENTS- CAN IF THEY CHOOSE TO
TAKE FIFTEEN UNITS- TERM- IT'S
GONNA REQUIRE A LONG TERM
INVESTMENT. THAT WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO INVEST D. D. THE LATEST
TRANCHE IN THE CURRENT YEAR
REMEMBER BACK LAST YEAR. IN IN
ADVANCE OF THE OF THE KOBE
BUDGET THERE IS A DECIDED A
DECISION TO REDUCE THE
UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO INVEST BRANDING
FUNDING. IN GRAD OF
THEIR- SO WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS
DOING WITH THIS SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IS ALLOWING US TO
COVER FIRST THOSE MANDATORY
COSTS AND THEN FULLY FINE
GRADUATION SHOULD. THAT'S GONNA
ALLOW US TO MAKE UP FOR LAST
YEAR THAN INVEST FOR THE NEXT
YEAR. SO THAT CAN ALLOW MORE
STUDENTS TO TAKE MORE COURSES
THAT THEY CAN GRADUATING MORE
TIME THE WA THERE'S GOING TO
BE A BETTER THROUGHPUT. WHICH
WILL CREATE MORE NATURAL ROOM
SO TO SPEAK. BUT I WILL ECHO
THE- COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM YOU SEE SAY OVER TEN AND-
AND SAY THAT ABOUT THE BEYOND
THAT IS WHEN WE TALK WHEN WE
WHEN WE CAN TALK ABOUT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. NOW IN OUR
CASE. THAT STATE WOULD NEED TO
ADD ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS. PER STUDENT.
IN ORDER TO GROW ENROLLMENT.
AND WE THINK FOUNDED
FOUNDATIONAL A WE NEED TO
INVEST FULLY IN THE GRADUATION
AND SHIP AND IT'S NOT ONLY JUST
FOR BEDFORD BETTER THROUGHPUT.
BUT IT'S ADDITIONAL- SUPPORT IN
ORDER TO ELIMINATE THOSE EQUITY
GAPS THAT HAVE BANNED AT ALL OF
ARE. AT THE FOREFRONT OF ALL OF
OUR MINDS. SO I THINK YOU GOT
IT. I THINK FUNDED
FUNDAMENTALLY YOU HAVE TO
SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY AND THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE WHICH IS ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS. AND IF YOU
HAVE ADDITIONAL MONEY TO ADD ON
TOP OF THAT. WE AGREED THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GROW AND
ROLLED. WE HAVE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES WE HAVE A LOT OF
CAPACITY PHYSICAL CAPACITY THAT
WE CAN STILL FILL WITH
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS THAT THE
HARD PART IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES IN ORDER TO HIRE
THOSE FACULTY IN THE SUPPORT.
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO DO MORE. I
KNOW THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE A
SATISFACTORY ANSWER FOR YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FROM
THE FROM THE VANTAGE POINT OF
WHY DON'T WE JUST GET OUT OF
THERE. BUT WORK WORK WE'RE
STAYING TRIED AND TRUE WITH OUR
BUDGET REQUEST THAT WAS ADOPTED
BY THE BOARD. AS AND GET AS A
CHANCER HAS PURSUED AND AS AS
EXPRESSED ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
ARE OUR HIGHEST PARTIES THE
GRADUATION AND SHIP. THEN ABOVE
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT WE CAN GO
TO ENROLLMENT GROWTH. YEAH AND
THE AND THAT LEADS TO MY OTHER
QUESTION SO. WE DON'T HAVE-
FULLY FUNDING FOR THE.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE HERE
CORRECT. BUT WE DO HAVE A- WE
DO HAVE IT BUT YOU HAVE. IN THE-
IN THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
IS OUR ABILITY TO FULLY FUND
THE GRADUATION SHOULD. SO IF
YOU TAKE HIM OUT THAT WAS
PROPOSED IN JANUARY ADDED THE
SEVENTY FOUR POINT FOUR THAT IS
PROPOSED TO BE REVISION. WE
CAN'T FULLY FUND THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. OKAY IF THERE'S
ANYTHING LESS THAN THAT WE
CAN'T DO IT. GOTCHA SO WHAT WE
HAVE IN THE MAY REVISE ALLOWS
YOU TO FULLY IMPLEMENT. THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE AND-
THAT'S- NOT AYE AS YOU KNOW I.
WE BOTH WOULD SAY THAT IF YOU
WANT TO EXPAND. ENROLLMENT
SLOTS. BESIDES FUNDING IN ROMAN
MORE SLEEP AND MORE SLOTS THAT
THAT THE OTHER THING THAT. YOU
COULD DO AND MAYBE YOUR BIGGER
BANG FOR YOUR BUCK IS TO. HELP
THE EXISTING FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CSU STUDENTS.
GRADUATE WITHIN FOUR YEARS OR
FOUR PLUS AND NOT. LINGER. FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS AFTER- SO EVERY
ELSE THAT WERE PUT HERE FOR
POLY TAC IN NORTHRIDGE AND ALL
THIS OTHER STUFF IS. IS GOOD
FOR HIGHER ED BUT IF WE REALLY
WANT TO ADDRESS THE KEY ISSUE.
AND HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESS
AND- AND FRANKLY WE LOCKED LOOK
AT AFFORDABILITY LOOK AT THE
DEBT CRISIS WHICH WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT LATER WOULD STILL
NEED COMMISSION. THE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE IS THAT IS THAT
IS THE NUMBER ONE YOU KNOW.
LINK BETWEEN THOSE TWO THINGS.
OKAY THAT'S IT FOR NOW
QUESTIONS MISTER- O'DONNELL BY
A DENTIST AND MEDINA. THANK
YOU- AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
WAS BROACHED I WAS OUT OF THE
ROOM FOR A MOMENT AGO. UP IN
CLASS INSTRUCTION IN CLASS.
CLASSES ARE ON A LABEL IT. BACK
AT THE CAMPUS NOT ONLINE THAT'S
THE PLAN FOR NEXT YEAR IS THAT
ACCURATE. THAT'S GENERALLY THE
PLAN RIGHT- OBVIOUSLY I THINK
LIKE ALL OF US IN ALL OF OUR
RESPECTIVE CAPACITIES IT'S ALL
GONNA DEPEND ON HOW THE DISEASE
PROGRESSES GOING FORWARD. AS OF
RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS LIKE
EVERYTHING IS LOOKING GOOD SO-
I WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CAUTIOUSLY MOVING TOWARDS
OPENING MORE AND MORE COURSE
SECTIONS IN PERSON AS WE GO
FORWARD- AND- OBVIOUSLY THE
IDEA HERE IS. A LONGER TERM IS
TO BE ABLE TO DO A LITTLE BIT
OF BALANCING RIGHT. LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BUT ALSO OFFERING
COURSES THAT ARE HYBRIDS AND
MARK MORE COURSES THAT ARE ON
THAT ARE FULLY ONLINE. GIVES A
STUDENTS FAR MORE FLEXIBILITY
IN TERMS OF THEIR SCHEDULING
AND THEIR ABILITY TO MANAGE
WORK LIFE EXPERIENCES BUT YES I
THINK FOR THE UPCOMING FALL OUR
GOAL IS TO GET AS MANY COURSES
WE CAN'T FOR MINE. IT'S ALL
DEPEND ALSO ON ALL THE LOCAL
AND REGIONAL- REQUIREMENTS BY
LOCAL. HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AS
WELL. I AND I GET THE HOW
REQUIRE AND AGREE THAT THEY
NEED BE ACCOMMODATED. BUT I
DON'T I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
MYSELF AND FOR OTHERS IN THE
ROOM FEEL THE SAME THAT. A YOU
NEED TO MOVE BACK ON CAMPUS.
AND FALL IF THINGS KEEP GOING
IN THE DIRECTION THEY'RE GOING.
I WALK THROUGH LONG BEACH STATE
WHEN I'M HOME. JUST ABOUT EVERY
DAY. AND THE PRAISE THE PLACES
PRETTY DESOLATE THERE'S SOME
STUFF GOING ON THERE NOW. BUT
IT'S PRETTY DESOLATE IT'S A
LARGE CAMPUS WITH- A LOT OF
FACILITIES IN THEIR EMPTY IT'S
RATHER TRAGIC TO SEE AND I KNOW
YOU AGREE WITH ME. BUT AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT- WE
NEED TO GET STUDENTS BACK. TO
THE CAMPUS IN THE FALL IN THE
FALL. IF THINGS KEEP HEADING
THAT DIRECTION. THEY'RE
HEADING. AND ALSO ONE OTHER
TOPICS THE SHARK LAB LONG BEACH
STATE THAT'S INTERNATIONALLY
KNOWN ACTUALLY. LOCALLY FAMOUS
AS WELL- DR LAW THE SHARK LAB
SHARK WEEK HE'S ON THERE ALL
THE TIME- IT'S NOT ALWAYS FOR
ENTERTAINMENT PURPOSES QUITE
FRANKLY IT'S FOR SCIENCE
PURPOSES. THAT'S WHERE HE COMES
FROM- AND WHEN Y. ESPECIALLY
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A LOT MORE
SHARK ACTIVITY ALONG OUR SHORE.
WHEN I WAS A KID GOING OUT TO
THE BEACH IN LONG BEACH. WE
NEVER SAW A SEALED WE NEVER SAW
A DOLPHIN WE NEVER EVEN THOUGHT
OF A SHARK. NOW THERE ARE SEALS
NOW THERE ARE DOLPHINS AND
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SHARKS WHAT WE
HAVE TO CALL THE KIDS OUT OF
THE WATER. AND WHAT WE NEED TO
STUDY THOSE A DOCTOR LOW. OUT
OF THE SHARK LAB HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB OF THAT WE GOT AND WE
GOT AN ALLOCATION ABOUT FOUR
FIVE YEARS AGO. AND WHAT I'M
SEEKING TO DO THIS YEAR'S
CONTINUE- GETTING MONEY TO THE
SHARK LAB SO IT CAN CONTINUE.
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE SAFE
WATERS WE UNDERSTAND SHARK
BEHAVIOR. SHARKS ARE PART OF
OUR ECOSYSTEM IT ALSO SPEAKS TO
OUR ECONOMY TO. THE USE OF
PEOPLE START HEARING ABOUT
SHARK ALERTS ALONG OUR
SHORELINE. THAT COME GOING TO
COME TO OUR BEACHES TO VISIT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SPEND
MONEY IN SUPPORT THE TOWNS.
ALONG THE BEACHES AND WE NEED
THAT TO HAPPEN. SO I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT. THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE SHARK LAB. TO CALIFORNIA
YES THE WORLD BUT REALLY
CALIFORNIA FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
AND THAT THEY'RE DOING REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK THERE ARE
CUTTING EDGE WORK. HOW THE HOW
THEY IDENTIFY WHEN SHARKS ARE
COMING NEAR THE WATER. AND
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT CAN ALERT US SO THAT WE.
CAN- YOUR PARTNER OKAY. YOU'RE
RIGHT- IN IN AND SHE THAT OUR
WILL SOURCE. WE DON'T TO SCAN
THE OLD THE SEVENTIES WHAT
KILLED. THAT WAS THE ANSWER
THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER ANYMORE.
AND DR LOWE WITH HIS EDUCATION.
IS OPPORTUNITIES CRITICAL SHARK
LOVER MAKING THAT HAPPEN SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU SO MEMBER
BY IT OUT OF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE KEEPS ON SAYING THAT
THEY'RE OPEN TO AN OF THE AROMA
CONVERSATION- BUT THEY ALSO
PREVIOUSLY INDICATED THAT THEIR
PLANNING A NEW. COMPACT
AGREEMENT CONVERSATION- WITH
THE SEGMENTS POSSIBLY FOR THE
FALL SO THE TIMING DOESN'T
REALLY WORK WELL FOR THE BUDGET
SO CAN YOU JUST PROVIDE SOME
CLARITY ON YOUR TIMELINE.
BUDGET PROCESS YOU KNOW. THE I
JUST THINK WE NEED MORE CLARITY
HERE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND GENEROUSLY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS MY
COLLEAGUE HAD MENTIONED AND-
THE CONVERSATIONS ARE- GOING TO
BE ENGAGING WITH- THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ND
CSU. AND AND SO IT WILL BE. A
CONCURRENTLY AS WE MOVE FOR
WITH THE WITH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. SO THEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS SHOULD BE
HAPPENING. ARE THEY HAPPENING
NOW. I WILL DEFER TO MY AND MY-
I WILL DEFERRED AND MANAGEMENT
ON A SPECIFIC DETAILS BUT I DO
KNOW THAT- IN ORDER TO
NECESSITATE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- WE WILL
DEFINITELY AT NEED TO HAVE-
CERTIFICATION WITH THE UNIVERSE
OF CALIFORNIANS YES YOU. GOT
STILL MIGHT A SECOND QUESTION
HERE- IS ACTUALLY ON THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
A NATIONAL HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTION. H. ASIDE. EQUITY
INNOVATION HUB THAT CSU
NORTHRIDGE MY ALMA MATER.
ACCORDING TO SEE THROUGH THE
FACILITY WILL BUILD UPON THE
FOUNDATIONAL WORK OF SEASONS
COLLEGE OF ENGINEERING AND
COMPUTER SCIENCE. ON THE
CENTERS FOR POSSIBILITIES
PROJECT THE FACILITY FACILITY
WILL PROVIDE A CUTTING EDGE
RESEARCH AND COLLABORATIVE
LEARNING AND SERVE AS A HUB. TO
BRINGING THE COMMUNITY AND P.
K. FOURTEEN. PARTNERS TOGETHER
TO FACILITATE NEW EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS IT'S SLATED TO OPEN
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS
INVESTMENT WOULD ACCELERATE THE
CAMPUS IS ABILITY TO ADDRESS
PERSISTENT GAPS AND DEGREE.
ATTAINMENT AND DIVERSE
REPRESENTATION IN STEM CAREERS
AND- I'M HOPING IT'S ALSO STEAM
CAREERS BECAUSE- IN HOLLYWOOD
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IS A BIG
FIELD IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-
AND THAT THE FULL CAPACITY. THE
HUBBLE SERVICE A NATIONAL MODEL
FOR ACCELERATING STUDENTS
SUCCESS FOR DIVERSE LEARNERS
AND HSI'S ACROSS THE NATION AS
I MENTIONED I THINK IT'S YOU
KNOW WHOLLY APPROPRIATE AND
EXCITING. BUT I AM A LITTLE
CURIOUS AS TO WHY- GIVEN THAT
SEASON'S WORK ON THE CENTER FOR
POSSIBILITIES PROJECT OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS. WHY A THIS PART
IDENTIFY AND THE CSU FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- I WITH THE
SEC THE CSU NORTHRIDGE THEM
EQUITY CENTER IS- CAPEN CAMPUS
REQUEST- AND- AND SO THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THEM AS
IT IS A REQUEST FROM THE FROM
THE CAMPUS- WE CONCUR THAT THE
CAMPUS IS WELL POSITIONED TO
HOUSE THE EQUITY CENTER AND- IN
AND SPPORT AND MENTOR
UNDERGRADS INTO THE SAME FIELD.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
FURTHER NOTES THAT NORTHRIDGE
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH A PRIVATE
INVESTOR ON THIS PROPOSAL AND
HAS A SOFT COMMITMENT FOR
OPERATIONAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT
THE PROJECT AS WELL AS
SIMILARLY A WEST COAST HAVE
SIMILAR. TO THE ATLANTA PROPEL
CENTER. GREAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR MEDINA THANK
YOU SO I HAVE A TWO QUESTIONS
TO CSU THE FIRST WIND PICKS UP
WHERE MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH- LEFT OFF I MET A COUPLE
WEEKENDS AGO WITH THE
CONSTITUENTS. OF MOTHER AND
FATHER WHO HAVE A STUDENT AT AT
CAL STATE LONG BEACH SHE'S A
FRESHMAN THERE- AND HAS LIVED
IN THE DORMS ALL YEAR LONG EVEN
WHILE CLASSES HAVE BEEN ONLINE-
AND RELATIVELY OUT OF A GOOD
EXPERIENCE THIS PAST YEAR. BUT
WHEN SHE WENT TO REGISTER FOR
CLASSES FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR
FOR THE NEXT TERM. SHE SHE
FOUND THAT FOR CLASSES FOR THE
NEXT TERM WOULD BE AGAIN ONLINE.
SO HERE SHE IS SECOND. YEAR
STUDENT AT CAL STATE LONG BEACH%
AND SHE HAD THIS. TO FIND EVEN
ONE CLASS- THAT WAS GOING TO
MEET IN PERSON AND SO THE- YOU
KNOW THEIR CONCERN THEY HAVE A
NO STUDENT- OUT AS- AND WAS
ABLE AT- NORTHERN ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY TO CONTINUE THE
WHOLE YEAR- IN PERSON. SO I
STRONGLY CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LONG BEACH I
WANT TO URGE. CSU TO PROVIDE AS
MANY CLASSES AS THEY CAN IN
PERSON- NOW WE'RE GOING INTO
THE SECOND HERE. AND I THINK
THAT STUDENTS WOULD BE GREATLY
SHORT CHANGED IS THERE A
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE- WAS NOT
MORE IN PERSON I THINK THAT WE
KNOW AS I KNOW. AS AN EDUCATOR.
THAT WHAT HAPPENS IN COLLEGE IN
THE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE IS NOT
JUST WHAT HAPPENS IN CLASS AND
CERTAINLY WHAT HAPPENS IN CLASS
WHEN IT'S ONLINE IS MUCH
DIFFERENT. FROM IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BUT ALSO THE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO MIX. AND EXCHANGE IDEAS-
WHETHER IT BE ON CAMPUS OR IN
THEIR DORMS. AND SO VERY MUCH
WANT TO- URGE. CSU TO OFFER AS
MANY CLASSES- IN THE NEXT TERM-
IN PERSON. AND HOPE THAT WE CAN
SEE THAT- NEXT YEAR AND THEN
CERTAINLY ALL OF OUR-
CONSTITUENTS. IN OURSELVES WILL
BE BE WATCHING. OKAY THANK ANY
ADVICE QUESTION- TO CSU. WE SAW
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR SIGNED-
LEGISLATION A DOCTOR WEBER IS
BILL TO- MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT FOR GRADUATION- I
BELIEVE IT'S ALREADY BEING
IMPLEMENTED OR WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED- FOR GRADUATION AND
THEN THE NEXT NEXT TERM SO MY
QUESTION TO CSU IS THERE
FUNDING- IS THERE FUNDING OR
THE BEEN REQUEST FOR FUNDING-
TO- COVER THE COST OF OFFERING
THOSE CLASSES. TO CSU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA- ALL ALL TALK
ABOUT BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES
ABOUT REAL QUICKLY IN TERMS OF
THE SPECIFICS ON THE LONG BEACH
SITUATION I WOULD HAVE TO. TALK
TO THE CAMPUS A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT- MY SUSPICION THOUGH
IS A LOT LIKE WHERE WE
ABANDONED ALL OF US IN OUR
RESPECTIVE LIVES WHERE PLANNING
IS FOR ONE THING AND WHAT
MATERIALIZES IS A DIFFERENT
THING THAT THAT HAPPENS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN MY OWN PERSONAL LIFE
I HAVE KIDS THAT STARTED THE
WHOLE YEAR FULLY ONLINE AND AS
AS THINGS. LOOSENED UP. TO
ATTEND IN PERSON RIGHT. SO I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT THIS
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE OF
REGISTERING AND FINDING ONLY
FOR COURSES OR OR OR THREE
WHATEVER THE NUMBER WAS. BEING
FULLY ONLINE I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT WITH THE URGENCY OF ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES WHITES AND RE OPEN
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST. FOR THE
STATE EXPERIENCE BUT FACULTY
AND STAFF I WANT TO RETURN AS
WELL AS SOON AS WE CAN. BUT I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT THOSE THOSE
COURSES WELL SOME OF THEM WILL
BE THEN CONVERTED AND BECOME-
IN PERSON. AS TIME PERMITS AS
WE GET CLOSER TO THE FALL AND
THINGS LOOK LIKE THEY CAN BE
MORE OPEN AND THAT SORT OF
THING SO I WOULD THINK THAT. AS
TRENDS ARE GOING RIGHT NOW I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT. DISTANCE
EXPERIENCE MAY BE THAT YOU KNOW
WATER TO THOSE CLASSES MAY
ULTIMATELY BE. UP OUT IN PERSON
BUT- BUT- I CAN MAKING
INSURANCE ABOUT THAT BUT I
WOULD THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
TREND THAT WE'RE HEADING DOWN
TOWARDS. AND OF COURSE I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT BEING
FULLY ONLINE I'D RATHER BE IN
THE BUILDING WITH YOU TALKING
AS WELL RATHER THAN OVER THIS
AND NOT HAVING MY MIKE WORKING
WELL. SO IT YES I THINK THAT'S
EVERYBODY'S ANGLE HERE IS TO
TRY TO BE BACK IN PERSON SUCH
AS POSSIBLE. ON THE IN THE
TERMS OF ETHNIC STUDIES- WHAT
WE DID IN OUR FALL REQUEST AS
WE INCORPORATED- SIXTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE
COST OF FULLY IMPLEMENTING
ETHNIC STUDIES. INTO OUR
MANDATORY COST CATEGORY OF
FUNDING. AND BY THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSING IN JANUARY. THE ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR GENERAL
OPERATING COSTS FOR UNIVERSITY.
OUR FIRST CALL ABOUT MONEY ARE
MANDATORY COSTS AND SO THAT'S A
LONG WAY BASICALLY SAYING. IF
THIS PROPOSAL HOLDS IT WE HAVE
THIS TYPE OF DISCRETION PEOPLE
USE THAT MONEY WE WILL BE FULLY
FUNDING THE ETHNIC STUDIES.
REQUIREMENT IN GETTING THAT
FUNDING OUT TO CAMPUSES SO THEY
CAN. IMPLEMENT THAT ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THERE WAS
SOME TALK ABOUT HUMBOLDT I
DON'T BLAME THEM FOR WANTING TO
BE AT AT POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY- CAL POLY POMONA ONE
OF OUR PREMIER UNIVERSITIES-
HERE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF WHAT THEY'VE DONE
ONE OF THE PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
USER TRANSFER PROGRAM. FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING TO THE CSU'S IN
THIS DISCRETIONARY FUNDING THE
BASE AUGMENTATION IS THERE A
PLAN TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
THAT IS BEING USED FOR THE
TRANSFER PROGRAM. JENNIFER YOU
LOOK LIKE YOU WANTED SPEECH BUT
I CAN I CAN I CAN TAKE THE
FIRST CRACK IF YOU LIKE- BUT
BUT BASICALLY I WOULD SAY. YOU
KNOW OUR OUR BUDGET REQUEST AND
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
FUNDING IS NOT FOR NEW
ENROLLMENT SO EVERY YEAR- WHAT
WE DO THOUGH IS WE HAVE A
BALLOTS WE HAVE BEEN ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS TO THE UNIVERSITY
ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND OF OUR NEW
ENROLLEES EVERY YEAR OUR
TRANSFERS. AND ART AND THE
TREND THAT WE HAVE BEEN SEEING
SINCE THE ORIGIN OF THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
IS THAT MORE AND MORE OF OUR
EIGHTY STUDENTS MORE AND MORE
OF OUR TRANSFER STUDENTS ARE AT
T. STUDENTS I BELIEVE ABOUT
HALF OF OUR TRANSFER STUDENTS
AT THIS POINT ARE AT T.
STUDENTS. SO I WOULD SAY FROM
THAT VANTAGE POINT- THAT FROM
YOUR QUESTION NO THERE'S NO NEW
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL
TRANSFERS AND LAST YOU DECIDE
AS THE ASSEMBLY AND THE AND THE
SENATE AND THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO COME TOGETHER AND
ADD TO WHAT ROLE- THERE'S NO
NEW FUNDING DEDICATED FOR MORE
TRANSFERS AT THIS POINT IF YOU
GROWING ROLE THAT- WE WILL
OBVIOUSLY ABOUT HALF OF THOSE
STUDENTS WILL BE COMING IN AS
TRANSFERRED TO THE WILL BE ABLE
TO ENROLL. ADDITIONAL TRANSFER
STUDENTS BUT IN TERMS OF WHERE
WE ARE TRANSFERS I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE VERY HAPPY WITH THE TO DO
WITH THE DIRECTION WHICH THINGS
ARE GOING- SPECIALLY WITH THE
FACT THAT SO MANY STUDENTS ARE
PREPARING WITH TWO YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE ONLY A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES COMING TO OUR
INSTITUTION WITH TWO YEARS-
ROUGHLY PLAN TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE SO WE'RE REALLY HAPPY
WITH THIS FACT THAT STUDENTS
THAT WE ARE RECEIVING STUDENTS
AT THE SCENE ISSUE. THAT ARE-
CREDIT READY TO BE ABLE. TO
COMPLETE IN TWO YEARS IF THEY
SO CHOOSE. WONDERFUL A IT BUT
ANOTHER ONE OF CAN- CO SAMBAR
DINO- I THINK THAT THEY- AGAIN
GOING BACK TO INCREASING A
MOMENT LOOKING AT EQUITY-
SPECIFICALLY. THE ENROLLMENT
AND AGAIN VERY INTENTIONAL
ABOUT INCREASING. MINORITY
STUDENT ENROLLMENT. I'M VERY
PROUD OF ALL THE WORK THAT THEY
DO IT CAL STATE SAMPOERNA DINO.%
IN IN IN BEING SO INTENTIONAL
ABOUT BRINGING IN A SPECIALLY
OUR STUDENTS. FROM THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. SO MY
QUESTION AND IT GOES BACK TO
WHAT WAS ASKED EARLIER THE
CHAIR ASKED ABOUT THIS- WITH
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND NO.
NO NO NO ONE MOMENT TARGET.
WHAT IS IT THAT CSU NEEDS TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT AND OF
COURSE IT'S GOING TO BE MONEY
WHAT SPECIFICALLY WHAT IS IT
THAT YOU NEED IN ORDER TO DO
THIS AND HOW WOULD YOU WHAT IS
IT THAT YOU NEED AND HOW WOULD
YOU THEN- INCREASE ENROLLMENT.
THE QUESTION WELL- I WOULD SAY
WE DON'T NEED ANYTHING OTHER
THAN FUNDING- WE HAVE CAPACITY
ON ON OUR CAMPUSES TO BE ABLE
TO ACCOMMODATE PHYSICAL
CAPACITY TO ACCOMMODATE-
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS SO WE HAVE
THE LAB SPACES WE HAVE THE
LECTURE HALLS WE HAVE THE
SMALLER CLASSROOMS WE CAN DO
THAT. WE ALSO IN TERMS OF
ENROLLMENT WE ALSO ARE LARGE
AND REFLECT THE CALIFORNIA-
DEMOGRAPHICS- WE HAVE A LARGE-
LET NEXT POPULATION THAT
REFLECTS THE POPULATION WRIT
LARGE ENOUGH OF YOUNGER
CALIFORNIANS SO IN TERMS OF THE
DIVERSITY AT THE UNIVERSITY I
THINK PREPARE. APART
PERSPECTIVE I THINK REALLY WHAT
IT BOILS DOWN TO IS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN OFFER
MORE SLOT SO TO SPEAK TO
STUDENTS ARE VARIOUS CAMPUSES.
I WILL SAY THAT- ON ON THE
ENROLLMENT. OF THINGS- THERE'S
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WE HAVE
GOING ARE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES. THERE'S A LOT OF
DEMAND AT THAT THERE. AND IN
SOME OF OUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES DEMAND HAS SOFTENED A
BIT. AND SO OUR PRIORITY WOULD
BE TO OBVIOUSLY PUT IN SLOTS TO
SPEAK TO THE PARTS OF THE STATE
WHERE. THERE IS GREAT DEMAND SO
YOU'RE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES WILL LIKELY BE THE-
RECIPIENT OF MORE OF THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IF YOU WERE
TO ADD ENROLLMENT AND THAT'S
SIMPLY BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
STUDENTS LIVE AND THAT'S WHERE
THEY WANT TO ATTEND. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE SEEING SOME OF OUR
CAMPUS IS BUSTING AT THE SEAMS.
I WILL SAY THERE ARE A COUPLE
THINGS YOU COULD DO ACTUALLY
FROM A FROM A- BUDGETARY
PERSPECTIVE FIRST IS. FUNDING
HAS TO BE RECURRING. IT CANNOT
BE ONE TIME FUNDING. RECURRING
REQUIRES US TO HIRE FACULTY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO COMMIT TO
FOR THIRTY YEARS OF THEIR
CAREER AND STAFF THAT WILL BE
WITH US FOR THE DURATION OF
THEIR CAREERS. THE OTHER THING
TOO IS THAT IF YOU WERE TO
PROVIDE US A LOT OF FUNDING FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. IN AN
BEGINNING JULY FIRST WE'VE
ALREADY MADE A LOT OF
ENROLLMENT DECISIONS. FOR THIS
FALL SO IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO MEET SOME SORT OF
ENROLLMENT EXPECTATIONS. IN THE
IMMEDIATE FISCAL YEAR THAT WERE
RECEIVING THE FUNDING FOR. WE
WILL OBVIOUSLY BE ABLE TO OFFER
MORE ENROLLMENT TO- TRANSFERS
IN SPRING AT CERTAIN CAMPUSES.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE- THE WAY YOU
SHOULD STRUCTURE IT AND IT'S
BEEN STRUCTURE LIKE THIS TO YOU
SEE WHEN IT WHEN YOU SEE A
PROCEDURAL GROWTH. IS CREATE AN
EXPECTATION FOR US TO BEAT THAT
NEW TARGET. FOR THE NEXT YEAR
FOR THE END OF THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE YEAR BUT ALLOWS US
TO BE ABLE TO. THOROUGHLY
RECRUIT FACULTY FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY IN ORDER TO EDUCATE OUR
STUDENTS THE BEST. THERE'S A
COUPLE OF OTHER ITEMS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO. PROBABLY TOUCH
ON BUT IT BETTER NOT BECAUSE
THAT TIME YOU'VE GOT YOUR ONLY
TWO ISSUES AND IF YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE TO MANY MORE TO GO SO
MAYBE I SHOULD STOP THERE. BUT
I HAVE A LONG LONG HOME PHONE.
THINGS THAT. TECHNICALLY WOULD
BE GOOD. YOU KNOW YOUR STAFF
FOR OUR- WELL AWARE OF THOSE
AND I CAN WORK WITH THEM IN
TERMS OF THAT. THAT MECHANICS
IN THE BUDGET. WE'LL LET YOU
FROM. I'M SORRY. SUMMARY MAYBE
JUST A FOLLOW UP ON HURT PER
QUESTION JUST REMIND US. IN SO
WE HAVE TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
SUMMER IMPACTED. HE SAID
EARLIER. LONG BEACH POLAR TEN
SAN DIEGO. SAN LUIS OBISPO I
THINK THOSE THE MAIN ONES. AND
HOW MANY STUDENTS AND IF YEARS
AGO WE SET A POLICY THAT IF YOU
APPLY TO THE CSU AND DONT GET
IN. THE AUTOMATICALLY GET
ACCEPTED TO ANOTHER CSU AND
IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN SOMEWHAT
SUCCESSFUL. HOW MANY STUDENTS
APPLY TO THE CSU. AND DON'T GET
IN TO A CAMPUS. RIGHT I THINK
THE REALLY IMPORTANT THING TO
NOTE WITH- WITH THAT ISSUE
ABOUT STUDENTS IS THAT THEY ARE
FOR THE THAT POPULATION WE'RE
pSTUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN BEEN
DEEMED CSU ELIGIBLE. TO THERE
LOTS OF PEOPLE WHO APPLY TO ANY
UNIVERSITY THAT OUR DON'T MEET
THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
RIGHT TO SET THOSE FOLKS
ASSIGNED OR NOT ADMISSIBLE TO
UNIVERSITY. SO THE SUPPORT
FOCUSED ON THOSE WHO ARE CSU
ELIGIBLE AND MAYBE THEY'VE
APPLIED AT SAN LUIS OBISPO ONLY
OR SAN DIEGO STATE- RIGHT WHICH
ARE VERY POPULAR CAMPUSES OF
OURS VERY DIFFICULT TO GET INTO
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST A LOT TO
ME RIGHT. SO WE SEE ISSUE HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED A REDIRECTION
POLICY BASED ON THE PRODDING OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE AND
THE GOVERNOR. TO DEVELOP A
REDIRECTION POLICY NOW BEFORE
THE REDIRECTION POLICY WE HAD
ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY TO THIRTY
THOUSAND CSU ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
THAT WOULD APPLY THAT COULD NOT
RECEIVE A SPOT AT THE
UNIVERSITY RIGHT TO HELP ME AND
MANY OF THEM LIKE I SAID
REPLYING TO MANY OF OUR OUR
VERY POPULAR CAMPUSES. SO WHAT
WE DO OFFER THEM THOSE TWENTY
TO THIRTY THOUSAND PER YEAR WE
OFFER THEM A SPOT AT A SECOND
OR THIRD OPTION UNIVERSITY WHAT
WE TYPICALLY DO IS EVERY YEAR
WE GO THROUGH AND WE SURVEY OUR
CAMPUSES AND LOOK AT THEIR LOOK
AT THEIR SITUATION ASK COULD
YOU TAKE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS.
ON YOUR CAMPUS- FOR EXAMPLE WE
WOULD DIRECT REDIRECT THEM TO
SOME OF OUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES ASSEMBLY CISCO STATE
CINEMA STATE ARE EXAMPLES OF
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE SOFTER
ENROLLMENT BUT WOULD BE OPEN TO
OFFERING MORE SPOTS ARE.
OFFERING STUDENTS A SPOT AT
THEIR UNIVERSITY NOW WE OFFER
STUDENTS TO MAKE A CHOICE ABOUT.
WHAT THEIR SECOND THIRD WOULD
BE. AND WE ALSO FOR OF THE
STUDENTS WE DENY ADMISSION TO.
WEEKS THE IF WE ENOUGH FROM
THEM WHATSOEVER JUST TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE A PLACE TO GO IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. OF FOR THE
MOST PART- WE END UP HAPPENING
AFTER AFTER ALL GETS DOWN TO
BOIL DOWN. OUR EXPERIENCE OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE
ABOUT BETWEEN SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHT HUNDRED STUDENTS ACTUALLY
TAKE US UP ON OUR OFFER. AND
THEY SAY OKAY I DO WANT TO GO
TO THAT OTHER C. ISSUE I
COULDN'T GET INTO SAN DIEGO BUT
I'LL GO OVER. AND I'LL GO
ATTEND CINEMA I'LL DO THAT. AND
THEY TAKE US UP ON THAT OFFER.
THE OTHER THING- I'LL POINT
OUT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY IS
THAT. WHEN WE LOOK AT THE-
WHERE STUDENTS APPLIED. AND
BEEN DECIDED NOT TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO US. IT'S OFTEN
STUDENTS THAT HAVE APPLIED ONLY
TO SLOW. OR ONLY THE SAN DIEGO
BUT THEY'VE ALSO APPLIED TO A
NUMBER OF C. ISSUE ARE UC'S.
WHERE THEY'VE APPLIED TO OTHER
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS AND OPTED
TO GO TO THOSE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN ADMITTED THERE. SO THE BOY
AT THE BOTTOM LINE ON
REDIRECTION IS THAT ANYWHERE
BETWEEN SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHT
HUNDRED STUDENTS ARE TAKING US-UP ON OUR OFFER. AND WE OFFER A
SPOTTED EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE CSU ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
THAT IS DENIED IF THEIR FIRST
CHOICE CAMPUS. SO THE
CHALLENGES REALLY EITHER
EXPANDING ACCESS TO THE COVETED
CAMPUSES SIMILAR TO WHAT. WE
SEE AT UC. OR TO MAKE THE OTHER
CAMPUSES. MARKUP IT LIKE YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND HUMBOLDT OR-
IN SOME THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CSU SO. THAT'S RIGHT OKAY I
THINK WE WENT AROUND AROUND ON
THIS SO- THIS IS STILL A
PRIORITY FOR US TO HAVE SOME
SOME TYPE OF ENROLLMENT TARGET
FOR THE QUESTIONS ON CSU AB
SINGH NINE WILL HOLD THESE
ISSUES OPEN AND- PROCEED NOW
WITH OUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HELLO DAN HAD OR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO I
PLAN TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROPOSALS FOR THE MAYOR VISION
AND THEN IT HAPPENED ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE- THAT A
HIGH LEVEL ACROSS THE THREE
YEAR BUDGET WINDOW THE MAY
REVISION REFLECTS JUST OVER ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION. IN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNDER THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THESE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS. ARE PROPOSED
TO HELP COLLEGES WHETHER THE
EFFECT OF CARBON- THE CO. AND
DEMOCRATS. OPERATIVE TO CUT TO
THE TRANSPORT. AND SUPPORT THE
LAW TERM. STABILITY THE CALLER.
FOR STARTERS THE MAYOR BILL
MAINTAIN OR SO. ON VESNA
PROPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR BUDGET-
INTO THAN THEIR VISION CLOSER
TO OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT WORKING
IN COLLEGE UP ON. FOR POINT
ZERO FIVE OR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WHICH THAT OF ONE
EIGHTY POINT FOUR MILLION FROM
THE GUY BUDGET I HAVE. ONE
POINT 5% THIS REPORT TO BETTER
THE COMBAT CALLED A STATURE ONE
SEVEN. FOR TWENTY TWO ONE
TWENTY. AND FOUR GONE TWO POINT
3% FROM. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES TO REMOVE
ENTIRE PORTION OF TO FOR ALL
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE ABOUT YOUR ABOUT YOUR
CLOTHES FONG COLA- DEFERRAL.
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FURTHER THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TO SPEED UP THE
REPAYMENT OF APPORTIONMENT
DEFERRALS. TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THE CAR YOU'RE ABOUT YOUR-
TO FOR ALL. THAT THEIR DAMAGE
OCCURRED BETWEEN JULY AND
AUGUST AS OPPOSED TO FROM JULY
TO NOVEMBER. TO FURTHER HELP
COLLEGES WITH THEIR ON GOING
BATES FUNDING IN THEIR VISION
PROPOSED ONE MILLION ONE TIME
PER. AND I'M GONNA TRY. SIMILAR
TO THE TWENTY MILLION ENACTED
IN THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE. TO
ADDRESS ENROLLMENT DECLINES
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. ONE OF THE KEEPING THAT
THIS BUDGET IS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME TO
SUPPORT DURATEC BECONTREE
GREASE. AND OPEN EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES. IT'S PROBABLY
UTILIZE THIS FIFTEEN MILLION
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED AND- FOR
YOUR TECH BECOMES DEGREES. AT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS
MONEY WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF DEGREE
PROGRAMS THAT ELIMINATE OR OF
THE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
COST OF TEXTBOOKS FOR STUDENTS
THAT THE UTILIZATION OF OUR WE
ARE. THE FIVE NINE PROVIDE
FUNDING PROVIDED THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUDGET FACT- FOR THE TT
HELP PRODUCE. FORTY TWO MILLION
IN CONFIDENCE STUDENTS SHOWING
THE POTENTIAL THAT THIS
INVESTMENT. CAN HELP FOR
STUDENTS- I YOU KNOW THERE ARE
A LOT BOTH. IN THIS BUDGET FOR
COMMUNITY. I WILL NOT THE HEART
VOCAL BUT HER NEW BUT AMERICA'S.
BETTER FUNDED BY PROPERTY
NINETY GENERAL FUND ON THE
STATE OTHERWISE- THE INCLUDES
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
FOR TWO ONE MOMENT CENTERS.
CARE COVERAGE THE ESTABLISHMENT
EXPANSION OF CECAFA CRIMMINS
CAN COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION ONE
TIME TO FOR THE SUPPORT COLLEGE
EFFORTS TO IMPLEMENT GUIDED
PATHWAYS PROGRAMS. FIFTY
MILLION TO EXPAND VOCATIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE
OPPORTUNITY AND ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE PROGRAMS- THAT
ARE LINKED TO CREDIT PROGRAM
PATHWAYS FOR ESL STUDENTS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIRTY
MILLION ON GOING TO ESTABLISH
BASIC NEEDS CENTER AND HIGHER
BASIC NEEDS COORDINATORS AT
EACH COLLEGE. FIFTY NINE ONE
TIME TO SUPPORT GRANTS ASSIST
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH
RESPONDING TO THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
TRANSITIONING BACK TO THEM
PERSONAGENS. FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION A ONE
TIME- FUNDING TO ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS OF
WHICH TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
IT'S FROM THE- THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT CAPITAL
PROJECTS FUND AND THEIR MAKERS
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
5% INCREASES FOR THE TWO
LARGEST. PROGRAM THE STUDENT
EQUITY IN TREATMENT PROGRAMS
AND A STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
THOSETOTAL ABOUT THIRTY SIX
POINT TWO MILLION ONGOING. THE
MILLION ONE TIME TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF YOUR BEST
PRACTICES. FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
CHAMBER RESOURCE BASED ON- THEY
ARE EXPECTATIONS AT THIS MOMENT
EXISTING FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
WHAT OFFER A FULL TIME POSITION
AT EACH COLLEGE. TEN MILLION
ONE TIME DEPRIVED
IMPLEMENTATION OF COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION PUBLIC
COMMUNICATIONS. TEN MILLION FOR
THE IMPLANT I'M GOING TO THE-
SYSTEM WIDE ACQUISITION OF
SOFTWARE THAT DIGITALISING
CLEARLY MAPS OUT QUICKER
PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS. TEN
MILLION ONE TIME TO PLAN FOR
BEGIN DEVELOPING A COMMON
COURSE NUMBER EXISTING THREAT
THAT THE AFTER THE
COMMUNICATIVE. FOUR MILLION
SUPPORT SYSTEM WIDE TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM FOR LIBRARY SERVICES.
ONE MILLION THAT SUPPORT THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE T. V.
REGISTRY AND A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT OF ONE POINT 7% OF
THE BUDGET YEAR STATUTORY
COOPER PROGRAMS THAT
HISTORICALLY RECEIVED ACOSTA
MANAGEMENT. THAT THE MARRIAGE
ALSO INCLUDES TWO PROPOSALS
COMPRISING THIRTY MILLION AND
WHAT THE NEW ONE TIME
INVESTMENT DESIGNED TO BETTER
ALIGN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THEIR WORKFORCE PARTNERS.
OUT THERE THAT IS YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD- WE'LL SEE FUNDS DIRECTLY
GOING TO SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS A RESULT OF THE
STATE OF CORPORATION PLANET- I
DON'T I DON'T THE PLAN NUMBER
BUT- I BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
ABOUT SIXTEEN BILLION WITH.
HALF GOING TO TAXPAYERS AND%
HALF GOING TO SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES I WITH THAT THANK YOU
TO BE ABLE I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AFTER MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO PRESENT OKAY
THANK YOU L. L. THANK YOU
DIDN'T. POLICY NOW AND THE-
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I'LL THE
CATCH ON A FEW OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES IN TERMS OF DOLLAR
AMOUNTS IN THE DECISIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE- OVER THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS FIRST WE SEE IT AS A
POSITIVE- IN MAY REVISE THE
PROPOSAL TO RETIRE ALL THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DEFERRALS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE PROVE THAT. OUR
MESSAGE ON FUNDING TO ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
VERY SIMILAR TO THE MESSAGE
THAT YOU JUST HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE UNIVERSITIES
BUDGETS. WE THINK IT HAS A
PARENT AND WE RECOMMEND THAT
YOU TREAT THEM A REVISED
PROPOSALS. ARE THOSE UNDING
LEVELS AS A MINIMUM GIVEN THE
SIZE OF THE COLLEGES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG WHICH IS
WELL OVER. ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD FREE UP
FUNDS TO ADDRESS EVEN MORE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. OR OTHER
COST PRESSURES THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE FACING SUCH AS
PENSIONS BY REJECTING THOSE
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DEEMS UNJUSTIFIED
OR OTHERWISE LOWER PRIORITY. WE
IDENTIFIED- SOME OF THOSE
PROPOSALS WE THINK ARE GOOD
CANDIDATES- AT THE FEBRUARY
HEARINGS ON JANUARY PROPOSALS
AND WE'VE SHARED WITH STAFF
OTHER WHAT WE THINK ARE GOOD
CANDIDATES FOR REJECTION BY THE
LEGISLATURE REDIRECTION OF THE
MONEY. WE SURE THAT WAS STAFF
AND I'M HAPPY TO DISCUSS IT
KERN HEARING IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS. IN TERMS OF ON GOING
SPENDING THE LARGEST PROPOSAL
COVERS THAT 4% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
APPORTIONMENT. AND WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
THAT'LL HELP THE COLLEGES
ADDRESS RISING SALARY BENEFITS
OTHER COST PRESSURES. THE MAY
REVISE PROVIDES A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR OTHER OR
OTHER TYPE OF BASIS
AUGMENTATION FOR SOME
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS- THE
PERCENTAGE VARIES FROM ONE
POINT 7% 24% 25% YOU SEE THAT
ON PAGE TEN OF YOUR AGENDA. A
NUMBER OF- COMMUNICATIVE.
PROGRAMS HOWEVER WOULD NOT
RECEIVE A BASE AUGMENTATION
UNDER THE MAY REVISE EVEN
THOUGH THERE YOU TEND TO BE
STAFF INTENSIVE AND FACED A LOT
OF THE SAME COST PRESSURES AS
THE OTHER CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
THAT AREN'T RECEIVING AN
INCREASE. SO LEGISLATURE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO GIVE A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO THE SAME
SAID AS THE GOVERNOR A LARGER
SET FOR A HIGHER BASE THAN WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING. AND
AS WITH THE ONE TIME FUNDS I
MET THE LEGISLATURE COULD FREE
UP FUNDING FOR COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS OR OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES BY
REJECTING ONGOING PROPOSALS-
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DEEMS.
UNJUSTIFIEDOR OTHERWISE LOWER
PRIORITY AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT IN IN FEBRUARY AGAIN SHE
ADDS BUT OUR OFFICES SHARED
SOME. IDEAS WITH YOUR STAFF.
AND WOULD HAVE TO DISCUSS THIS
YEAR IF YOU'D LIKE. SO THERE'S
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES HERE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT ITS
STAMP ON TOO MANY COLLEGES
BUDGET AND MAKE SURE IT'S LIKE
JUST IT'S REFLECTING THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION MY NAME IS LIZ THAT
NEVER IT AND THE LICENSE FOR
COLLEGE FINANCING FACILITIES
PLANNING AT THE COMPANY CAN
COLLEGES PUTTING STUDENTS FIRST
CONTINUES TO BE THE DRIVING
FORCE BEHIND ALL OF OUR ACTIONS
TAKEN BY OUR COLLEGES
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND SO WE ARE THANKFUL THAT
GOVERNOR RECENT ISN'T INDUSTRY
SHOULD HAVE PROPOSED IN THE
REVISED AT LEAST STRONG
FOUNDATION FOR RE EMERGING FROM
THE PANDEMIC EQUITABLY.
FORESEEN OUR SYSTEM IS KEY TO
THE RESILIENCY STRATEGY THE
INVESTMENTS PRESENTED IN THE
MAY REVISE GENERALLY FLL INTO
SIX CATEGORIES RESTORING
INSTITUTIONAL RESOURCES BECAUSE
PANDEMIC RECOVERY DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION
AFFORDABILITY AND BATES BASIC
NEEDS WORKFORCE AND PATHWAYS
ALL ATTENTION ON OUR
PERSPECTIVE ON SOME OF THESE
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE PAY DOWN
OF THE ONE POINT FOUR FIVE IN
DEFERRALS AND SEE THIS AS KEY
TO PUTTING THE HARDSHIPS OF THE
PANDEMIC BEHIND US. WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HEARD OUR CONCERNS AND JOINED
US- IN ELEVATING THE NEED FOR
PARITY- IN OUR COAL AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ADJUSTMENT
ABOUT FOUR POINT. ZERO FIVE
COLA. RENDON POSE PANDEMIC
RECOVER THE DESTRUCTION BECAUSE
BY THE CAN DEMO. A LEFT
LINGERING SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES PARTICULARLY FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR AS EVIDENCED
BY OUR OUR ENROLLMENT DECLINES
AS SUCH WE SUPPORT THE MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES FOR RETENTION
AND ENROLLMENT STRATEGIES. AND
DEFERRED PAYMENTS THAT WILL
HELP US COME BACK TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. FOR DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION THE
GOVERNOR PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE OUR
IMPORTANT WORK TO DISMANTLE
STRUCTURES. THAT PERPETUATE
SYSTEMIC RACISM WE SUPPORT THE
FOLLOWING INVESTMENTS THAT
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY THE
REGISTRY MODERNIZATION AND-
BASING CREASE FOR INSTANT
EQUITY ACHIEVEMENT. WE DO
HOWEVER HAVE A CONCERN AROUND
THE CONTINUED- THE CONDITIONS
REQUIRE DISTRICTS TO MAINTAIN
ONLINE COURSE OFFERINGS AT
LEAST 10% HIGHER THAN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. I LET ME
CLARIFY WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS
ONLINE COURSE OFFERINGS AND
BELIEVE THAT THEY PROVIDE MUCH
FLEXIBILITY TO POSE TRADITIONAL
LEARNERS. WITH WE DON'T HAVE
EVIDENCE AROUND THE HARD AND
FAST RULE FOR TEN PERCENT. AND
SO- WE BELIEVE THAT OUR FOCUS
SHOULD BE ON QUALITY AND
CULTURAL COMPETENCY. AN ONLINE
AD. WE THE VARIOUS. I'LL WORK
FOR PURPLE UNDER TO PARTNER.
BIG WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
SO THAT WE CAN FOCUS ON
EMERGING INDUSTRIES- IN
PARTICULAR A HIGH ROAD AND WORK
BASED LEARNING. AROUND THE
AFFORDABILITY AGENDA WE HAVE A
LOT OF ALIGNMENT WITH THE
ASSEMBLIES ARE CONCERNED WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO NOT SEE HOW
GRANT REFORM IN THIS PROPOSAL
OUR STUDENTS DESPERATELY NEED
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID AND AS
PART OF A CONCERTED EFFORT TO
ENSURE BASIC NEEDS. ARE
STRUGGLING STUDENTS ARE MEANT
WE BELIEVE THE STATE NEEDS TO
ALSO ADDRESS LONG- LOT LONG
TERM FINANCIAL AID. I
SPECIFICALLY OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STUDENTS ENTRY INTO
THE EXCLUSIONARY CAL GRANT SITS
DOWN. IN LATE FEBRUARY THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOVERY WITH EQUITY
REPORT INCLUDED A GOAL THAT
LEARNERS WOULD RECEIVE SUPPORT
YOUR BASIC NEEDS THERE IS
SIMPLIFIED INTEGRATED SYSTEM
THE CONCEPT IS SIMPLE YET VERY
PROFOUND RE DESIGNER STRUCTURES
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
HOLISTICALLY. IN THEIR DAILY
LIVES TO DO WE DON'T HAVE TO
CONSTANTLY ASK THEM TO PROVE
THAT THEY'RE POOR WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPLY THIS
CONCEPT IN THE VARIOUS BASIC
NEEDS PROPOSALS IN THIS PROJECT.
WE ARE ARE GLAD TO SEE A
CONTINUED INVESTMENT OUR
PATHWAYS EFFORTS THIS IS A
FRAMEWORK THAT HELPS US
STREAMLINE ITS STUDENTS JOURNEY
THROUGH COLLEGE BY PROVIDING
CONSTRUCTION CHOICE IN REVAMPS
IMPORTS SO THAT ULTIMATELY
STUDENTS CAN ACHIEVE THEIR
COMPLETION AND COLLEGE GOALS.
AND LASTLY WE URGE
CONSIDERATION AND- FOR KOHLI'S
FOR THE VERY CATEGORICAL THAT
HAVE NOT SEEN THEM FOR MANY
YEARS INCLUDING THE MO JO A
FINANCIAL AID AND OTHERS THAT
DIRECTLY SERVE STUDENTS. AND
AND WE ASK FOR CONSIDERATION OF
GREATER CHANCES OFFICE CAPACITY
TO SUPPORT THESE NEARLY A DOZEN
NEW OR EXPANDED INITIATIVES.
WITH THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONTINUED SUPPORT
OF OUR SYSTEM OKAY. THANK YOU
START WITH SOMEONE MEMBER
MEDINA. YEAH I COUPLE ISSUES I
WANT TO BRING UP THE FIRST ONE
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. I AND SHOULD I- SHARE
THE ENTHUSIASM. FOR THE NEW
BASIC NEEDS CENTERS- TO BE
ESTABLISHED AND FUNDED WITH
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS- THANK
YOU KNOW I'VE CERTAINLY HEARD.
IN THE LAST. YEAR YEAR AND A
HALF TWO YEARS OF THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS- UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. AND WILL ADDRESS THE-
STUDENT AT CAL GRANT REFORM IN
THE NEXT ITEM BECAUSE THAT IS
ALSO NEEDED. BUT FOR THE BASIC
NEEDS CENTERS OF THAT ARE GONNA
BE ESTABLISH. HOW WILL THESE
CENTERS COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL
AND COUNTY PROGRAMS AND HOW
LONG WILL BE SANDERS. TAKE TO
BE IMPLEMENTED. THANK YOU
THAT'S A VERY THAT'S A QUESTION
ARE THE TEAMS OFFICE ACTUALLY.
A PERSPECTIVE WHERE WE ARE
SEEKING AT LINEMEN'S AND BETTER
INTEGRATION REALLY REDESIGNED
STRATEGY FOR BASIC NEEDS ALSO
BRINGS AND VERY S. CAMPUS
SUPPORTS THAT ARE ALREADY-
OFFERED INCLUDING FINANCIAL
AID. FOOD PANTRIES AND OTHER
CORE SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT INSURANCE AT
THESE CENTERS HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO THE DRIVERS OF THE CULTURE
OF OUR BASIC NEEDS AND THIS
INTEGRATED HOLISTIC APPROACH
FOR OUR STUDENTS. AND THAT IT
LEVERAGES EXISTING AND NEW
INVESTMENTS IN THIS APPROACH
WOULD BE THE FIRST IN THE STATE
TO OFFER BASIC NEEDS AND
FINANCIAL AID THROUGH THIS
HOLISTIC APPROACH- AND IT'S
REALLY WHAT WE KNOW IS WORKING
AND A LOT OF RESEARCH. BACKS UP
MORE OF THIS ONE STOP. APPROACH
FIRST STUDENTS SO WITH THAT WE
THINK THAT WE CAN HAVE BASIC
NEEDS BE MORE SUCCESSFUL ON OUR
CAMPUSES. AGAIN LEVERAGING
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURES AND
NOT RELYING JUST ON ONE PERSON
TO SERVE CAPACITY OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
REALLY A CASE MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY. AND TO THE SECOND
PART OF THE QUESTION. DO WE
HAVE AN AYE OF HOW LONG IT MAY
TAKE IMPLEMENT THESE. CENTERS
YES IF WE GO AN IN. APPROACH
THAT A LEVEL WHAT EXIST WITHIN
OUR FINANCIAL AID OFFICES THIS
WOULD- TAKE MUCH LESS TIME THAN
IF WE HAVE TO GO OUT AND STOP
LISTENING CENTER HIRE A NEW
PERSON INSTEAD WE WOULD WORK
THIS SUMMER WITH THE EXISTING
TEAMS THERE. AND CONTINUE TO
AGAIN- BUILT ON AND BRING IN
FINANCIAL AID CHOIR BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATORS ARE AND BEGIN WORK
ON THE INTEGRATION THIS WOULD
BE A KEY OFFERED THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER AND FALL. JOHN HEARING
YOU SAY THAT IT COULD BE DONE
PRETTY QUICKLY. YES ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. MY NEXT QUESTION IS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- AND PERTAINS TO COBB
RIGHT- I HEARD YOU SPEAK ABOUT-
HOW DID YOU REFER TO IT-
RECOMMENDATIONS- THIS FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THINGS THAT
COULD BE. DEFERRED OR OR NOT
FUNDED- SO TO THE LEGISLATIVE-
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS CALLED
RIGHT AMONG THAT IN THAT LIST.
IT'S A POLICY AGAIN WITH LIVE
ANALYST- SELLER WHAT I WAS
REFERRING TO WAS PROPOSALS BY
THE GOVERNOR IN JANUARY OR MAY
WE'VE RESPONDE TO THOSE-
PROPOSALS WITH OUR OWN
RECOMMENDATIONS SUGGESTIONS
LEGISLATURE OPTIONS LEGISLATURE
ON WHAT THEY MIGHT WANT TO DO
WITH THOSE PROPOSALS. THERE'S
NO PROPOSAL IN THIS BUDGET
PERTAINING TO COUNT RIGHT WE
ACTUALLY HAD A SUGGESTION LAST
YEAR WHEN THE STATE WAS FACING
UP BUDGET CUTS I TO CONSIDER
CUTTING OR EVEN ELIMINATING
CALIBRATE. I WE DO NOT HAVE
SUCH A RECOMMENDATION THIS YEAR
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO PROPOSAL
ON THE TABLE- BUT THAT'S
CERTAINLY- COURSE LEGISLATURE
HAS THAT ABILITY AND- THAT
PROVOCATIVE TO KEEP LOOKING AT
CAL BRIGHTON SEEN IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU WANT TO KEEP
OR NOT AS PART OF A- OF A
BUDGET- OR- POLICY DECISION.
THANK YOU AND TO- DEPARTMENT IF
I. OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE LAST AUDIT THAT WE GOT FROM
THE THAT THE- THE STATE AUDITOR
I REPORTED THAT DESPITE THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED TO COVER RIGHT
COLLEGE ONLY TWELVE STUDENTS
HAVE GRADUATED. AND WE SAW IT
A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO.
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
AND MYSELF GET. UNANIMOUS VOTE
IN IN THE- IN THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN IT WAS
BROUGHT UP- WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
THE- RECOMMENDATION AND WHAT
ARE THE ADMINISTRATORS IT'S
PLAN. ON ON CALIBRATE COLLEGE
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI
MISHANI WHEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- HELLO WE'RE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING- THAT
AUDIT REPORT BUT AS A MY A
COLLEAGUE AT THE ALLEY-
MENTIONED YOU KNOW THE MAY
REVISION DOESN'T PROPOSE ANY.
CHANGES TO THE FUNDING LEVEL
FOR CALIBRATE COLLEGE AND- YOU
KNOW IT'S BAD THAT THE COLLEGE
IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
INCREASED ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR YOU KNOW THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITHOUT A POST SECONDARY
DEGREE. AND THOSE WHO ARE
UNABLE TO ACCESS TO MORE
TRADITIONAL SETTINGS AND YOU
KNOW WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THAT POSITION. SO WHEN IT IS
SAID THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATION
FOR CHANGE THAT THAT IS ALSO
BECAUSE THE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION I BELIEVE. OR THE
MONEY ALLOCATED WHICH MAY BE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION. HAS NOT HAS NOT
BEEN SPENT ENTIRELY- AND I
WOULD JUST. ADD THAT THAT THE
AUDIT ALSO SHOWS THAT COBB
RIGHT ALSO HAS NO PLAN. IN
PLACE TO SHOW. EXACTLY HOW
THEY'RE GONNA MEET THE GOALS
THAT WERE ESTABLISHED BY BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO AGAIN I WOULD
JUST RECOMMEND THAT. THAT AS
WHEN WE SPEAK ABOUT MONEY BEING
ABLE TO USE BETTER ELSEWHERE-
THAT MANY THAT IS ALREADY BEEN
ALLOCATED TO CALIBRATE. OF BE
REDIRECTED THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU THE ARRESTS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE THE
ONE MEMBER WHO IS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GRADUATE I DID THE MY
APOLOGIES- MISTER CHAIR ARE YOU
ARE ALSO A GRADUATE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHERE I HAVE-
GREAT RESPECT FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE ROLE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IN HIGHER
EDUCATION I HAVE QUESTIONS IN
THREE AREAS ONE IS HAVING TO DO
WITH THE COLA- BUT IS. A- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
INVESTMENT OF THE FOUR POINT OH
FIVE. PERCEPT COLA BUT THERE IS
GREAT CONCERN AS TO WHY IT WAS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE UC CSU
AND CSU- AT THE 5% BASE
AUGMENTATION WE DO KNOW THAT K.
THROUGH TWELVE DID GET THE FOUR
POINT OH FIVE BUT THEN THEY GOT
THE ADDITIONAL 1% INCREASE IN
L. C. F. F. BASE FUNDING. WHY
DID THE WHY DIDN'T THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES GET THE SAME
5% INCREASE AND IS THERE
CONSIDERATION BEING GIVEN TO-
TO GIVE THE ADDITIONAL 1%
INCREASE SIMILAR TO WHAT K.
TWELVE RECEIVED. DAN HAD OR THE
OF FINANCE. THAT THE DIRECTLY
THAT THE MAYOR VISION DOES
REFLECT THAT UNITED HEY AND
AUGMENTED COBA ARE COLLECTING
NOT ONLY THE STATUTORY- COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR ONE POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. ALSO INCORPORATING AN
ACT IN A COMPOUND MODEL TO TWO
POINT THREE ONE FORGOTTEN
CALLED UP FROM THE CURRENT
YEAR- I BELIEVE I HAVE TO BOY
THE PARTY MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
PART OF MY COLLEAGUES TO COVER
THE OUTFIT TO. TAKE THIS THAT
IT BUT I KNOW THE WERE SOME
TENSE BUDGET TO THE BASE THERE
AS YOU. THAT LED TO WHAT WHAT
IS INCLUDED ARE ATTRACTIVE IT
PERSON POINT AND THOSE
CALCULATIONS WERE SPECIFIC TO-
DLT ABOUT THE SUPPOSED TO THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA- I WOULD OFTEN AT THAT
THE BETWEEN. REFLECTS OUR
BOUNCING. OF DATA ONGOING AT
ONE TIME RESOURCE ENERGY TO
PROPOSITION NINETY CARE THAT
ALL TO THE BY TO- TOWARD
STUDENTS. PROVIDE ONGOING
FUNDING A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS IN ORDER TO HELP MAKE SURE
THAT THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNICATIONS ARE ADDED. TO
THE FUTURE. YEAH I WAS AS A
FALL UP ON THE ONE I WOULD.
HOUSE THE ADDITIONAL 1% TO THE
BAY BECAUSE- OF BEFORE
COMMUNITY CALL. AS WAS-
EXISTING PROPOSED FOR THE K.
TWELVE- THE SECOND QUESTION IS
THERE I SEE THAT THERE'S
FUNDING FOR ELP PROGRAM AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER PROGRAMS BUT IS
THERE A SPECIFIC REASON WHY
THE- MO JO A WENT THERE AND
MESS UP WERE NOT INCLUDED. SURE
SEVEN IN THE BUDGET REFLECTS
OUR REFLECTS EXISTING PRACTICE
OF CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THAT
RECEIVED A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT SO BUT THE PROGRAMS
ARE COULD SO MUCH OF THE TICKET
PRACTICE WITH CONTINUED INTO
THE ABOUT YEAR. THE THESE THREE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS A MO JO ONE
DAY AND MASS I HAVE HAD GREAT
SUCCESS WITH OUR STUDENTS AND I
WOULD ELSE THAT. THE
ADMINISTRATION RECONSIDER- THEY
ARE ABSOLUTELY DESERVING OF
INCREASES BECAUSE OF THEIR
GREAT SUCCESS WITH OUR STUDENTS.
R. IN THE LAST QUESTION I WOULD
LIKE TO- FOLLOW UP ON MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE'S
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE BASIC
NEEDS CENTERS AND COORDINATORS.
IF MY MATH IS CORRECT WITH
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. AND
OTHER HOT ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
OR ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
CAMPUSES. HOW MANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DO WE HAVE. YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED SIXTEEN ONE SIXTEEN
THEM IF THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR
EACH OF THOSE IS UNDER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND IS
THAT ENOUGH. THANK YOU YES
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT- THAT
REALLY ISN'T ENOUGH IN TERMS OF
THE CASE MANAGED APPROACH AND
ONE THAT CAN HOLISTICALLY
SUPPORT EVERY STUDENT WE HAVE
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE AS MANY AS
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS.
DO YOU CAN ENVISIONED HOW
CHALLENGING IT CAN BE FOR ONE
PERSON TO HANDLE THE NEEDS OF
EVEN HALF OF THAT POPULATION
WITH A MORE INTEGRATED STRATEGY
THAT HAS BASIC NEEDS AT THE
CORE- AND STILL BRINGS ON OF
THE BASIC NEEDS COORDINATOR TO
DERIVE THAT WORK- WE THINK THAT
WE CAN SERVE MORE STUDENTS TO
BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE SAME
PRINCIPLES OUTLINED- BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND IN
LEGISLATION. THAT'S CURRENTLY
MOVING THROUGH. I THINK I FOUND
THE U. FOR THE- MONEY. TO
PROVIDE MORE FUNDING FOR. FOR
THESE BASIC NEEDS CENTERS AND
ALSO FOR OUR OTHER SUPPORT-
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS LIKE
REMOTE JOB WENT IN MESSA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WELL THANK YOU IS
THAT A IS THAT A MOTION
MAJORITY LETTER. WELL I WILL
NOTE THAT A LOT OF TIMES THAT
WE COMPLAIN THAT THE GOVERNOR-
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T PUT
SOMETHING IN THE BUDGET AND
JUST REMIND US THAT WE'RE A CO
EQUAL BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
HITS HIS VERSION WE DO OUR OWN
BUDGETS WELL OF OUR PLAN THAT
WE'RE GONNA ADOPT. IN THE
COMING DAYS AND YOU KNOW YOU
BET THAT THESE. AUGMENTATIONS
FOR EMOJI A PLANT DAY- MESA AND
RISING SCHOLARS TO WHICH I KNOW
THE COMMUNICORP CATCHES OFFICES
BIG ON SUPPORTING THANK YOU
MISTER AT- WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE THOSE ARE OUR PRIORITY
SAID THAT ARE FUNDED. IN IN IN
THE BUDGET AS WELL SO- HI I
JUST KNOW THAT ARE YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY WE HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR FROM OUR COMMUNICATORS
LAST FOUR MONTHS THAT. YOU KNOW
THEY DID A GREAT JOB THE
CHANCES OFFICE IN THE LEAGUE-
TO GOING REMINDING US THAT THE
COLA ALLOCATION WAS UNFAIR SO
THAT'S ADDRESSED IN THE REVISED
UP. I THINK THATS PROBABLY
THREE QUARTERS OF THE ISSUES
THAT THAT WE WANTED TO ADDRESS
FROM THIS FROM THE SYSTEM AND-
WILL TRY TO. FINE TUNE THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE COMMUNICATORS
IN THE COMING DAYS SO WITH THAT
WE'LL TRY TO OUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF A US. I'LL JUST ASK
ONE PROMISE. MAYBE THEM.
REVISION PROPOSED AN ADDITION
HIGH. MILLION AND ONE TIME FOR
A TOTAL OF ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION TO INCREASE
DEGREE OPTIONS USING OPEN
SOURCE MATERIALS WITH ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST. A REPORT ON THE
USE OF THE FIVE MILLION
PROVIDED IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
IS MORE THAN A YEAR OVERDUE AND
GALLIO HAS EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT REPEATING. OR EXPANDING
THIS EFFORT WITHOUT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE FIRST. IS
THE T. C. X- EXPERIENCE HAS-
HAS THE SEGMENT COMPLETED THE
REPORT ABOUT THE FIVE MILLION
PROVIDED. FOR SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
AND IF SO WHAT WERE THE
FINDINGS. THE NUMBER OF DEGREES
AND COURSES INCLUDED AND WHAT
ABOUT. THE STUDENT
PARTICIPATION AND SAVINGS.
THANK YOU I. TO ANSWER FIRST
QUESTION. A CHANCE IS OFTEN HAS
SUBMITTED THAT REPORT WILL MAKE
SURE THAT. THAT IS A BILL IN A
COPY IS PROVIDED YOU MEMBERS
THAT BY SUB. SOME OF THE
FINDINGS- WERE THAT- THIS
STRETCH. SAVES ARE AN ESTIMATED
US SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR- FOR THE- EFFORTS. ONE
OTHER RECKON- IS REFLECTED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
LOOK AT SOME OF THE BEES
PATHWAYS ARE CAN'T COMPLETELY.
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST BECAUSE
THEIR ROYALTIES ASSOCIATED. AND
SO YOU SEE THAT PROPOSAL
INCLUDED AND RECOGNIZES THAT
SOME WILL HAVE TO BE LOW COST
EFFORTS- WE ALSO CONTINUED TO
HEAR FROM OUR STUDENTS. THAT
TEXTBOOK COSTS CONTINUE TO BE A
KEY DRIVER TO SOME OF THEIR
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES SO WE
DO THINK THAT THIS DESERVES A
LOT OF MERIT- THEY- THEY
INVESTMENTS WOULD COVER NOT
ONLY. AT DEVELOPING THESE OUT
COURSE IS PRO. BUT IT ALSO WILL
COVER. THE FACT TIME DEVELOP
THESE TWO- I DON'T KNOW. QUAN
RESEARCH. INCIDENT THAT ARE ARE
USED AND TO DELIVER THE SAME
AND THEY WOULD GET FROM-
EXISTING TEXTBOOKS. TERRA
CARNEY YES. MAY I SPEAK MY
RESPOND OF COURSE. OKAY SO I
DID WANT TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTION AND ALSO TO WHAT YOU
JUST HEARD FROM MISS NAVARETTE
SO THE REPORT- DID ARRIVE IT
WAS THE LAST MONTH IT WAS- BY
YEAR AND A HALF LATE AND IT-
TALKED ABOUT HOW THE MONEY FROM
THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
INITIATIVE I WAS SPENT AND WHAT
THE RESULTS ARE- WHEN YOU READ
THE REPORT I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY YOU'LL BE KIND OF
DISAPPOINTED THERE WASN'T A LOT
OF INFORMATION THERE IT SEEMS
TO BE THERE SOME DATA
COLLECTION ISSUES. WITH THAT
THE REPORT DOES MENTION THAT
BUT- DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THAT
JUST WANT O POINT OUT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AFTER ALL THIS TIME
STILL LAKES LACKS BASIC
INFORMATION ON HOW THAT FIRST
INITIATIVE WHEN WE DON'T KNOW
AT THIS POINT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH FACULTY- HAVE ACTUALLY
CHOSEN TO USE THESE MATERIALS
THAT WERE TRADED WITH THIS
MONEY YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
ACADEMIC FREEDOM THEY CAN
DECIDE WHETHER THEY WANT TO USE
OPEN RESOURCE- OPEN EDUCATION
RESOURCES OVER CHARGE THE OLD
YOU KNOW HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLAR
TEXTBOOK LIKE THEY ALWAYS HAVE
WE DON'T KNOW IF FACULTY
ACTUALLY USING. THESE RESOURCES
IN THESE PATHWAYS WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY STUDENTS ACTUALLY
COMPLETED EIGHT ZERO TEXTBOOK
COST DEGREE OF DEGREE OR
PATHWAY WERE ON TRACK TO DO ONE
WE DON'T KNOW HOW THEY
PERFORMED ACADEMICALLY- WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT CHALLENGES WERE
ENCOUNTERED BY GRANTEES YOU
KNOW THAT THE COLLEGES THAT GOT
THIS MONEY IN DEVELOPING THESE-
THESE PATHWAYS AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE REPORT WE ACTUALLY THE
REPORT DOES NOT LAY OUT HOW
MUCH SAVINGS WERE GENERATED WE
DO KNOW THAT. STUDENTS SPEND A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY PER
YEAR ON. AVERAGE ON TEXTBOOKS
WE DON'T KNOW. OVER HOW THESE
TWO. SAVED MY AWAY TO SAVE
MONEY SO. AFTER ALL THIS TIME
THE LARGEST STILL HAVE ANSWERS
TO VERY BASED QUESTION SO WE'RE
REALLY WRECKED. THE TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT THIS PROPOSED.
IN THE MAY REVEAL PROVIDE A
HIGH AND- MILLION FOR THE
PROGRAM. WE COULD WE RECOMMEND
YOU YOU YOU CONSIDER REJECTING
AND CHILL GET THIS. WE CAN GET
THIS AND- IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS THEN THEN LET'S HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION THE LEGISLATURE-
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND ITS
CHANCES OFFICE BUT- I DON'T. AT
THIS POINT I DON'T THINK THAT.
INFORMATION ON. I WOULD- AGREED
AND I THINK IT IS PREMATURE
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING. YOU KNOW
THE FINDINGS AND WERE HAVING
REAL DATA A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS A LOT OF
MONEY- AND IT IS YOU KNOW
CONCERNING TO ME. AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
A STUDENT THAT YOU KNOW KIND OF
OUR TEXTBOOK I TOOK A-
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW CLASS
WITHOUT THE TEXTBOOK BUT STILL
GOING TO BE- BUT IT WAS HARD
IT. I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW OUR
STUDENTS ARE AT BUT I'M REALLY
HESITANT TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M NOT KNOWING WHAT THE DATA
ACTUALLY SAYS AND IT'S A BIT
PREMATURE SO- AT. THE LAST
QUESTION ALL OUT IS HAS
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERED
TARGETING DIZZY T. C. EFFORT TO
SPECIFIC COURSES WITH HIGH
ENROLLMENT. SUCH AS GENERAL
EDUCATION OR TRANSFER PATHWAYS
IS NOT A BETTER WAY- TO HELP. A
GREATER AMOUNT OF STUDENTS
AGAIN DANTAN ARE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF- SO THE- PROPOSAL.
THE CONTINUING OF A BIGGER
TICKET PROGRAM THE X. TO-
INCLUDE OPEN AND OR OR OR LOW
COST PRO- I THINK THAT. GOAL
REALLY IS TO REDUCE THE COST
ATTENDANCE THE STUDENT-
SPECIFICALLY RELY TO TECH AND
SO I THINK WE WOULD BE AND
ENGAGE A COVER. ABOUT HOW THE
DO THAT BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OVER TO GET
THIS PRO THAT WE GOOD RESULTS
FROM FAR. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU. I THINK NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
MOVE ALONG AND- AB UP. THE. IN
THIS TUNE COMMISSION- HASTING
THE LIBRARY AND GET THE PUBLIC.
IF YOU FOR YOUR NAY CAN. HM AND
MY W. LIKE TO HAVE A WITH THE
OF. TO SUPPORT WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED AS A RESULT OF
THE CALL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THE PROPOSAL THE RICE THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO THIS PLACE
WORKERS TO COVER THE COST OF
POST SECONDARY PROGRAMS HIGH
QUALITY TRAINING PROGRAMS OR TO
START A BUSINESS. WHAT ARE THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRAHAM
PROGRAM. THAT MAY WOULD BE FROM
AND OF FOUR MILLION GEN FUND
ONE TIME FOR THE TOTAL FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. TO
SUPPORT THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM THERE IS
ALSO TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROGRAM.
WHICH EFFECTIVELY AUTHORIZES
INTERNS WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS.
TO BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM. AT
THE TRAILER BILL ALSO AMENDS
THE DEFINITION OF HIGH NEED
FIELDS. TO INCLUDE.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS. OBLAK THERE SEVERAL.
I JUST- PERTAINING TO THE
DIFFERENT COLOR. AND THE MAY
REVISION ALSO. COSTS OF THE
GOVERNOR BY THE FOR- AND I'M
HAPPY. TO GET INTO THAT BECAUSE
THE- IF IT'S NEEDED ALSO HOW
IT'S TAKEN QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU. ELIA. THANK YOU
BECAUSE RENDON ON THE EDUCATION
TRAINING SCRIPT PLACE WHERE WE
DO REFERENCE BOTH. ONE
CONNECTED TO THE STATE
WORKFORCE TO SYSTEM. PANTHERA
BY LOCAL EXPERTS ON BOARD. AND
SO FORTH. THIS PROGRAM%
PROTECTING RESOURCES IN TRYING
TO. NOTIFY THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION DEVELOP NEW SYSTEMS
TO DELIVER GRANTS NOT JUST TO
COLLEGE STUDENTS BUT ALSO THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW LONG THEY
TAKE TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM
IN PART BECAUSE IT'S INTENDED
TO ADDRESS AT A VERY TIME
SENSITIVE ISSUE UNEMPLOYMENT
DURING THE ECONOMIC. BUT YOU
CONSIDERATIONS IN MIND THE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL. X. THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT THIS TO MEET
COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY A
MINISTER IN THE FIRST ROUND OF
FRANCE UNDER THE PROPOSAL IS IN
THE FIFTEEN MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS PROVIDED FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I'M GONNA FIND
NOTED THE GOVERNOR'S. WENT
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. SHE WOULD CALL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. ONE AS THE
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM BEFORE
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF THE FIRST ROUND AND-
NONETHELESS A PLEDGE. DOES MUCH
TO REPORT THIS REPORT. WE CAN
CONSTRUCT THE PEOPLE FABRIC ANY
REPORT AND OUT. INCLUDING THE
NUMBER OF TEACHER TYPICALLY
THEIR SERVICE REQUIREMENTS. BY
BETTER INFORMATION ON SHE'LL
ACCEPT BEING TRAPPED OF THE
KIND OF PROGRAM AND TEACHING
DESPITE. THANK YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. OKAY THING YOU STATE
COMMISSION. GOOD MORE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D TAKE FROM
HER ON BEHALF OF THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION THANKS FOR
HAVING US TODAY I'M I'LL BE
BRIEF IN MY COMMENTS HERE-
PARTICULARLY ON THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM I
WILL NOTE THAT THE COMMISSION
DOES SUPPORT THIS PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE FUNDS-
AVAILABLE TO- ADDRESS WHAT WE
KNOW IS A CRITICAL SHORTAGE
ANARCHY THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR TEACHER PIPELINE- ALL
NOW TURN MY COMMENTS TO THE
GOLDEN STATE EDUCATION
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND TRAINING
GRANT PROGRAM. I'M THE
COMMISSION IS GRATEFUL TO FEED
THIS PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHICH WILL HELP
US BETTER SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
AS THEY SEEK EDUCATIONAL AND
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES OR START
THEIR OWN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
AND WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WITH
THE APPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING AND STAFFING
CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL AS WITH
ENGAGEMENT- WITH OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE AND
BUSINESS PARTNERS THE
COMMISSION COULD EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW APPROACH. TO
SUPPORTING DISCONNECTED WORKERS.
TOTAL WOULD ALSO BE A MEANS THE
DRAWING DISLOCATED WORKERS BACK
INTO THE EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR
UPSKILLING AND RESKILLING. AT
THE VERY POPULATION THAT AS YOU
KNOW IS CURRENTLY UNDERSERVED
BY OUR TRADITIONAL FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS. AS WE DISCUSSED
IN A PRIOR SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
AND I KNOW MEMBERS ARE VERY
WELL AWARE. THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS STILL FEATURES
OUTDATED RATIONING DEVICES THEY
KEEP OUT STUDENTS WERE OLDER OR
TAKING SOME TIME TO WORK AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL. THESE ARE THE SAME
STUDENTS AND BE COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS WHERE THEY FACE
ONE IN EIGHT CHANCE OF
RECEIVING AN AWARD DESPITE
BEING ELIGIBLE BASED ON THEIR
FINANCIAL NEED. AND THEIR
ACADEMIC STANDING. THE GRANTS
UNDER THE PROPOSED GOLDEN STATE
EDUCATION ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND
TRAINING PROGRAM WOULD ALLOW US
TO RE ENGAGE THE POTENTIAL
STUDENTS AND BRING THEM BACK
INTO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
WELL IT OPTING TO CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AS OUTLINED IN
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- MEDINA
MCCARTY. WOULD PROVIDE THEM
WITH GREATER ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID TO SUPPORT THEIR
SUCCESS AFTER THE ANVIL. SO
OFTEN LEAVE MY COMMENT THERE
FOR NOW AND WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. THANK YOU- TO JAKE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION SO MY QUESTION IS TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANTS BUT ARE UNABLE TO
RECEIVE THEM DUE TO THE SMALL
NUMBER OF AWARDS. AND SO GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS- THAT COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR THE CAL GRANT AND THAT
SIGNIFICAN NON TUITION CLASS.
THAT THE THAT THE STUDENTS FACE
WHY ISN'T THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSING A CAL GRANT EXPANSION.
MATCH TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION-
GOVERNOR MY TENNIS WITH THE
PLUMBING OF FINANCE
DEMONSTRATION DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE CURRENT PROGRAM
MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL- I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT THE MADE
FOR A BIG FAN BILLS ON THE
AFTERNOON. OF OUR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WITH
BUDGETARY INVESTMENTS AIMED AT
REDUCING THE OVERALL COST OF
STUDENTS. THIS PROPOSED
AUGMENTATIONS. YOU SEPARATE
JODY OF. I'M SORRY IS THE
MAJORITY OF A ONE TIME FUNDS I
DID NOT HAVE THE SAME TYPE OF
PRESSURE LIABILITIES. THAT
THEY'LL BRING STATE BUDGET- WE
FACE SOME OF THESE INVESTMENTS
INCLUDED STUDENT HOUSING. AT
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE KONKURRENZ CHILD
SAVINGS ACCOUNT AND. REDUCE
TEXTBOOK COSTS. THEY WERE
GIVEN- THE PROPOSALS IN BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND IN THE SENATE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK. WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
MODERNIZE THE CAL GRANT-
PROGRAM AND THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
GET IT DONE THIS YEAR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I CONCUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA I I'VE
I'VE SPOKEN TO PERMANENT
FINANCE IN THE GOVERNOR'S.
OFFICE ABOUT THIS THEY KNOW
IT'S A PRIORITY AND THEY YOU
KNOW SUPPORT AT NIGHT. THE
BUDGET IS THAT THE OPPORTUNITY
A TRANSFORMATIONAL BUDGET AND
INVESTING IN OUR PRIORITIES AND
SO- YOU KNOW I ONLY GIVE IT AT
AT AT A NOT A PLUS BECAUSE-
THIS IS ONE OPPORTUNITY WHERE I
THINK THAT IF WE WANT TO.
TRANSFORM OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND UPWARD
MOBILITY IT'S ACCESS TO HIGHER
pEDUCATION SO IT'S MORE
ENROLLMENT SLOTS WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT WITH UC AND CSU.
AND IT'S OUR PLAN TO MODERNIZE
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND MAKE
COLLEGE DEBT FREE. I KNOW THE
SENATE IS GOING ALL IN ON THIS
ON THEIR SIDE- IT'S IN OUR
ASSEMBLY BLUEPRINT. TO FOCUS ON
THIS AS WELL SO- WE'RE GOING TO
BE. LOOKING AT A DUSTING THAT
THE MAY REVISE AND SOME OF
THESE ISSUES- THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT WHERE
THE REVENUES ARE FOR ON GOING.
TO PRIORITIZE BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR A
LONG TIME WE'VE WE'VE HAD YOU
KNOW THREE OR FOUR BILLS ON
THIS IN FIVE YEARS AND SO- IF
WE CAN'T DO IT THIS YEAR. WHEN
ARE WE EVER GONNA DO IT MR
MEDINA SELF. GET OUT WHO WILL
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT THAT-
FINANCIAL AID IS SO KEY AND AS
THE CITY COMMISSION ALLUDED TO
WE HAVE. THE ENVY OF THE WORLD
ARE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS BUT IT
JUST GETS IT IT FOCUSES ON
GETTING PEACEKEEPING KEEPING
PEOPLE OUT. ESPECIALLY OLDER
STUDENTS WHO WERE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AS MISS NEVER
AT SAID WITH THAT COMMUNICORP
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SO. WE
REALLY WANT TO- YOU KNOW BUILD
BACK BETTER LIKE THE OUR
PRESIDENT SAYING IN. THE END-
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
CALIFORNIA CAN THRIVE IN THE
FUTURE GENERATIONS. IT'S
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY AND
FINANCIAL AID WHICH WILLING TO
STEP IT UP WITH SELF. THIS IS
AN UNFINISHED BUSINESS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND- STAY TUNED ON
THIS UP. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
IDENTITY- TOO BECAUSE- THE
FIRST ONE FOUR SO THE STATE
TEACHER GRANT PER- WE STOOD.
WHO ARE NOT AT ONE OF THE
SEGMENTS- BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY
FOR THIS CURRENT. IF GOT A TIP
BERMAN FINANCE- I THINK THEM
EVERY QUESTION- THERE ARE SOME
STUDENTS I'M SORRY NOT
STUDENTS- YES THERE IS SOME
STUDENTS WERE DOING INTERNSHIPS
THROUGH THE LOCAL AGENCIES AND
ALSO WITH THE OAKWOOD CHRISTIAN
AGENCIES AND WITH THE
INSTITUTIONS. AT THIS
INDIVIDUALS WERE NOT PREVIOUSLY
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT IN
THE PROGRAM NOW WITH THE
CHANGE- THE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY ENTRANCE WILL BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. I JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE IT- EIGHT TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR ALL STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY SINCE PART OF ITS
TARGETING IS- AS IS WE'RE
LOOKING AT TKT EXPANSION- THAT
WORK FORCE NEEDS A HUGE
INSERTION AND WHEREVER STUDENTS
ARE STUDYING EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND EASY. I WISH TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS AND AVAILABILITY AND ARE
AVAILABLE TO APPLY FOR THIS
GRANT- SECONDLY. I'M KIND OF.
DID YOU WANT TO ADD I'M SORRY.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT LED
TRAILER BILL WITH THE CHANGE
ONE OF THE CHANGES THAT WE'RE
MAKING IN THE HIGH FILL NEED
ADS- TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
AS PART OF THOSE- EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT WILL QUALIFY.
GREAT THANK YOU. I'M THE OTHER
THING THAT KINDA JUST. BLOWS MY
MIND RIGHT NOW IS. THIS
CREATION OF THE GOLDEN STATE
EDUCATION ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND
TRAINING GRANT PROGRAM. WELL I
APPLAUD ITS INTENTION IT'S A
BILLION DOLLARS- AND I'M JUST
REALLY PERPLEXED AS TO WHY WE
WOULD. WHY THIS- PROGRAM
WOULDN'T BE UNDER THE PURVIEW
OF GULBIS IT JUST IT'S IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S A NEW PROGRAM WE'RE
GONNA BE PUTTING A BILLION
DOLLARS INTO IT AND IT'S NOT
THE AREA OF EXPERTISE. FOR OUR
SEGMENT SO UP I'M REALLY
PERPLEXED AS TO WHY- WHY WE
WOULD WHY IT'S HERE SO I DON'T
KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WANTS TO SPEAK TO THIS I THINK
I'M NOT A BUT- THE BILL BIZ
WOULD BE BETTER EQUIPPED. TO
HANDLE WHAT'S IS WHAT THE
INTENTION OF THE PROGRAM IS. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR FEEDBACK
TO MANAGEMENT- I WOULD JUST
POINT OUT THAT FUNDING FOR THE
ONE BILLION. OF FOR THIS
PROGRAM IS DIRECTLY FUNDED FROM
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACTIANCE. I'M SO THE INTENT OF
THE PROGRAM IS TO ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ARE WE SEE
THAT THEY COULD GO INTO
EDUCATION SECTORS TRAINING
SUPPORT OR THE CASE THAT'D
BUSINESS AND WE- CONSIDERS THE
FACT THAT AN ENTITY THAT COULD.
PERFORM THOSE ACTIONS AND USE
THEM THE NETWORK OUT THE MANY
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I JUST I'M I'M A BIT OF
A SCAB HERE- I MEAN. IT'S SO IF
WE'RE USING THE MONEY FOR HIGH
QUALITY TRAINING PROGRAMS I GET
THAT BUT FOR STARTING A
BUSINESS- EIGHT. FOR WHICH THE
RECIPIENT HAS ALREADY FILED FOR
A BUSINESS LICENSE AND
DEVELOPED A BUSINESS PLAN- I'M-
I'M I'M MAYBE I'M JUST UNAWARE
DO DO THE SEGMENTS AND DO THIS
I MEAN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT-
AS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
MYSELF. THE FOR MY FIRST
THOUGHT IS NOT TO GO TO MY
LOCAL YOU KNOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR HIGHER INSTITUTION
FOR THIS GUIDANCE- ESPECIALLY
IF I'M SOMEONE WHO LOST MY JOB
AND IS NOW. LOOKING AT OPENING
MY OWN SMALL BUSINESSES ALREADY
APPLIED FOR A LICENSE I'M GONNA
BE GOING TO THE S. B. A. I'M
GONNA BE GOING TO GO BAD SO. I
JUST FEEL LIKE THERE'S A HUGE
DISCONNECT AND IT'S A BILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT. WE GET IT
RIGHT SO THE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE I'M JUST GOING TO A POINT
THAT TO MY- COLLEGE AN
APPRENTICE TO FUNDED DETAILED.
DURING ACCIDENT. SORRY THANK
YOU I. DID MENTAL AND MY
COLLEAGUE THAT COME INTO MY
COLLEAGUE AT AND HI THIS IS A
NEW PROGRAM WE'RE TRYING TO
DIRECTLY RESPOND TO YOU I KNEW
NEEDS YOU TO CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ONLY RECOGNIZE THE
BEST OF IT AND VERY UNIQUE
PROGRAM. I ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT WE'RE IN A VERY UNIQUE
TIME IN THE STATE AND THE NEEDS
OF. THE DISPLACED WORKERS
ADVOCATE ARE ARE QUITE UNIQUE
AT THAT TIME SO THIS PROGRAM IS
A- VERY SPECIFICALLY. TRYING TO
TARGET THOSE MEET. I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY. IT I JUST FEEL
LIKE WE WERE WERE MISSING
SOMETHING REALLY IMPORTANT HERE
SELL THANK YOU. YEAH AND NOT TO
TOTALLY. THE JUDGE THIS BILL
JUST NOTE THAT THE WORDS THAT
THEY'RE SAYING ABOUT DISPLACED
WORKERS NEEDS THOSE EXACT SAME
WORDS WE HEARD WE CREATED
CALIBRATE. AND LOOK LOOK HOW
THAT IS BEEN LOTS OF FART
IMPLEMENTED SO THIS IS A
BILLION DOLLARS NOT ONGOING
MONEY AND WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF PLACES TO PARK ONE TIME
MONIES ARE LOOKING FOR- YOU
KNOW. THINGS TO FOCUS ON THE
NEEDS BUT- YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT TO SQUANDER THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND LOOK AT OUR
BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK FOR.
FOR MAKING A DIFFERENCE FOR
FAMILIES AND WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO. WE'LL HAVE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AND SOME OF
THESE THINGS YOU KNOW WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO SETTLE. BY THE
TIME WE- PASSED THE BUDGET MAY
HAVE TO EVALUATE THESE FURTHER
IN THE SUMMER. YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
LEGISLATION ON THE LOOK AT
BECAUSE- WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY WE'RE TRYING TO FINALIZE
AND SQUARED AWAY BEFORE YOU. DR
BUDGET ON JUNE THE FIFTEENTH
BUT- I'D RATHER BE RIGHT THAN
BE FAST SO. I WITH THAT
TERRIBLE WILL HOLD YES. I JUST
I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
REITERATE THAT A COUPLE POINTS
OR JUST MAKE I THINK THEY'RE
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS IS.
AT A BILLION DOLLARS YEAH SO
THE FIRST IS ON STARTING A
BUSINESS IS A THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR TWENTY FIVE. HUNDRED DOLLARS
THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
REALLY ENOUGH TO START A
BUSINESS WE HAVE THOSE
CONCERNS. ALSO JUST THINK ABOUT
KIND OF THE THEORY OF CHANGE
THE ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO
HAVE WITH THIS. WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THIS IDEA THAT IF
MONEY IS OFFERED THE DISLOCATED
WORKERS WILL JUST KIND OF KNOW
ABOUT IT AND WILL BE ENOUGH TO
GET THEM TO ENROLL. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHO IS AFFECTED BY THE
JOB LOSSES WHOSE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE JOB OFFICE JOB LOSSES HIS
MONIES INTENDED FOR. ITSLOWERS
PRIMARILY LOWER SKILLED
INDIVIDUALS NOT COLLEGE
EDUCATED THE PARENTS LIKELY
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE IMMIGRANTS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT THIS
IS INTENDED TO HELP- BUT- IT'S
UNLIKELY THAT JUST BY PUTTING
OUT MONEY AND GIVING MONEY
THROUGH THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. INDIVIDUALS WILL
JUST KNOW ABOUT THIS BILL.
THERE'S NO INVOLVEMENT HERE BY
SOMEBODY MENTION KOBE IS OUR
LOCAL WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARDS TO. WORK ON REFERRALS-
JOB PLACEMENT. SOCIAL SERVICE
COORDINATOR. ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE REALLY NEED TO BE
PART OF THE PICTURE IN ORDER TO
HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM BECAUSE WE
ALL WANT THE SAME THING. FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS. OKAY THANK
YOU. YES SOMEONE MEMBER S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO GO BACK TO THE CAL GRANT
ISSUE- I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AS-
STRONG ADVOCACY CHAMPIONING
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE- WITH OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
SPECIFICALLY. THEY HAVE THE
HOUSING COSTS AND YET THAT IS
NEVER SOMETHING CONSIDERED FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO AS WE
LOOK TO EXPAND AND I HOPE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION. WILL
RECONSIDER AND AGREED TO THE
EXPANSION OF CAL CAL GRANTS
THAT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS NEEDS ALSO BE
CONSIDERED VERY SPECIFICALLY-
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHO WAS
ELIGIBLE HOW MUCH THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR. YES THANK YOU A
MAN NOT SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE COMMITTEE
CALLED I'M SORRY THIS DANNY
COMMISSION AB. ISSUE OPEN AND
GO NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER. FIVE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS. IN SEPTEMBER
THREE OUT OF BROWN'S PART IN IT.
AND PROVIDE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION ON GO AND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT THE CALIFORNIA IT
LIVE FOR LIBRARY INFRASTRUCTURE
BROADBAND ACCESS EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES AND LIBRARY PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
AGES PARTICULARLY RESIDENTS AND
UNDERSERVED AND UNDER
RESEARCHED COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OKAY THANK YOU
L. L. HI JASON CONCENTRA- I'M
IF YOU CAN SENIOR GENDER THERE
ARE MANY NUMEROUS LIBRARY
PROPOSALS- WHEN WE SUBMITTED
COMMENTS TO STAFF. BASIC WE
WRITE A LOT OF THESE PROPOSALS
AS NEEDING MORE INFORMATION IN
RESTORATION HAS SENT. DOWN SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THE
CENTER- YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
WERE STILL RECEIVING- THAT THAT-INFORMATION SO WE CAN BE IN
TOUCH OF STAFF- IS NEEDED. WE
DON'T WANT TO TOUCH ON A FEW
ISSUES FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
OF THE FIRST OF THAT VERY FIRST
PROPOSAL- ON YOUR AGENDA THAT
FOCUSES ON LOCAL LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS. ON WE
WANTED TO WE THINK THIS RAISES
A FEW ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION-
AS WE'VE NOTED TO THE COMMITTEE
BEFORE LOCAL LIBRARIES ARE
PRIMARILY LOCALLY SUPPORTED AND
THAT INCLUDES LOCAL LIBRARY
CAPITAL PROJECTS. I'M NOT SAID
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME RESEARCH
RECENTLY- CALIFORNIA RESEARCH
BUREAU REALLY RECENTLY DID A
pABOUT THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL NEEDS AMONG
PUBLIC LIBRARIES. SO THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE THERE'S WHERE
THERE'S A THERE THERE IS A
DEMONSTRATED NEED. IF THIS IS
AN AREA THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO PURSUE. WE
RECOMMEND A FEW MODIFICATIONS
TO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. FOR
EXAMPLE WE RECOMMEND- NARROWING
THE SCOPE OF THE GRANTS TO
FOCUS ON. ON A MORE LIMITED
AMOUNT OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SUCH AS A CAPITAL PROJECT YOUR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. WE
RECOMMEND THAT BECAUSE YOU'LL
SEE AN AGENDA THAT THERE ARE
OTHER PROPOSALS RELATED TO OUR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
WE JUST RECOMMEND ENSURING THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE GRANT
PROGRAMS IF THEY DON'T PEOPLE
KIDNAPPERS. WELL WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE WERE A FEW PROPOSALS
WE ARE RECOMMENDING THE
LEGISLATURE. UP FOR EXAMPLE
YOU'LL SEE PROPOSALS RELATED TO
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
INSTRUCTION AND- ONLINE
TUTORING FOR K. TWELVE
STUDENTS. WE THINK THESE ARE
PROPOSALS LARGELY DUPLICATE.
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GOING ON AT
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STATE PROVIDES BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SHOULD BE BECAUSE
ACTIVITIES. WE DON'T SEE A
RATIONALE AND PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL SET ASIDE ABOUT FROM
FOR LIBRARIES. TO CONDUCTION.
IT'S I REALIZED IS ONE OF SO ON
HAPPY THAT ON THE DURING. OKAY
THANK YOU. STATE LIBRARIAN
MISTER LUCAS. HI GREG LOCUSTS
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER- ANY QUESTIONS
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HANDS- I WOULD
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT THE- THE
SURVEY THAT JASON WAS TALKING
ABOUT OF LIBRARY FACILITIES
FINDS A THREE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR NEED- FROM
RESPONDENTS WHO REPRESENT 70%
OF THE LIBRARY FACILITIES SO IF
YOU SORT OF EXTRAPOLATE THAT
OUT THE RENOVATION AND
MODERNIZATION NEEDS CLOSER TO
ABOUT. FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. SO
IS IT IS THIS TO PROVIDE MORE
LIBRARY SERVICES OR MODERNIZE
AND UPGRADE EXISTING BECAUSE IT
SEEMS THAT WE HAVE. DEUL NEEDS
IN OUR STATE WIDE LIBRARY
FACETTI. WELL THAT'S TRUE THERE
THERE ARE THE INTENT OF THESE
BONDS ARE TO MAKE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENTS HAVE THE LIBRARIES
IN CALIFORNIA OR FORTY YEARS OF
AGE OR OLDR SO THAT MEANS
THEY'RE NOT AS ENERGY EFFICIENT
AS THEY COULD AND SHOULD BE-
THAT MEANS MANY ARE
GRANDFATHERED IN UNDER THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
IT MEANS THAT MANY HAVE WIRING
THAT INADEQUATE TO DELIVER THE
KIND OF HIGH SPEED- BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY THAT'S- BOTH
EXPECTED THE NEEDED BY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. OKAY AT. QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SIX ZERO
NINE I YEAH MISTER GALLAGHER.
AS A QUESTION. SO ON THE
BUSINESS THIRTY FIVE MILLION
FOR COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN LOCAL EDUCATION
LIBRARIES AND TELEHEALTH
PROVIDERS TO EXPAND INTERNET
ACCESS TO ISOLATED COMMUNITIES
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE- BUT THE L. A- INDICATES
THAT KEY INFORMATION IS MISSING
FROM THIS PROPOSAL- CAN THE
ADMINISTRATION SPEAK TO HOW
INTERNET ACCESS WOULD BE
EXPANDED- HOW MUCH ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING THE STATE WOULD
RECEIVE. AND WHAT THE BALANCE
OF STATE ANOTHER FUNDS WOULD BE
TO ACCOMPLISH- THESE
COLLABORATIVE PROJECTS. BUT
IT'S CRITICAL SO I CAN TAKE A
STAB AT THAT- TELL A PROBABLY
TELL ME WHAT YOU KNOW ALREADY
ABOUT THE FEDERAL E. RATE
PROGRAM WHICH OFFERS DISCOUNTS
BOTH IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT LIBRARIES AND SCHOOLS AND
OTHERS PAY. FOR THEIR INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY- AND IT'S THE
RIGHT THE DISCOUNT IS BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF SUBSIDIZED MEALS
THAT ARE SERVED AT SCHOOLS IN
THE SAME JURISDICTION SO
THERE'S PARTS OF THE STATE YOU
KNOW SOME SOME YOUR DISTRICT-
WHERE. FOR PROVIDERS ARE
BIDDING ON THE PROJECTS BECAUSE
CONNECTING THE AREAS IS SO
EXPENSIVE. ADD THAT TO DO WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH IN TO THE REVENUE
THAT THEY'LL GET BACK- DOESN'T
COVER THE EXPENSE OF THEIR
INVESTMENT. SO WE'VE HAD SOME
SUCCESS LAST YEAR WORKING WITH
OUR PARTNERS- AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. AND TWO PROJECTS
AT THE SAME TIME RIGHT SO A
LIBRARY PLUS A SCHOOL PROJECT
AND SO THAT BRINGS INTO PLAY TO
E. RATE DISCOUNTS. AND THEN THE
LIBRARIES USED- THERE'S I
FORGOT THE NAME OF BUT IT'S ON
THERE THERE'S A- WE HAVE A SIX
MILLION DOLLAR POT OF MONEY FOR
BROADBAND GRANTS. AND SO WE'VE
BEEN USING FUNDS FROM BACK TO
MAKE A TO MAKE THE STATE MATCH
WHICH ALSO TRIGGERS- YEAH KIND
OF A REDUCTION IN COST BY THE
FEDS. BUT AT LEAST LAST YEAR ON
THE PROJECTS WE DID WAS RUNNING
AT A ONE DOLLAR FROM US. TEN
DOLLARS BACK FROM THE FEDS
RATIO. SO THIS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION CONTEMPLATES TAKING
THAT AND SO WE'VE HAD SOME
SUCCESS LIKE FERNDALE AND-
SHOOT WHAT'S OUT GARBER VILLE-
WERE PROJECTS THAT IS. NOBODY
IN THAT ON BECAUSE THEY WERE SO
EXPENSIVE BUT MATT WAS ONE OF
THE SUCCESSES LAST YEAR. ALSO
JUST NEAR HERE IN SACRAMENTO-
CLARKSBURG FOR EXAMPLE
CONNECTING THE LIBRARY AND-
ONCE ITS HIGH SCHOOL THERE- BUT
THOSE WERE TWO SUCCESSES THAT
CAME FROM THIS BUILDING. TO
KINDS OF PROJECTS AT THE SAME
TIME SO THAT THE INTENT OF THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION IS TO SAY
OKAY. WELL LET'S DO. LIVE PLUS.
PLUS TELEHEALTH WHICH TRIGGERS
A THIRD- EAT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THIRTY RATE DISCOUNT OF MAIN
BREAKS- EVEN MORE PROJECTS MORE
ATTRACTIVE TO- PROVIDERS. CAN I
ANY BETTER WAY TO LEVERAGE
THOSE ALL THOSE DOLLARS THOSE
POTS OF MONEY TO GET. SOME
BROADBAND INCREASE IN THESE
AREAS. YES. YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
A UP ON THE ON THE- IS THERE
STUFF MAYBE AND LOOKED AT. WELL
FOR THAT WE WORTH. NORTHERN
VALLEY DRASTIC COUNTY OF YOU
KNOW THE- AREA AS WELL SISKIYOU.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS WHERE YOU
KNOW THOSE THREE KIND OF
SCHOOLS PLUS LIBRARIES PLUS
TELEHEALTH ARE A PLATE AND A
NUMBER OF THE PROJECT OUR END
BUT IN ORDER THIS NORTHERN PART
OF THE STATE I CAN'T SAY
EXACTLY WHERE OKAY BUT I MEAN
I'M HAPPY TO- WITH THE BROAD
THE- PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING ON
THIS AND SEE WHAT THEY COME UP
WITH WHAT LOOKED LIKE GOOD
POSSIBILITIES. I IMAGINE SOME
WILL BE AND SISKIYOU AND SHASTA.
HOW ABOUT THIS I MEAN JUST THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN YOU GUYS
SPEAK TO THAT. HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO VOTE EXPECT THINGS.
AND VERY SWEET THANK YOU YOUR
QUESTION. YES SO HOW TO THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN YOU SPEAK TO
HOW INTERNET ACCESS WOULD BE
EXPANDED HOW MUCH ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING THE STATE WOULD
RECEIVE. AND WHAT THE BALANCE
OF STATE ANOTHER FUNDS WOULD BE
TO ACCOMPLISH THESE
COLLABORATIVE PROJECTS. CHECK
THE BRIANNA RENT THAT APARTMENT
BINANCE AND YOU KNOW I THINK
WE'LL BE WORKING REALLY CLOSELY
WITH OUR LIBRARY COLLEAGUES IN
TERMS THAT YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT
IS THAT IT WILL BE ABLE TO
DRIVE DOWN I WOULD KNOW THAT
THAT IS THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM- BROADLY OF MY-
COLLEAGUE MISTER WE GET
MENTIONED YEAH WE DO INTEND
PRETTY THANKS TO JOT DOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS-
ESTHER AND- OF THAT THE- AT
THAT. SPECIFIC AMOUNT THAT WILL
BE A TO DRIVE DOWN I WOULD TO.
I WORK WITH MY LIBRARY
COLLEAGUES ON THAT DATE AND GET
BACK. HERE OKAY. ST LUCAS
AGAIN. AS I SAID EARLIER OUR
EXPERIENCE IN DOING. JOINT
PROJECTS WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
K. THROUGH TWELVE LAST YEAR.
WAS WE RECEIVED ROUGHLY. TEN
DOLLARS. RIGHT IN FEDERAL MONEY
FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT THE STATE
PUT IN. SO IF WE PUT IT IN A
MATCHING YOU KNOW A MATCHING.
AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS RIGHT WE GET ABOUT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING MONEY COMING BACK. FOR
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY IN
PROJECTS LIKE THIS THAT WE DID
WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH K.
THROUGH TWELVE- WE PUT IN ABOUT
A MILLION AND SOME CHANGE AND
GOT BACK THIRTEEN MILLION- IN
FEDERAL MONEY YEAH. WELL THAT'S
IT I OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A GREAT
RATIO AND- AND I'M CERTAINLY
NOT GOING TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
THAT ISSUE EITHER YOU KNOW. I
JUST WAS WONDERING IF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND MAY
BE CALCULATED OUT WHAT THEY
WERE ESTIMATING IN TERMS OF.
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WOULD COME
IN. BASED ON THIS BUT I THINK
THAT HELPS ANSWER MY QUESTION
THANK YOU MISTER LUCAS YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU. OKAY- WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THESE ISSUES OPEN AT
THE ASSEMBLY WILL PROBABLY HAVE
SOME IDEAS ON. OTHER STATE
LIBRARY PROPOSALS AS WELL WE
COME BACK WITH A PLAN NEXT
WEEK. I WITH THAT FINAL ISSUE
BEFORE PUBLIC COMMENT HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW WE CAN TRY TO DO
THIS VERY BRIEFLY CARMINA
FINANCE ELIA. SURE PRIMARILY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE THEM
BUT A REVISION PROPOSES THREE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
FOR AN ALTERNATIVE CAMPUS
PUBLIC SAFETY PROGRAM. HAPPY
SIXTH. BAG GO AHEAD PLEASE
CONTINUE. BOB THERE ARE CERTAIN
PROGRESSIVE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE VISION INCLUDES
THREE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. FOR AN ALTERNATIVE CAMPUS
PUBLIC SAFETY PROGRAM AT
HASTINGS. OKAY. WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IN PLAIN ENGLISH
ALTERNATIVE CAMPUS PUBLIC
SAFETY WE LIKE ALTERNATIVES WE
LIKE ALL I'M TRYING TO BE BRIEF
I KNOW WOULD LIKE TO TELL US
REAL QUICK WHAT THAT MEANS SO
THIS IS THEIR DIRE THE CAMPUS
HAD SOME SECURITY INSTITUTION
ISSUES AND TRADITIONAL PUBLICLY
FUNDED POLICING AND ALSO
PRIVATELY ADMINISTERED SECURITY
GUARDS WERE NOT DOING THE TRICK.
SO IN ORDER TO FIND A SOLUTION
TO THE SECURITY AROUND CAMPUS
ISSUES THEY WORKED WITH URBAN
ALCHEMY TO NON FOR PROFIT THE
ONLY HIRES. FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS THAT
USE ALTERNATIVE POLICING
METHODS OR NOT POLICING METHODS
BUT THEY ARE UNDER ALTERNATIVE
TO POLICING. SO THEY DON'T
CARRY GUNS THEY ARE TRAINED IN
DE ESCALATION IN AND REFERRALS
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACCEPT HER UP. AND SO THEY
PROVIDED BY. WHAT HAS BEEN AN
INCREASE IN SAFETY AND WELLNESS
AND WELL BEING FOR THE
COMMUNITY AROUND AS THINGS
THEY'VE DONE AS AN ALTERNATIVE
TO FOR EXAMPLE- TRYING TO
INCREASE THE SORT OF
TRADITIONAL IT'S A POLICING.
OKAY SO THESE WILL BE ONE TIME
RESOURCES TO BASICALLY GET THIS
PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING. THAT'S
CORRECT SO THEY PILOTED THIS
PROGRAM FOR SIX MONTHS- IT'S
ONGOING RIGHT NOW IN THE
CURRENT YEAR PILOTED IF PARTLY
IN RESPONSE TO COBIT.
ABANDONMENT AND THIS THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
THREE YEARS AND IT WOULD X.
EXTEND THE PILOT AND FLOUR TO
MOVE FORWARD. THE REASON FOR
THE THREE YEAR TIMELINE IS
SIMPLY THAT THE ONGOING IT IS
UNCLEAR- THE SORT OF. SECURITY
AND SANITATION ISSUES THAT THIS
IS ADDRESSING ARE THEY HAVE
BEEN DYNAMIC IN SHIP SHAPE
SHIFTING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND SO GOING FOR ITS
VERY- IT'S JUST AN UNKNOWN OKAY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIS
HASTINGS I THINK NINE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN. RELATED TO
THE SCHOOL FINANCE AUTHORITY
SCHOLARS SHARE AN OFFICE
PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SAME
ISSUE NUMBER. CHAVEZ WITH
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. THREE OR
WHAT. YES PLEASE CONTINUE TO
JENNIFER. YOU'RE NOT JENNIFER
BUT GO HEAD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HI- THE MAIN
REPLACEMENT PROVIDES
APPROXIMATELY TWO BILLION ONE
TIME FEATHER AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FUNDS. IN THE BUDGET YEAR IN
ESSENCE A HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE SO I CLAMOR SHACKLED
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS FOR ALL
CARRILLO INCOME POP PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS. AS THE PRIMARY
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WHICH SUPPLEMENTAL
INVESTMENT FOR FOSTER YOUTH IN
HOMELESS STUDENTS ENROLL IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL EFFORTS TO SET
THE COURSE OF THE STUDENTS
POPULATION. AS THEY ENTERED
FIRST GRADE. WHILE STUDENTS
WILL RECEIVE S. ACROSS FIVE
DOLLAR. FOR YOU TO CALL
CHILDREN WILL RECEIVE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. CAPITANES ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY L.
A. L. HI L. O. SORRY THIS IS A
MASHONALAND FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- I THINK OF IT
JENNIFER **** WHO IS SET TO
PRESENT BUT WAS NEEDED SO- ARE
YOU GEN ARE YOU THERE TO
PRESENT THE REST OF THE
PROPOSAL'S. OKAY GREAT. YES
OKAY YES. SORRY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES HERE. OKAY SO-
GABBY JUST OF I BELIEVE SHE
JUST COVERED THE DOLLAR SHARE
INVESTMENT IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT. OKAY SO I'LL BE GOING
OVER THE OTHER THREE
INVESTMENTS- JENNIFER COP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
THE FIRST COUPLE OF TALK ABOUT
IN THE CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
POSE ON THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
ALL COLLEGE SERVICE PROGRAM THE
NEIGHBOR VISION PROPOSES TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION ONE TIME OF WHICH TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION. AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACT FUNDING AND FORTY FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION OF WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEER TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL COLLEGE
SERVICE PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AND THE
CALTRAIN COMMUTER COLLEGES.
THIS PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE UP TO
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
PART TIME SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES
TO COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CRITICAL
ISSUE AREAS THAT JUST CRIED
ACTION EDUCATION AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT HEALTH AND DISASTER
RESPONSE. STUDENTS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM
WILL GAIN VALUABLE EXPERIENCE
WHILE SERVING THEIR COMMUNITIES
I WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR UP TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
COMPENSATION. I SPEND AND
POLITICIAN FOR THIS PROPOSAL MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FINANCE ARE ON
THE LINE I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IN THE
PROPOSAL. ALSO DELTA ANTHONY
CHAVEZ FROM THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS IS ON THE LINE. FOR
THE PROGRAM TO QUESTION. NOT IS
THE HIGHER. GEN HAPPEN. THE
MAYOR OF A BECAUSE IT UP FOR.
ONE TIME FUND AND HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT. EVENLY OVER
TO. TWO BILLION TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND TWO. AND TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FINANCE AUTHORITY WILL
ADMINISTER GRANTS THE THREE POT
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENT. IT DIDN'T HOUSING
BUBBLE IN YOUR ADDRESS HOUSING
INSECURITY BY COVERING THE UP
FRONT COST OF HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION OR HOUSING
ACQUISITION AND RENOVATION AND
INCREASING THE AVAILABILITY OF
LOW. LOW COST UNIT HOUSING. TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS STUDENT COSTS
DEPEND- LACK THERE. KEEP YOUR I.
COLLABORATIVE THE NAY REVISION
AND IN. IN THE OFFICE AND
RESEARCHING. INTO LYING HIGH
ALIGNING HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS AND RECENT
REGIONAL WORK FORCE NEEDS. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
ALLOCATING THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND SATISFIED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM
REGIONAL CATERING SIXTEEN
COOPER IS. STOCKED WITH THE
PLANNING AND RESEARCH WOULD
PROVIDE GRANTS FOR
COLLABORATIVE THAT INCLUDE AT
LEAST ONE CAMPUS ALL THREE
PUBLIC BECKMAN. THREE
OCCUPATIONAL PATHWAYS THAT LEAD
TO HIGH PAYING IN DEMAND JOBS
AND ADOPT RECOMMENDATIONS MADE
BY THE HIGHER EDUCATION
RECOVERY WITH EQUITY TASK
FORCE. BUT THAT MY COLLEAGUES
AND I ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU. L. A.
L. YEAH I DIDN'T CONCENTRATE
SOLELY- I WE REALIZE TIME IS
SHORT SO WE WERE JUST GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE TWO BIG ITEMS YET
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FOR
STUDENT HOUSING AND THE ONE OF
THE SCHOLARSHIP- CLOSE ALSO ALL
I'LL TOUCH ON THE HOUSING ONE
AND THEN MY COLLEAGUE WE STILL
COVERAGE COLLEGE HERE. I JUST
ON THE STUDENT HOUSING PROPOSAL
WE'RE STILL WAITING ON THE
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION THE
ADMINISTRATION HASN'T RELEASED
IT YET- SO WE CAN'T OFFER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AT THE
MOMENT BOB BUT WE DO WANT TO
RAISE A FEW ISSUES ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURES.
FACTOR TO CONSIDER ON THIS ONE-
COME ON THIS WOULD BE. OUR ONLY
A NEW INITIATIVE REALLY IN
APPROACH FOR THE STATE.
HISTORICAL TO THE STATE HAS
FOCUSED ITS OUR CAPITAL
RESOURCES ON ACADEMIC
FACILITIES. MR BE A NEW
APPROACH BY FOCUSING ON OUR-
SPENDING ON STUDENT HOUSING.
IT'S ALSO A NEW APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING AFFORDABILITY
HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS
FOCUSED ITS SPENT ON SPENDING
ON TOP FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS.
HOW BECAUSE THIS IS NEARLY
RAISES A FEW AREAS OF
UNCERTAINTY FOR ONE IT'S HARD
TO GAUGE THE IMPACT OF THE
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE ON
AFFORDABILITY. HAPPENS FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S HARD TO GAUGE HOW
MANY ADDITIONAL BEDS WERE
PROVIDED HOW MANY STUDENTS TO
BE IMPACTED BY IT. IT'S ALSO
HARD TO PROJECT- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAMS
IT'S HARD TO PROJECT WHETHER.
CAMPUSES WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO. IRAN BUT HOUSING ON A
CERTAIN KIND OF MIND. FINALLY
IT'S A WANTS TO HOOK HOUSING
UNITS ARE BILL- DEPENDING ON
THE TRIM LEGISLATION AND
DEPENDING ON THE LIMITS THAT
ARE IMPOSING ON RENTAL RATES.
IT'S HARD TO GAUGE THE ABILITY
OF OTHER SEGMENTS MOVING
FORWARD TO BE ABLE TO. MAINTAIN
AND OPERATE THE FACILITIES. I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT YOU A RESERVE
FOR THE- COMMENTS. OKAY IN.
COLLEGE STATING BOTH OVERLAPS
WAITING PRO ACCOUNT GETS
PROGRAM WHICH THE STATE END
NINETEEN TO. UNDERSTANDING
SCHEDULED TO LAUNCH THIS
PROGRAM LATER THIS YEAR AND IT
WILL BE AN ST ACCOUNT EVERY NEW
KERR BUT IT'S THE OF THESE ON
FACT THESE. MUCH LITERATURE
FIVE FUNDING COLLEGE SAVINGS IN
THE BUDGET GAP WE THINK COULD
CONSIDER AUGMENTING THE
EXISTING PROGRAM RATHER THAN
CREATING A NEW ONE AND HAVING
ONE COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT
COULD BE EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO
NAVIGATE THAT'S INCREASING
LIKELY HAD THE BILLING CARE
TRIVIALIZE. THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU. SO THANK YOU. THAT OKAY
I'M US SOME SOME SOME COMMENTS
ON THESE TO THE LARGER ITEMS.
WHEN I REALIZED THE OTHER ONE
WELL- NOT AS LARGE AS TWO
BILLION IS SIGNIFICANT TWELVE
THAT CALLS FOR ALL SERVICE
PROGRAM. THAT'S THIRTY MILLION
ONE TIME. THANK ARE THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION TWO HUNDRED AND SO
THE FIRST PCS. OKAY OKAY. CATCH
ALL COME BACK TO THAT SIHLTAL
FIRST ON THE- ON THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING- THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS HIS IS INTERESTED IN IN HIS
SUPPORT OF UP TO DIVERT PEOPLE
TRANSPARENCY I HAVE A BILL THAT
WOULD DO. EXACTLY THIS CREATIVE
REVOLVING FUND FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING IT'S
A BIG NEED AND FOR THE COST OF
INSTRUCTION IS STUDENT HOUSING-
WE DO SUPPORT THIS IS GOING TO-
THE CAMPUS I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
THE MAJORITY OF IT GOING TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES JUST BECAUSE
TALKING TO THEM LAST YEAR. AND
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT WERE
LEAST LIKELY TO ENGAGE IN BILL
STUDENT HOUSING AND OTHERS A
COUPLE OF ENTREPRENEURIAL
CAMPUSES BUT- REALLY IF YOU
WANTED TO. FOCUS ON- GETTING
THAT MONEY ON THE BIGGEST BANG
FOR THE BUCK IT'S THE UC AND
CSU SEGMENT AND REALLY ADDRESS
THE OTHER ISSUES WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER WHICH IS
ENROLLMENT ACCESS. NOT TO SAY
THAT A STUDENT HOUSING IS AN
ISSUE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS BUT JUST DON'T
THIS DOESN'T SEEM OF THERE'S A
LOT OF VIABLE. PROJECTS COULD
THEY COULD JUST GET UP AND
GOING NOW- YOU KNOW WE CAN TALK
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY
SHOULD BE. AREVOLVING LOAN
FUND- JUST GRANTS TO THE
SEGMENTS I THINK WE'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WHEN IT IS.
KNOWING THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF IDEAS AND- AND
REALLY SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW
TO DO THIS I THINK THIS IS.
LIKE WE SAID EARLIER AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE WE
JUST DON'T GO FAST BUT DO IT
RIGHT AND REALLY BE THOUGHTFUL
AND DELIBERATIVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE FOCUS ON STUFF NASA
FOR BILLION. IN INVESTMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- WE GET OUR
BIGGEST BANG FOR A BUCK AND
REALLY. FAT HE ENSURE THAT. YES
TO HOUSING ANSWER ACTUALLY
BUILT. AND THEY'RE PERSONALLY
AFFORDABLE AND LASTLY. WE THINK
THAT IT'S- IT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF TAXPAYERS TO HAVE
THESE- UNIVERSITY BELTS. AND
NOT BRING IN IN. THE PRIVATE
SECTOR FOR THESE YOU KNOW
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
THEY KNOW THEY THEY SOUND GOOD
BUT MANY TIMES ARE JUST. WALL
STREET INVESTORS TRYING TO GET
THERE. THERE ARE A WIDE ON
THESE RATES AND SO YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP THE
PRICES DOWN FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS. LIKE WE'VE SEEN IN.
UNIVERSITY HOUSING THE UC UC
SAN DIEGO FOR EXAMPLE HAS DONE
A GREAT JOB OF DOING THIS SO-
THOSE ARE OUR THOUGHTS ON THIS.
THE SCHOLARS SHARES SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT WE'VE BEEN
BANGING ON THIS FOR A FEW
YEARS- THAT IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE PERMANENT. THE COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS. AND I'VE SEEN
THIS LOCALLY WITH THE PROGRAM
THAT I HELPED CREATE HERE WITH
KINDERGARTEN TO COLLEGE THAT.
KIDS AND FAMILIES WHO HAVE A
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT IN
THEIR NAME. WHETHER IT'S YOU
KNOW FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR- FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AS A TRUST
FUND KID. THEY'RE ALL JUST AS
LIKELY TO GO ON TO COLLEGE
BECAUSE IT IT BUILDS UPON
EXPECTATIONS OF COLLEGE-
COLLEGE ATTENDANCE SO. CALLED
ATTAINMENT OF HIGHER EDUCATION
ATTAINMENT SO THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY I KNOW
THAT SOME WHENEVER NECESSARY
AND IT'S BEEN A LEADER IN THIS
ISSUE. ALSO HAS LEGISLATION
THAT YOU KNOW WE MAY KIND OF
FINE TUNE THIS PROPOSAL TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT ACTUALLY. AT WORK
SO THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS ON
THESE ON THESE TO LARGER ISSUES
I KNOW- AT THE COMMITTEE OUR
STAFF WE WILL. TAKE A LOOK IN
THAT. THAT POTENTIALLY. FINE
TUNE THE OTHER PIECES AS WELL.
I ON THESE ISSUES AS WELL
COMMENTS MEMBER. BY THAT IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YEAH SO IN
REGARDS TO THE SAVING ACCOUNTS-
THE MATE SO. THE MEMBERS OF
ROSES TWO BILLION ONE TIME
FEDERAL ARE PROMOTE DOLLARS TO
ESTABLISH COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS. FOR AN ESTIMATED
THREE POINT SEVEN PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS GRADES ONE THROUGH
SIX. SO IT'S JUST A FEW
QUESTIONS ON HOW THIS IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO WORK IF WE'RE
CREATING THESE ACCOUNTS FOR
STUDENTS ONE TWO SIX ONE. WELL
THE ACCOUNT BE THE ACCOUNT OF
THE CHILD OR CHILD'S FAMILY'S.
PREFERENCE BANKING PREFERENCE
ONE TWO IF THESE CHILDREN LEAVE
AS MANY MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA BECAUSE-
IT'S EXPENSIVE TO LIVE HERE-
WILL THEY STILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE BONDS OR IS IT JUST TO BE
SPENT IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES- I'M JUST
AND LASTLY. I'M TO GET TO- M.
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY
INDIVIDUALS WITH CALLS ACCOUNTS
MIGHT BE MORE SUCCESSFUL I'M A
IT JUST IT ARE WE LOOKING AT A
FROM A HOLISTIC PERSPECTIVE AND
NOT YOU KNOW IF THE CHILD HAS
EIGHTY COLLEGE ACCOUNT- SAVINGS
ACCOUNT IS IT BECAUSE PARENTS
ARE ENGAGED OR OR SOMEBODY IN
THEIR LIFE THAT IS ENGAGED AND
CONTINUALLY MOVING THEM FOR
EXAMPLE RATHER THAN IT JUST
BEING A REALLY YOU KNOW BASIC
YOU HAVE AN ACCOUNT NAMES
YOU'RE MORE LIKELY TO GO TO
COLLEGE. SO- MAYBE V. M. M.
DEPARTED FINANCE COMMAND ON
THIS THANK YOU. YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
I'LL TRY TO ANSWER ALL OF THEM-
SO ON THE FIRST POINT OF LIKE
SAY WE ARE THINKING ON THE
CHANGE IN THE MINDSET OF THE
STUDENT ONE STUDENT KNOWS THAT
THERE ARE SOME MONEY SAVED FOR
AT THE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL TO GO
TO COLLEGE THERE IS A CHANGED.
ARE WE ARE LOOKING AND HOW A
LOT OF THE STUDENTS WHO WILL BE
LOW INCOME- MAYBE THEIR PARENTS
EXACTLY THEY DID NOT ATTEND
COLLEGE THEY MAY NOT EVEN HAVE
A CHECKING ACCOUNT. BUT THAT
THE MINDSET OF THE STUDENT
KNOWING THAT THERE'S MONEY SAVE
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL IS GOING TO
COLLEGE HAS A BIG IMPACT AND
WE'RE LOOKING INTO THE
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY
REDUCTION AS A WAY TO START IN
AN EARLY AGE- I THINK ONE OF
YOUR OTHER QUESTION ONE AS TO
WHAT HAPPENED IF THE STUDENT
DOESN'T ATTEND COLLEGE- THE
CURRENT TRAILER BILL INDICATES
THAT. THE STUDENT HAS UNTIL IT
TURNS THIRTY FIVE YEARS. OLD TO
USE THAT SPACE. IF THEY DON'T
THEM I THEN YOU WOULD JUST BE
RIPPLE TO THE FOR. IT WILL USED
FOR TO. INCLUDING WITH ALL THE
MONEY THAT YOU MAKE GROW DURING
THIS TIME. I WONDER IF I BASS
ANY OTHER UP YOU'VE GOT AND SO
THEN- SO THAT IS THE
EXPECTATION THAT. WE WILL BE
OPENING AN ACCOUNT FOR A CHILD
IN CONTROL THAT ACCOUNT. A GOOD
BILL WILL HAS THE COLLEGE
INVEST BOARD THEY'LL BE ONE
OPENING THE ASK EMPOWER TO
STILL AND THERE WILL BE MANY
THE TO. AND IS THERE AN YOU
KNOW. A. AN OPT OUT IF FFM
DOESN'T WANT OTHER. WE DO
CURRENT TRAILER DOES NOT HAVE
AN OPT OUT BUT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE YOUR SUGGESTIONS TO
MANAGEMENT. OUR GOAL IS THAT IF
NOT GIVEN THE OPTION TO EITHER
OPT THAT OF. OR OFTEN
AUTOMATICALLY THE STUDENT HAS
THE SECOND GROWING UP AND WHEN
THEY STUDENT DETERMINES WHETHER
OR NOT WANTS TO ATTEND TO. AND
IT CREATION OF TRAINING PROGRAM
HIGHLIGHTED THE PATIENT THEN AT
THAT TIME HE CAN MAKE THAT HE
OR SHE CAN MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION. AND IS THERE A
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION THAT
YOU'RE CONSIDERING. TO OPEN
THIS ACCOUNT. AT WE DON'T HAVE
THAT AT THIS MOMENT THE TRAILER
BILL ONLY INDICATES THAT IS
CULTURE INVESTMENT WILL BE BEST
SEEN AT THE SECOND. THANK YOU.
YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
IS THERE GOING TO BE A CAP ON
ADMINISTRATIVE CHARGES FOR
THOSE ACCOUNTS. I WOULD I WOULD
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- IS THERE GONNA
BE ANY DETERMINATION OF WHICH
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION OR- OR
BUSINESS VENTURES WOULD QUALIFY.
FOR WITHDRAWAL OF THOSE FUNDS.
OUR CURRENT TRAILER BILL
REQUIRES SIMILAR TO THE CALKINS
ACCOUNT- TO BE A POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION OR A TRAINING PROGRAM
AT THIS MOMENT GOOD DOES IT
HAVE TO BE IN CALIFORNIA- COULD
BE ANYWHERE. IT HAS TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA OKAY. I MEAN IT JUST
FROM THESE QUESTIONS LIKE. YOU
KNOW. I JUST DON'T THINK
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF THOUGHT
HAS BEEN PUT INTO HOW THIS IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO WORK YOU KNOW
WHAT IF PEOPLE MOVE- YOU KNOW
AS MY COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT-
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS DOESN'T
GET YOU A WHOLE LOT IN
CALIFORNIA LET'S JUST BE. VERY
FRANK. AND FOR MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT ARE STRUGGLING. THEY
DON'T HAVE MONEY TO PUT. YOU
KNOW TO PAY FOR GROCERIES MAN
LET ALONE. PUTTING MONEY INTO A
SAVINGS ACCOUNT SO CHANCES ARE
UNLESS WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT
COST OF LIVING IN. MOST WE DO
SOMETHING ACTUALLY ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY THIS JUST GIVE ME
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS SITTING IN
AN ACCOUNT- PROBABLY A MONEY
MARKET ACCOUNT IS NOT GOING TO
GAIN MUCH INTEREST- THAT. IS
NOT GOING TO BE ALL THAT
HELPFUL AND SO TO ME IT'S JUST
IT'S ANOTHER FLUFF PROPOSAL.
YEAH A LOT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO SAY LOOK
WE'RE LOOK WHAT WE'RE DOING
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE EVERYBODY
FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS IN AN
ACCOUNT. OKAY WELL WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION. TO MAKE IT
MORE EQUITABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY KID TO SUCCEED WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING MORE
ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE UC SYSTEM.
TO ENSURE THAT MORE CALIFORNIA
KIDS ARE GETTING INTO.
UNIVERSITIES THOSE ARE THE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO AND I'D
RATHER TAKE THAT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. IN PUT INTO THINGS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE
THAT DIFFERENCE. RATHER THAN
JUST SITTING INTO AN ACCOUNT.
AND I'VE AND I FEEL LIKE ABOUT
ALMOST ALL OF THESE PROVISIONS
IN THIS LAST PROPOSAL THERE. A
VERY FLAT PROVISIONS- YOU KNOW
YES OF COURSE WE WANT MORE
HOUSING I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
CAMPUS IS. MANY OF THESE
CAMPUSES WERE TALKING ABOUT
DON'T HAVE AVAILABLE ROOMS EVEN
BUILD THAT HOUSE YOU KNOW TO
CONVERT SOMETHING FROM
COMMERCIAL- LET ALONE LIKE. ME
UP AMEND ELDEST DIVERGE FROM MY
COLLEAGUE A LITTLE BIT ON THE
SIDE THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS ONE
WHO KNOWS HOW TO. MANAGE COSTS
AND ENSURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THIS IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY-
BUREAUCRATIC COLLEGE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. I'M SORRY ARE NOT
VERY GOOD BUILDERS AND NOT VERY
GOOD AT BEING COST EFFECTIVE
IT. PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING- SO TO
THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BUILD. AFFORDABLE HOUSING- AT A
REASONABLE LEVEL I THINK IS.
AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW THIS
PROGRAMS GOING TO WORK YOU KNOW
AGAIN THERE'S NO IT NOT EVEN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE YET. ON
IT IS JUST ANOTHER HEY WE'RE
GONNA THROW TWO BILLION DOLLARS
THAT SOMETHING- THAT HOPEFULLY
WILL RESULT IN MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- FOR STUDENTS I I'D
LIKE TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
TARGETED IN THAT- YOU KNOW THE
YES OF COURSE I LOVE SCENE
COLLEGE STUDENTS GETTING
INVOLVED IN SERVICE I DON'T SEE
WHY THEY CAN'T ALREADY DO THAT
THROUGH THAT SO MANY DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE
AMERICORPS- YOU KNOW. TO NAME
ONE BUT JUST SO MANY THAT
SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
ALREADY THERE BUT WE NEED TO
SPEND. WHAT THIRTY MILLION MORE
DOLLARS ON SOME KIND OF NEW
PROGRAM THAT- WHEN THERE'S
ALREADY EXISTING PROGRAM AGAIN
IT'S JUST TOO IS THE SAME
INDICATION OF MORE FLUFF THAT
I'D RATHER PUT THAT MONEY. IN
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THROUGHOUT THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT I THINK ARE GOING
TO MAKE MUCH MORE OF A
DIFFERENCE. FOR KIDS
EDUCATIONAL LONG TERM SO- JUST
LOOKING AT THESE SONIC. ON WHAT
WE'VE GOT THE FORCE WITH LIKE
PRETTY MUCH NO LANGUAGE AND NO
DETAILS THAT I DON'T THINK I
CAN BE VERY SUPPORTIVE. OF
REALLY ANY OF THESE MEASURES AT
THIS POINT. OKAY. WELL. HE HIT
SOMEONE'S RESPONDING THERE GOOD.
S. HI FRIENDS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I DID JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT FOR THE
CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WE DO
HAVE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE-
THAT IT POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE
AND THE FUNDS THEMSELVES FOLLOW
THE STUDENT SO THEY DID NOT
HAVE TO BE IS THE TYPICALLY AT
A CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THE TRAILER
BILL CLASSIFIES THE FUNDING TO
BE USED. FOR QUALIFIED HIGHER
EDUCATION EXPENSES AND OUR
EXPECTATION. THAT THAT THOSE
FUNDS WOULD POLITICS TO THAT.
YES I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
AND ALLOW FOR FORWARD THAN AT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIS
RESEARCH ON COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS AND THIS WAS AN IDEA
THAT WAS THE ASSEMBLY'S
PROPOSAL BEFORE. THE GUN WHEN
GAVIN IS A LIST OF THE TEN A
GOVERNOR AND SO HE'S- EMBRACE
THIS AND HE KNOWS THIS BECAUSE
IN SAN FRANCISCO. THE CITY
TREASURER THERE CREATED ONE OF
THE FIRST ONES IN THE NATION.
ALONG WITH SOME STATES LIKE
OKLAHOMA- IN SOME PLACES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT HAD DONE THIS
AND SHOWN IT VERY SUCCESSFUL
WHERE THEY PICK THEY PICK
KINDERGARTENERS. AND THEY
CREATED THESE THESE COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WHICH I KNOW
THAT I CREATED FOR MY- MY KIDS
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU GUYS HAVE
TWO ENDS FIVE TWENTY NINES
THEY'RE- THEY'RE PORTABLE AND
THEY CAN BE USED FOR ANY
COLLEGE. ATTENDANCE ACROSS THE
NATION AND IF YOU COULD DOESN'T
GO TO COLLEGE. YOU CAN GIVE IT
TO ANOTHER CHILD IN YOUR FAMILY
OR ANOTHER THAT DOES NEED FOR
ANOTHER. INDIVIDUAL AND IF THEY
EVENTUALLY ARE WITHDRAWN
THERE'S MASSIVE PENALTIES YOU
PAY ON THAT SHOW IN THIS CASE
WTH THE MONEY GO BACK TO THE
STATE OF FAMILY LOVE TO. LOOK
AT OOK AT THAT. BUT BUT I WILL
SAY THAT YOU KNOW YES FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS ISN'T GOING TO.
MAKE OR BREAK GOING TO COLLEGE-
YOU KNOW MR GALLAGHER BUT- IF
THE IF THAT. ENVELOPE CONS IN
YOUR HOUSE. YOU KNOW THREE
TIMES A YEAR. EVERY QUARTER
BEFORE TENS A YEAR. AND HAS
THAT KIDS NAME FOR COLLEGE THEN
THE FAMILY STARTS THINKING
ABOUT NOW WHEN THEY HAVE A
BIRTHDAY PARTY MAYBE SO YOU
KNOW WHAT. NO GETS BRING.
TWENTY DOLLARS YOU CAN DEPOSIT
IN THAT COLLEGE FUND. AND
THERE'S BEEN RESEARCH UPON
RESEARCH THAT SHOWS THAT
REALISTIC REALLY. DOES INCREASE.
S. OF CALL. ATTAIN AND THIS IS
A PIECE OF THE PUZZLE IN OUR
ECONOMY WE NEED MORE PEOPLE
GOING TO COLLEGE THAT THE
SYSTRACE IT WE HAVE THIS. THIS
MASSIVE DEFICIT OF COLLEGE
GRADUATES THE NEXT YOU KNOW
FIVE TO TEN YEARS THAT. P. P.
I. C. TALKS ABOUT. AND WE NEED
MORE PEOPLE- PREPARING AND
GOING ON TO COLLEGE SO. THIS
HAS BEEN- RESEARCHED AND SHOWN
TO WORK ACROSS OUR OUR COUNTRY
ON THE GLOBE. AND IT'S BEEN
BIPARTISAN I'LL GIVE YOU THAT
THIS HAS BEEN PROPOSED BY. YOU
KNOW REPUBLICAN U. S. SENATORS
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY AS WELL. AND
I THINK THAT IT'S A REALLY
SOUND INVESTMENT I'M EXCITED
CALIFORNIA IS STEPPING UP WE DO
NEED TO- MAKE SURE THAT WE
IMPLEMENTED. WELL SO DID THE
TRAILER BILL BUT ALSO WE HAVE
SOMEONE IS THERE AND HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THIS LEGISLATION FOR
TWO YEARS. AND THAT IT IS NOT
WE DON'T USE THE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION IN SCHOLARSHIP.
THERE ARE THEIR PREEMINENCE TO
SEND. IN THE COUNTRY IN
INVESTING MONEY FOR COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO YOU KNOW FOCUS ON. IS
GOING TO BE THAT. THE BANK WE
ALREADY HAVE YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
REINVENTING THE WHEEL IT'S OURS
IT'S OUR SCHOLARSHIP. SAVING
STRESSED AND THEN FOR THE
STUDENT HELP FOR THE STUDENT
HOUSING. I AGREE I AGREE MR
GALLAGHER WE SHOULDN'T DO
ANYTHING NEW AND COMPLICATED WE
SHOULD JUST. HOW DO WE HELP OUR
CAMPUSES BUILD MORE STUDENT
HOUSING WHETHER IT'S SEX ST
CHICO UC. SAN DIEGO SANTA
BARBARA FULLER TEN WHEREVER
THEY THERE'S NOT ENOUGH STUDENT
HOUSING ON THESE CAMPUSES. AND
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE REASON
WHY STUDENTS. SPEND SO MUCH
MONEY IS THE NON TUITION COSTS
INCLUDING HOUSING SO. ALWAYS
CAMPUS HAVE LANDS WE TALK TO
THE CHANCELLORS AND PRESIDENTS
LAST YEAR AND A HALF. AND THEY
SAID WE WOULD LOVE. TO BUILD
MORE STUDENT HOUSING BUT WE
COULD WE COULD IT COULD REALLY
HELP US IF WE HAVE- ZERO
INTEREST LOANS OR GRANTS TO
HELP US FINANCE STUDENT HOUSING
ON OUR CAMPUSES AND SO. THIS IS
WHAT- THE MONEY OUR OUR OUR
INDICATION. IT'LL BE USED FOR
AND WE'RE GOING TO FINE TUNE
THE APOSTLE TO MAKE SURE IT
ACTUALLY TO WORK. SO WITH THAT-
FURTHER FURTHER QUESTIONS-
THING NINE WE WILL HOLD THESE
ISSUES OPEN AND IT'S- NEARLY
ONE O'CLOCK AND SO WE WILL NOW.
AND PROCEED TO PUBLIC. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE. ON
THE LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE- WE HAVE YOU THERE. WE DO
INDEED THERE'S A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE QUEUED UP. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WANT TO HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR ALL THE TOPICS
RIGHT NOW YES PLEASE ALSO BE
JUST A GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ALL THE ITEMS. THANK YOU TO
SHOW OUR SUPPORT- OR OR-
OPPOSITION FOR ALL ITEMS PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT OPPOSITION- ALL THE
ISSUES TODAY. ARE FIRST
PARTICIPANT IS ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY SEVEN.
I'M SO GLAD TO KEEP GO TO LINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I KITCHEN AND OF THE
OF THE CAN FOR COLLEGE ATHLETES.
PROVIDING COMICS THE COURT
AGREED ABOUT AT A CRITICAL TO.
COLLEGE AND AFFORDABILITY.
FIRST TO THE FUNDING INCREASES
FOR THE FEW YOU NEED
INVESTMENTS HERE IN HIGHER AT
PRACTICAL. INCREASING STATE
REVENUE THANK THE SHACK GAPS IN
DEGREE CONTENT ATTAINMENT.
THANK YOU WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK CHEN MCCARTY AND NUMBER.
FURTHER FOR LEADERSHIP IN
MOVING TO CAL GRANT FOR. AFTER
CODE BUT ENEMY COMMISSION. WE
STRONGLY GROUPS WILL WOULD
REMOVE BARRIERS TO EIGHT FOR
TWO EIGHTY THOUSAND TODAY.
CREATING ADDITIONAL COMPLICATED
LAYERED. AFFECTED INSURING THAT
STUDENTS HAVE A CLEAR ROADMAP
TO SUCCESSFULLY TRACK RECORD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. IT MIX
WITH A LINE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU TOO YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STOP NOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE GOVERNOR FOR
ALL THE POSITIVE PROPOSAL- IN
THE MAIN. REVISION WE THINK THE
FIVE POINT 007% DIFFICULT FOR
K. TWELVE IS EXCELLENT BUT WE
pSHOULD ALSO REPEATED THE
PROPOSAL AND- WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ALLOCATION
FOR IT THE CAT I THANK GOD
PLEASE SEPARATE THE DANCE
PROGRAM. BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM
EXPECTED TO COMPLETE COLLEGE
CREDITS BY THE. POLICE AS WELL
THANK YOU. WE WILL ALIGN TO SIX
PLEASE CALL. REALLY ROSENBERG
WITH THE FBI- WE WERE PIECE OF
THE COMING FIFTY ABOUT ACCESS
TO THE POINT OF- HOWEVER WE
THEM BUT EACH YEAR YOU WERE
FEET. VERY LITTLE AROUND LABOR
WE THAT HAPPENED BACK WHEN I
THERE WAIT A JAZZ- AND MAKE
STUDENTS HAVE- YOU KNOW
CONTINUE OTHER EDUCATION
THROUGHOUT THE PEN- WHEN WE
RESTORE THE DOLLARS FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY BECAUSE WE DID
NOT REQUIRE THEM TO RE HIRE
THOSE ARE LAID OFF. WE ALSO
WOULD URGE CONSIDERATION FOR
INSURING THAT FACULTY IS
RESTORED- AND WE INCREASE
FACULTY HIRING AS WELL AS
ADDRESS THE STAGNANT WAGES THAT
OCCUPIED SPACE- WITH INVERTED
SALARY THANK YOU. MINDSET YOUR-
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
EXTENDED OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS
SERVICES ASSOCIATION WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE ADDITIONAL
DREAMER LIAISON FUNDING ANIME
REVISED ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE PROPOSAL TO HAVE THE
DEFERRAL OF THE CALL INCREASE
ALTHOUGH WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
MATCH K. TWELVE WITHOUT THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS
REMOVING COAL CONTINGENCIES
HOWEVER WE STILL BELIEVE THE
PROPOSAL FOR A 10% INCREASE AND
ONLINE ARE OFFERING IS
ARBITRARY. WE'RE DISAPPOINTED
WITH THE LACK FUNDING THAT THE
KIDS PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE
HOURS AND FULL TIME FACULTY
HIRING AND WE AGREE WITH THE
POINTS MADE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA REGARDING CALIBRATE. AND
SUPPORT EXPLANATION THANK YOU.
ONE SEVEN TWO YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE GET MCCARTY
MEMBERS AND STAFF MY NAME IS
LARRY FRANK UCLA LABOR CENTER
THE LABOR STANDARDS BEEN IN
THAT LEAGUE BUILDING NEAR
DOWNTOWN LA THE PAST NINETEEN
YEARS IF YOU LIKE PURCHASED IN
NINETEEN FORTY WHEN BUILDING
LAST YEAR WHEN IT WAS PUT ON
THE MARKET BUT IT NEEDS
SIGNIFICANT WORK TO BE
COMPLIANT. I WOULD RAISE NEARLY
TWO MILLION OVER THE LAST
DECADE IN THE FIFTEEN MILLION
CONCERT NATIONAL AFTER IT WILL
GET US TO THE FINISH LINE YOU
OUGHT TO BE THE BASIS FOR THE
NAMING THE BUILDING AFTER CIVIL
RIGHTS AND WORKERS RIGHTS ICON
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON JUNIOR HI
THIS ITEM STARTED THE MEMBER
REQUEST BY FAMILY MEMBERS JONES
SAWYER AND SANTIAGO ALONG WITH
SENATOR. AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT IT THAT IT BREAKS
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
OTHERS- WE SUBMITTED MATERIALS
ON THE WORK OF THESE DELIVER
CENTER REQUESTING THE SUPPORT
OF YOUR BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE THIS WORK
IN THE COMMUNITY IN SUPPORT OF
THE COMPANY OF LABOR AND
WORKFORCE. DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND WE ARE
GONNA GO TO. SIXTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD MCI ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE STAND PORTANTINO'S YUBA.
PERALTA KERN SAN FRANCISCO LOS
ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. TWO POINTS WE
AGREE WITH THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAILS ON THE ADDITIONAL 1% BASE
INCREASE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS WERE SUPPORTIVE BUT
THE CODE NINETEEN BLOCK GRANT
PROPOSAL AND ON THE ZERO COST
TEXTBOOK. PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE
THAT THE GRANT LEVELS IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ARE TOO
LOW TO CREATE A QUALITY
ALTERNATIVE. TEXTBOOKS THANK
YOU. CAN YOU CHECK MOVING ALONG
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON LARA BARBECUE THAT'S
WHAT THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS WE ARE
PLEASED THE REVISED BUDGET
RETAIN PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS THAT'S ABOUT
SUPPORT COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
INCLUDING MORE COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT IN THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM WELL WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNITION OF THE BURDEN OF
NON TUITION COSTS. IN A
PROPOSED THE BEST YOU COULD
DRAFT UNDERLYING COST DRIVERS
AS DISCUSSED TODAY FURTHER
STRENGTHENING THE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT ARE STATE POLICE
REPORT STUDENTS RELY ON TODAY
ACCESS TO SUCCEED IN COLLEGE
REMAINS A CRITICAL PRIORITY FOR
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE BUDGET.
INCLUDES ADDRESSING THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS STRUCTURAL
LIMITATION BY EXTENDING AN
ENTITLEMENT AWARD TO AT LEAST
ALL STUDENTS WITH PELL GRANT
ELIGIBLE FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND PROVIDING
ROBUST FACT TO WORKER NANTWICH
IN COST AS LAID OUT IN THE CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK AND
REFLECTED IN PRIORITIES FROM
BOTH CHAMBERS INCLUDING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND CHER
MCCARTY AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THESE CRITICAL REFORMS. WHICH
WE HOPE TO SEE IN THE FINAL
BUDGET. WINDS SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIFTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE ON MUTE. I WILL MOVE
ALONG THE LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ERICA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WERE
GRATEFUL FOR A VERY GOOD BUDGET
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ACADEMIC OUTREACH
PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS FUNDING TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP AT
ALL OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS. FURTHER WE LIKE
TO SEE FOR THE STRENGTHENING OF
THE FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS AND
FINALLY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
REGIONAL COLLABORATIONS TO
CLOSE ACHIEVEMENT AND EQUITY
CAPS FOR OUR STUDENTS ACROSS
THE CUTS. ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU. PINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY SIX
PEOPLE NEAR ME WE CAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS ENTERED
IT CAN NOT BE HALF THE STUDENT
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE OFFICIAL VOICE THE
TWO POINT ONE MILLION COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF WEBSTER THE FARES
AND STUDENT APPLE FROM MY
COLLEGE WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
IN SUPPORT OF ALMOST ALL THE
GOVERNOR'S YOU FOLKS TO POLLS
IN THE IN THE BUDGET.
ESPECIALLY THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS SET ASIDE FOR BASIC
NEEDS TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE COMMENTS WE DO NOT
SUPPORT THE COLOCATION OF BASIC
NEEDS CENTERS IN FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES BUT DO ENCOURAGE
COOPERATION WE WOULD POINT TO
AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE IS THE
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE FOR
CLARIFICATIONS AND TO ANSWER A
SOME OF OUR MEDINA IS-
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL
WE ALSO URGE ADOPTION. OF THE
COMMON EQUITY FRAMEWORK THANK
YOU. MY NINETY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
THREE CAN YOU HEAR ME. INDEED
HI MY NAME IS ROBIN KIANA
BUSINESS INSTRUCTOR AT CITY
COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO THANKS
FOR THE CHANCE TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY I'M REQUESTING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO FULLY FUND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND GIVE US
THE RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS WHAT WE
REALLY NEED IS FOR YOU ALL TO
EXTEND THE HOLD HARMLESS AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO PROVIDE
STABILITY WHILE WE RECOVER WE
NEED YOU TO INCREASE THE
COLLECTOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT ADDITIONAL 1% TO MATCH THE
COLOR IN K. TWELVE SCHOOLS CSU
AND UC. AS WELL AS REMOVING THE
CONTINGENCIES AND LASTLY WE
URGE YOU TO ELIMINATE CALIBRATE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND WE WILL GO TO ONE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY TWO
ARE YOU MUTED. PLEASE ON MUTE
NINETY TWO. HAVING A LOT
AFTERNOON CORRECT GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JASON
NEWMAN AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE LOS REALES COLLEGE
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS IN
SACRAMENTO. I REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO FULLY FUND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND GIVE US
THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS. IT'S
VITAL THAT WE EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO
PROVIDE STABILITY. INCREASE THE
KOLHAPUR COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND
ADDITIONAL 1% TO MATCH COLORS
IN K. TWELVE SCHOOLS CSU IN THE
UC. AS WELL AS REMOVE THE
CONTINGENCY LASTLY WE ARE THE
LEGISLATURE TO LIMITING CAL
BRIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING OUR COMMUNITY CALLED.
ANNEX'S LINE NINETY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES MY NAME IS MERRY BRAVE
WOMAN VICE PRESIDENT OF A THREE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE IT TO THE
COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO AND UP
I AM REQUESTING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO FULLY FUND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND GIVE US
THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS IT IS
VITAL THAT WE EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR THE DISH MOVIE
HERE TO PROVIDE STABILITY
INCREASE THE COOPER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BECAUSE IT MATCHES K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS- CSU AND UC AS
WELL AS WITH THE CONTINGENCIES.
LASTLY WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ELIMINATE HELP RIGHT THANK
YOU. FOR SUPPORTING OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THANK YOU
NEXT. TWENTY YOUR OPEN. HERE.
HELLO- I'M CUANDO IF THE BAY
BIT THE WITH THE U. S. STUDENTS
WOULD LIKE TO EIGHT FROM INVEST
INTO THE NATION'S MOST CONTENT
PUBLIC SYSTEM HAD A DOING IN A
THE FINAL BUT WE HOPE THAT YOU
PRIORITIZE ADDITIONAL VOTED
THAT THE CABINET SYSTEM WE THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE IN. DEPORTING
CAL TO BASIC NEEDS BUT WE
BELIEVE REFORM NECESSARY TO
FULLY OUR STUDENTS SEEING THE
SENATE'S VOTE BACK WILL BE
BUDGET PRIOR IN CONSTRAINTS THE
COVER OF TIME WE BELIEVE THOSE
PER ABOUT. COUPLED WITH A FORTY
FIFTY SIX WHICH YOU THE COPPER
BEFORE STUDENTS BEEN NOT FOR
THANK YOU FOR TO MEMBER MEDINA
PROOF THAT COMMIT AND LET- ONE
AND NOT FOR A SIX BY AID. MY
NAME EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME KAREN- A PART
TIME YES ON AT LANEY COLLEGE
AND ALSO AT- THAT COULD
COLLEGES NEVER DISCO- I WAS
UNTIL I GOT LAID OFF WITH THE
OTHER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PART
TIMERS LAST- LAST YEAR- I
REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO FULLY FUND
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND GIVE
US THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS. IT'S
VITAL THAT WE EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO
PROVIDE STABILITY INCREASE THE
CALL OPPORTUNITY COLLEGES AN
ADDITIONAL 1% TO MATCH COLORS
IN K. TWELVE SCHOOLS IF YOU AND
THE C. AS WELL TO MOVE THE
CONTINGENCIES AND LASTLY WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ELIMINATE CAL RIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORTING. OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LETTING YOU SPEAK. ONE
OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANYOU HEAR ME THIS THEN THAT
WOULD YES. WONDERFUL SO MY NAME
IS SUSAN AT WOOD I AM THE
TREASURER OF THE RETIREES
CHAPTER ADD. FAVORITES IF THE
CITY COLLEGE. AND ALONG WITH
ALL MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN ON
THE LINE ALREADY I REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO FULLY FUND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND GIVE US
THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC. AND
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS. I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO PUSH FOR A
READ P. ALL OF THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA. THIS
FORMULA ALTHOUGH IT PRETENDS TO
HELP POOR AND DIVERSE STUDENTS
DOESN'T DO THAT. BECAUSE IT
EMPHASIZES FULL TIME STUDENT.
AND IT DOESN'T HELP POOR
STUDENTS THAT HAVE TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES. SECONDS I WOULD
LIKE US TO INCREASE THE COAL OF
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AN
ADDITIONAL 1% TO MATCH THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE. AND REMOVED
CONTINGENCIES AND LASTLY TO GET
RID OF CALIBRATE WHICH IS
WASTED THAT MONEY WHEN WE
REALLY NEEDED TO HELP OUR POOR
STUDENTS AT CITY COLLEGE AND
ALL THE OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NINE ONE HUNDRED SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON KHAKI WITH
MCCUE CAPTAIN THE THIRTIETH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ADULTS EDUCATION.
AND CALIFORNIA'S DUAL EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION
TODAY I AM CALLING WHEN WITH
REGARD TO THE COLOR FOR ADULT
EDUCATION WE FIND OURSELVES
HIGHLY DISAPPOINTED THAT AMID
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT STATE
SURPLUS A COLD FRONTAL
EDUCATION REMAIN SO LOW FOR
SUCH IMPORTANT PROGRAM. AS YOU
RECALL ADULT EDUCATION PROPOSED
COLA FOR THE CURRENT BUDGET
YEAR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WAS RESCINDED LAST YEAR
AMID ECONOMIC CONCERNS
ASSOCIATED DAM PANDEMIC BETWEEN
A LACK OF COAL WELL DESPITE
YEAR AND INCREASING COSTS
INCLUDING BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
ARE OFTEN ALIGNED WITH OUR K.
TWELVE SYSTEM. I DON'T SCHOOLS
WILL BE FORCED TO CLOSE CLASSES
PROGRAMMING TO DROPS ONGOING
COST PRESSURES FOR MOST
MARGINALIZED ADULTS IN NEED OF
CRITICAL PROGRAMMING AND ESL
CITIZENSHIP BASIC SKILLS IN
SHORT TERM CAREER TRAINING. TO
THAT END WE URGE THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO MAKE ADULT
EDUCATION BEYOND ITS MOST
MARGINALIZED ADULTS IN THE
STATE AS A PRIORITY AND
INCREASE IT'LL EDUCATION COLA
THE STATE NEEDS TO AVOID
SHORTCHANGING THE STUDENTS WE
SERVE DOWN TO MEET ACCESS AND
YET ANOTHER BUDGET YEAR.
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE STAFF
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES WITH THE TINY HOUSE
AND PROCESS TO DISTRIBUTE THE
ADULT EDUCATION FUNDING AND
APPRECIATE ARE YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE THE. CONVERSATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. YNAB TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I IS DEBBIE
RUSHER WE JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
EACH WE SUPPORT THE GUY TO
ALLOCATE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE BASIC
NEEDS WE ALSO REQUEST THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE REFLECT
THE PROVISIONS OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN. A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN FINANCIAL
AID AND BASIC NEEDS SERVICES IS
ESSENTIAL WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AS
PROPOSAL TO COMBINE BASIC NEEDS
AND FINANCIAL AID SERVICES
WOULD BE IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF STUDENTS AT THIS TIME I
WOULD ALSO UNDERMINE THE
INCREDIBLE WORK THE CAMPUSES
HAVE DONE ON THIS ISSUE. TO
DATE THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING
ARAMBULA AFTERNOON I SHOULD
SAY- LEVERAGE AND MISTER CHAIR-
MONEY QUESTIONS THE BILL'S
HOUSTON ASSOCIATION ARE WE WANT
YOU ARE SIMILARLY A COUPLE OF
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR WORKFORCE
WHO SAID AND THAT WE NEED TO
PERFORM CAL GRANT AND WE NEED
TO INVEST IN BROADBAND REFORM
R. AND B. AS AN ORGANIZATION
HAVE BEEN POPPING SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY FIFTY SIX AND A POINTS.
OUT THAT AN OUTLINE IN THAT
LEGISLATION WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE THE LEGISLATURE TAKE
ACTIONS IN FUNDING BACK IN
ADDITION CALL YOU KNOW IN THE
AGENDA THERE WAS THE QUESTION
ASKED ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
OPPORTUNITIES YOU SPECIFICALLY
BUT THIS IS NOT EXCLUSIVE TO
ISSUE AND ME AT LEAST YOU CAN
ASSOCIATION FEEL THAT WE HAD A
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR THAT WOULD
HAVE DONE JUST THAT- FUNDING
STATE THAT. ONE OF THE KEY
CHALLENGES SO THAT MORE
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO FIND NOT SIXTEEN
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT MOVIE REFLECTED IN
THAT- BUDGET THAT BEEN
PROPOSED. HE WAS VERY MUCH WANT
TO ONCE AGAIN ASK FOR FUNDING
TO THE PROGRAM BOB ASK MR
TWENTY MILLION ONGOING INTO
THAT PROGRAMS AND WE WOULD LOVE
TO BOB DYLAN. TAKE ACTIVE STEPS
IN FRONT THAT AS WELL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THE PROPOSED
INCREASE OF FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME FUNDS TO SUPPORT ANALYSIS
AND RESEARCH ASSOCIATED WITH
PREVENTION OF HATE INCIDENTS.
BY EACH AMERICAN PACIFIC
COMMITTED TO THE DAIRY PLAINLY
AS ANC IS LOOKING TO CONDUCT
RESEARCH ON HATE CRIMES AND
INCIDENTS THE CALIFORNIA
DEVELOP EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
AND TRAINING TO ADDRESS
RACIALLY MOTIVATED HATE.
IMPROVE STRUCTURES FOR
REPORTING AND CONTINUE FUNDING
TO OUR COMMUNITY BASED PARTNER
AT ADDRESSING THE RIGHT EVENT
PAGE THE HATE. THAT WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT IN FAVOR OF THE
FUNDING OF THE PROPOSAL THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WEEK PLEASE.
AND WE WILL ALIGN FIFTY YOU ARE
OPEN. SCHERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHEILA ON
THE VETERINARIAN I AM A STUDENT
AT MONTANA TURN YOUR COLLEGE AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE STATING I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
REGARDING A WIDE VARIETY OF
ISSUES AFFECTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS I PERSONALLY
IN HERE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION
ESPECIALLY THE THIRTY MILLION
ONGOING FUNDING TO SUPPORT
BASIC NEEDS CENTERS AND
BASICALLY COORDINATOR.
ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT THE
LANGUAGE AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A
LINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
ROB AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
STUDENT ACTIVITIES AN
OUTRAGEOUS HANCOCK COLLEGE. I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT THERE BE
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE THAT IS
AFFECTED AND ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SEVENTY FIVE. GET
CAMPUS IS LIKE MINE PUTS
ABILITY TO BEST SERVE OUR
STUDENTS. WE HOPE TO BUILD ON
THE SUCCESSFUL EFFORT
UNDERTAKEN TO DATE SACRAMENTO
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENSURING THAT
EVERY CAMPUS OFFERS A BASELINE
OF SUPPORT. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. FIVE
ONE OH THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS MEGHAN
LOW FOR ON BEHALF OF AN
STRUCTURE WE ARE CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
AMENDED LANGUAGE CALLING FOR
COMMON ENTERTAINMENT A LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS LEGALLY THAT
COMMON ALAMAT SUPPORT TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND WILL HELP LEAD TO
BETTER EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
ADDITIONALLY WE BELIEVE THAT
OUR COMMON ALABAMA PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY BUILDING BLOCK FOR
FUTURE POLLS RELATED TO
TRACKING EQUITABLE STUDENT
SUCCESS. AND FUTURE EFFORTS
RELATED TO CRADLE TO CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A AND
YOU WANT TO GIVE US THE
CALIFORNIA'S PRETTY COSTLY-
CUBICLES LOOK AT CALIFORNIA BUT
WE WANTED TO PICK THE GOVERNOR
FOR FUNDING THE LEAGUE'S TOP
PRIORITIES AND IMPLEMENT
PROJECTS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE ALSO WANTED CURRENTLY
SUPPLEMENTAL 1% INCREASE THE
PACE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THREE
OTHER SEGMENTS HAVE RECEIVED.
PACKAGES AND WHAT WHAT PROBABLY
TRANCE SAID IN HER TESTIMONY OR
QUESTIONS EARLIER TODAY BUT
ALSO TO CONTINUE ADVOCATE FOR
PARTICULAR REFORM COULD SUPPORT
AND I APPRECIATE THAT CAN CARDS
CONSTANT COVERAGE COLLINS ON
THAT ISSUE I WOULD ENCOURAGE A
COMPANY DOESN'T ACTUALLY
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN PASS WITH SUPPORTERS
GROUPS WITH THE FURNACE LIKE
NEEDS. TO HAPPEN THANKS FOR
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY. YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU JOHN MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M JUST HAN
STEVEN SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE. MR BY
THANKING YOU FOR LEADING THE
CALL IN PRIORITIZING CAL GRANT
WITH FORMS AND WEREN'T COURAGE
BY YOUR CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK
I PROPOSED IN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX. WE ARE ALSO PLEASED TO SEE
THAT THE MAY REVISED BUILD ON
THE JANUARY PROPOSALS THAT
PROVIDE DIRECT RELIEF TO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. WITH NEW
INVESTMENTS IN BASIC NEEDS
CENTER THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
GRANT TO RESKILL AND UPSKILL
DISPLACED WORKERS. EXCITING THE
MAY REVISED ALSO. ENERGY
PROPOSALS INCLUDING AN HISTORIC
INVESTMENT INSTRUMENT HOUSING
AND COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
FOR LOW INCOME Q. THREE TRUCKS
TO THAT. WHILE THE DETAILS OF
THE PROPOSALS NEED TO BE
EXAMINED WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
POTENTIAL THIS PROPOSAL CALLED
FOR STUDENT. THANK YOU. WE WILL
ALIGN SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JOHN KATZMAN THE PROBATIVE
HUMBOLDT STATE AND SPEAKING IN
FAVOR OF FUNDING FOR HUMBOLDT
BECOME A POLYTECHNIC HUMBLED AS
THE POLYTECHNIC WILL NEED IT
LIKE CREATE ACCESS AND ROMAN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS I
CAN TELL ON ROMAN AND THREE
YEARS TO ELEVEN THOUSAND
DIDN'T. FUMBLED IS COMMITTED TO
DIVERSITY WITHIN THE COMMISSION
AND IS IN THE FABRIC OF OUR
POLYTECHNICS LAND 55% OF OUR
STEM STUDENTS ARE WOMEN OVER
40% OF OUR STEM STUDENTS ARE
FOR UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES
THE FIGURES ARE MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
POLYTECHNIC IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILL QUICKLY ADDRESS
WORKFORCE GAPS AT ACCESS FOR
STUDENTS. AND DRIVE THE ECONOMY
THANK YOU. PFIZER ONE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER SHINNOK PM A CHEMISTRY
INSTRUCTOR AT MERRITT COLLEGE
AND BECAUSE OF ALL THE
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS THERE HE
LOCAL THANK YOU KNOW THREE I'D
LIKE TO- GIVE ME GRATITUDE FOR
BETTER FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
IN OUR REQUEST. THAT THE
LEGISLATOR TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO FULLY FUND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR HALF DAY
THAT YOU EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS FUNDING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE A FULL COLLEGE SYSTEM
FOR OUR STUDENTS TO RETURN TO
AFTER THE PANDEMIC. AN
INCREDIBLE INCREASE THE
COLLECTOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY
AN ADDITIONAL 1% TO MATCH THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE BE A IF
YOU'RE A NEW PIZZA SOME THERE'S
NO REASON TO EXACERBATE THE GAP
THAT ALREADY EXISTS. AND
FINALLY WE ASK YOU ONCE AGAIN
TO ELIMINATE CALIBRATE COLLEGE
FROM THE BUDGET THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED. SUPPORT OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND WE WERE
GO TO LINE. NINETY THREE YOUR-
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MY NAME
IS KATE HURLEY AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CORRECT SHELTER MEDICINE
PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS. AS THE
FIRST SHELTER MEDICINE PROGRAM
IN THE WORLD WE HAVE SPENT THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS RESEARCHING
THE BEST PRACTICES TO KEEP PETS
HEALTHY SAFE AND HOME WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL AS MEET
THE STATE'S GOAL THAT NO
HEALTHY OR TREATABLE ANIMAL BE
EUTHANIZED. THE PROPOSED ANIMAL
SHELTER GRANT PROGRAMS WOULD
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE THE
CRITICAL COMBINATION. OF
TRAINING AND RESOURCES. TO
TRANSLATE THOSE BEST PRACTICES
INTO REALITY ACROSS THE STATE.
AND ESPECIALLY IN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT CONTINUE TO
SEE MORE PASSED ENTER SHELTER.
SHELTERS AND FEWER LEAVE ALIVE.
ANIMAL ISSUES TRULY ARE HUMAN
ISSUES AFFECTING EVERYTHING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. THIS ONE TIME FIVE YEAR
INVESTMENT WOULD LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR EVERY SHELTER IN
EVERY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
URBAN ARE WORLDS NORTH SOUTH OR
CENTRAL. TO SUCCEED IN THEIR
CRITICAL WORK THROUGH THE CALL
THE RECOVERY AND BEYOND IN
ALIGNMENT WITH OUR STATE HUMANE
VALUES AND TWENTY YEAR OLD
POLICY GOAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
HISTORIC PROPOSAL. AND WE WILL
MOVE ALONG TO LINE ONE OH ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS TRACY MORE ON THE
ANIMAL SERVICES MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF CHICO I RUN A SMALL
MUNICIPAL SHELTER IN BUTTE
COUNTY AND I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE ANIMAL SHELTER
GRANT PROGRAMS. OUR COMMUNITY
WAS STILL TRYING TO RECOVER
FROM THE CAMPFIRE THE HOUSING
CHALLENGES IT CREATED AND THE
LOSS OF VETERINARIANS WHEN THE
PANDEMIC HIT. THE PANDEMIC
FURTHER REDUCE ACCESS TO
VETERINARY CARE FOR BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND THE SHELTER. THE
NORTH COMPLEX FIRE DURING THE
ENDEMIC JUST COMPOUNDED THOSE
ISSUES. DOCTORS WILL CONTINUE
TO BE IMPACTED AS HOUSING
BECOMES LESS AFFORDABLE AND
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR HOMES DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND WILDFIRES. FOR
OWNERS CANNOT ACCESS VETERINARY
CARE FORCING THEM TO GIVE UP
THEIR PATENT FOR THE SHELTER
GRANT PROGRAM WILL BE A MUCH
NEEDED BOOST FOR OUR STATE
SHELTERS WITH WITH RECOVERY
FROM THE PANDEMIC. PROVIDE
RESPONSE DURING DISASTERS
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITIES AND IMPLEMENT BEST
PRACTICES TO MAXIMIZE THE
NUMBER OF ANIMALS WHOSE LIVES
ARE SAVED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. AND
LATER IF YOU'RE LINE IS OPEN AT
THE SPEAKER OR CO HOST. A
WITNESS- PLEASE MAKE YOUR
PHONES WERE NOT SPEAKING THANK
YOU AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JOE PARKER AND I'M THE
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF THE HUNDREDS OF MUNICIPAL
AND NON PROFIT SHELTER AND
REPRESENT. I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDS SUPPOSED
TO DEVELOP A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
ANIMAL SHELTERS. ANIMAL
SHELTERS RECEIVE NO STATE
FUNDING AND THE DISPARITY OF
RESOURCES AMONG THESE AGENCIES
THE SIGNIFICANT. MORE SUPPORT
IS NEEDED TO HELP OUR STATE
STATE SAVE ALL HEALTHY AND
TREATABLE PASS AND EFFECTIVELY
RESPOND IN DISASTERS. MANY
SHELTERS ARE FACING SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET CUTS TO THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CREATING A
CRISIS THAT MAY VERY WELL COST
ANIMALS THEIR LIVES. THESE
GRANT FUNDS AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH THE EXPERTS FROM
THE UC DAVIS TEAM WILL HELP
IMPROVE OPERATIONS AND BUILD
LIFESAVING CAPACITY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. BY
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
AM THREE SALTERS I'M CALLING IN
FULL SUPPORT OF REQUEST A FULL
REFUND. BUT A NATIONAL BUDGET
REQUESTED INCLUDED SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A TO
ENSURE A BLACK STUDENT SUCCESS
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND YOU'RE NOT
CONTEMPLATING HOW YOU MIGHT
REPURPOSE FUNDING INCLUDING THE
ELIMINATION OF CALVARY I TRULY.
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER
FULLY FUNDING. AMONG THE
EDUCATION FOUNDATION EIGHT TWO
MEN AND THE H. B. C. U.
TRANSFER PROGRAM THAT AWAITING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE SIX
CLEARING INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY
TO BUILD AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENT SUCCESS AND ALLOW FOR
THE CONTINUOUS PROGRAMMATIC
EXPANSION AT ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THESE PROGRAMS ARE THE ONLY
RECOGNIZE BLACKS BECAUSE
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE AND ARE
COUNTING ON YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THESE EFFORTS.
PLEASE CONSIDER ALL OVER THE
NUMBER THREE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO CLEAN
CONTINUE THIS WORK AND WE IT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE SOME DEEP.
THOUGHT ON YOUR PART BUT PLEASE
CONSIDER HELPING US BASED
PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. MORE ON LINE NINETY
NINE GO AHEAD. HELLO OUR
MANAGER THIS VERY THE HISTORY
AT COLLEGE ON- I'M CALLING-
THANK YOU- YOUR YOUR WORK
COLLEGE AND AFTER THAT YOU TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO APPOINT
FUND OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
GIVE US A RESOURCE BASED. TO
RECOVER FROM THE TENDECK ANSWER
QUESTIONS SOLOMON THOSE THINGS
WE'D LIKE TO ASK THAT YOU
EXTEND THE HOLD HARMLESS
ADDITIONAL YEAR LOW TO PROVIDE
OF STABILITY- HAVE YOU COME
BACK TO WHATEVER NORMAL GOING
TO LOOK LIKE- TO INCREASE THE
POLITECNICO AS ADDITIONAL 1% TO
MATCH THE COLOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. CSU'S NBC AS WELL AS
WE WILL GET TO THE STATE AND WE
LAST WE URGE THAT YOU- WHEN
THEY CALIBRATE YEAH SO I'M
THANK BRIDGEPORT. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES A GREAT DAY BYE. ONE
ONE HOW NINE GOING. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER BUT BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY YOU MEAN SOCIETY
AND THE THING ABOUT THIS GIRL
ED PA AND THE PORT OF THE ONE
TIME FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A STATE GRANT IN TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR ANIMAL SHELTERSTHE
FUNDING MODEL CALIFORNIA
REALIZED THE TWENTY YEAR OLD
POLICY THAT NO HEALTHIER
TREATABLE ANIMAL BE EUTHANIZED.
YESTERDAY THE PROGRAM IS WELL
POSITIONED MAKE TARGETED
CAPITAL SUPPORT AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST IN A CRITICAL LIFESAVING
RECOVERY AND DISASTER RESPONSE
NEED FOR ANIMAL SHELTERS THE
BURDEN HAS ALWAYS FELT NOT IN
COMMUNITY BUT THE MOST
VULNERABLE HUMAN POPULATIONS ON
A LEASE FOR SARGSYAN WHAT
SHELTERS WE ARE JUST A PART OF
THAT EFFORT BY UC'S EXPERT. TO
ADDRESS THE DISPARITY THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL LIGHTS SIX YOUR-
THANK YOU MY MOTHER. BOTH WE
ARE SUPPORTER OF THE THIRTY MIN
INCLUDE THE GOVERNOR MAYBE TO
COMMITTEE COLLEGE TO BASICALLY.
AVERAGE LOBSTER MARKS WE DO NOT
SUPPORT- FUNDING GOING TO
INSTANTIATE OFFICES OUR
NAVIGATOR EXPRESS NEED FOR
BASIC NEEDS CENTER THANK JOBS
LEARNED BY THAT CAN BE COLLEGES
HOWEVER- ANYONE WHO HAS SET
FOOT INTO GRADUATE OFFICE DOES
NOT SPACER THOSE SPECIFIC
NEEDS. WE NEED A SAFE SPACE TO
ADD A FEW PROVIDE OUTREACH AND
RESOURCES TO FOOD HASN'T
KRISTIN'S MOST IMPORTANTLY A
FULLY FUNDED COORDINATOR WITH
CULTURAL COMPETENCY AND
UNDERSTANDING FOR THE NEED OF
SUCH AN UNDERSERVED POPULATION
THIS IS WHY I AM ASKING FOR
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE THAT
REFLECT PROVISIONS OF ASSEMBLY.
BILL SEVENTY SEVEN FIVE THANK
YOU. AND WHY ONE HUNDRED TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE COULD HAVE
BEEN MR CHAIRMAN BOND SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESTORATION OF
THE TWO HUNDRED NINETY NINE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLAR CUT
FROM LAST YEAR WE BELIEVE THOSE
RESOURCES NEED TO BE USED TO
RESTORE FACULTY POSITIONS AND
COURSES THAT WERE CUT. SECONDLY
WE SUPPORT- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
BASED ON MEDITATION TO SUPPORT
STATUTES OPERATIONAL COSTS AND
I WANT TO STRESS THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH YOU KNOW THAT
WELL MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE- FOR ALL STUDENTS BUT-
SPECIFICALLY FOR HIGHER ED
STUDENTS- WE DO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS ON
OUR CAMPUSES. BUT WE BELIEVE
THE DOLLARS SHOULD BE TO HIRE
MORE FULL TIME TENURE TRACK
CULTURALLY COMPETENT FACULTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. R. ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOE
EVAN SMITH I AM AN ANIMAL
WELFARE IN SHELTER PROFESSIONAL
DOCTOR COUNTY I AM ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
ANIMAL SHELTERS CALIFORNIA
SHELTERS PROVIDE CRUCIAL
SUPPORT FOR PET OWNERS AND
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THE HUMAN
ANIMAL BOND IN TO SAVE ANIMALS
LIVES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY
THREE ARE OPEN. YES WE CAN.
BERMAN HAS BEEN THE NORM
STUDENTS AN INDUSTRY TO CALL
THE CHAIR AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO
ADDRESS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS- ONE OF THE
STUDENTS WHO WAS HOMELESS WHO
NEEDED HELP AND- IS REALLY
MAKES A DIFFERENCE FOR
STUDENTS- HOLLOW GROUP IN THIS
MORNING AND BILL HANDLED FOR A
NATIONAL DATABASE OFFICES. IT'S
A BIG MISTAKE- PEOPLE WHO WORK
AT THE WITH THE UNDERSTAND THE
COMMUNITY THEY SERVE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE REAL NEEDS
OF STUDENTS ARE ALSO ASKING
THESE MONIES TO TWENTY FOUR-
COMMUNICATOR BASICALLY ITS
GOING THERE AND HAD A SPACE FOR
STUDENTS WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY GO IN THERE AND KIND
OF CLEAN THE BASIC NEED
RESOURCES. THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU. THANK AND LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MCCARTY BUCKLEY
MANY OF GET SOME TRUST LOS WE
APPRECIATE IT DURING- TO DISH
WITH WITH ME FIVE AND I'LL KEEP
MY COMMON TO BE OF THE IN BOTH
SYSTEM- PURSUIT. CHANNEL CALLED
BIGGEST WITH ONE MINUTE LEFT IN
A BROADER MORE AT PLAN SYSTEM
AS OUTLINED IN THE TOP LEFT AND
MARK. AT FIRST GLANCE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AND INVEST IN THIS
FRAMEWORK AND WHICH WOULD LOSE
ACCESS BARRIERS AND STREAMLINE
ABOUT FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
FURTHERMORE. MARKET VIEW THAT
IN ORDER FOR ANY STUDENTS TAP
INTO WHATEVER FINANCIAL SYSTEM
WE HAVE WE NEED TO APPLY THE
FOKKER THE CALIFORNIA DREAM-
THEREFORE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE L. YOU HAVE SENIORS FILL
OUT THE ORMS OF DATA ANALYZE.
WHAT TOPIC. FIVE SECONDS- WE
ARE YOU- THE COST FOR ALL GOING
TO GIVE. INCREASE FOR. PROGRAMS
HELP ON HIS. AND POP.
ESPECIALLY AMONG KIDS. ENGLISH
LEARNERS BUT GENERATION TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL.
HI NAME'S ALAN NILE I THE FIGHT
SHE OF THE GOVERNMENT OF
COMMITTEE USED SINCE NATION. I
TO STRONGLY ACT THE NEED TIGER
MODERN. WE URGE ASSEMBLY THE
BOWS IN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT BILLION SECURING
FUNDING FOR CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION IN THE STATE
<c.green>UDGET. I DON'T CLOSER TO HIS</c>
FAMILY TO FUND TWENTY THREE
MILLION ONGOING ISSUE SINCE
THEY HAVE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
THE TWENTY MILLION ONGOING
INVESTMENT IS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
SYSTEM IMPACTED AND FOSTER.
YOUTH THE UC THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WILL WIND ONE SIXTEEN
EUROPE PLEASE COLLECT.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU
WITH YOUR W. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR YOU IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER I'M SPEAKING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING ITEM. DIDN'T
WORKERS BUT EVERY YOU SEE A
RENT BURDEN TO SPENDING AN
AVERAGE OF 3860% OF INCOME ON
HOUSING WE SUPPORT THE STATE
PROVIDING DIRECT FUNDING CAN
YOU SPEAK TO EXPAND AFFORDABLE
CAMPUS HOUSING HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE THE STATE SHOULD TAKE
STEPS TO MAINTAIN- YOU SEE
AFFORDABILITY NOW SO WE SUPPORT
AND JUST IN THE CURRENT PLAN.
TO FREEZE RENT INCREASES FOR
HOUSING AND TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDS ARE USED TO RELIEVE RENT
BURDEN FACING ALL STUDENTS. AND
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE. ONE
SEVENTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH CRUZ AND I
AM A SOPHOMORE AT VENTURA
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CALLING TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR THE THIRTY MILLION ON GOING
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
COMPANY'S BUDGET. FOR BASIC
NEEDS CENTERS AND BASICALLY
QUITE A. THE IMPLEMENTATION
WOULD HELP A LOT OF STUDENTS
JUST LIKE ME FIND EQUITY IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT CAN OFTEN FEEL
PRECARIOUS. THANK YOU. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRIS BURNS
AND I'M A CULTURE THERE I THANK
YOU FOR CALLING I HAVE
EXPERIENCE ALMOST
INSTANTANEOUSLY KERRY AND I HAD
A MAJOR EFFECT ON MY ABILITY TO
FINISH COLLEGE ARE YOU EXPECT
MY SUPPORT FOR THE THIRTY
MILLION INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECT.
COLLEGE STUDENT. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION
LANGUAGE REFLECT THE LANGUAGE
IN EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN FIVE SURE
NOT EVERY CAMPAIGN HAS
BASICALLY SAID I WANT TO. ASK
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE ME
WHO NEED EXTRA HELP AND SUPPORT.
TO GET TO HIGHER EDUCATION
THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WAS MUTED-
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD FIFTY OKAY ON THE
CARD- HI MY NAME IS JASMINE- I
GOT A CALL FROM MY COLLEGE AND
I'M GOING TO BE THE INCOMING BY
FRIDAY BUT THIS. ON BEHALF OF
THE INCENTIVE FOR CALCULATING
COLLEGES MEET THE CORE OF WHAT
ALL THIS IS OVER AND THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET AND URGED
THE LEGISLATURE TO THE DOG
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN FIVE AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE BERRY
THIRTY MILLION ONGOING BASC
NEED FUNDING. AND ALSO- THE
DOCTRINE OF CALGARY- EQUITY
FRAMEWORK FOR- EVEN. IN THE-
SYSTEM THANK YOU. M. LINE
THIRTY SO IF YOU PLEASE- RE
QUEUE UP. DISCOID HIT RE Q.
THIRTY SEVEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY
THEY DID TAKE THEMSELVES OUT OF
Q. AND- MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. WELL WE
GOT THIRTY SEVEN JUST. RE
OPENED PLEASE GO AHEAD THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU HI
MY NAME IS ALREADY A GOOD MANY
BIRDS THAT EAT YES OUT AND HELP-
BUT POLITICS ARE ALSO SERVE AS
THE FACULTY UNION PRESIDENT
THERE. I FULLY SUPPORT THE
REQUEST THAT SCHEDULE ONE ITEM.
687-010-1100 THE INCREASE BY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION AND ESL
PROGRAM PROVIDED FOR YES DOCU
THEN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
OUTSIDE THE LEGISLATURE EXTEND
THE HOLD HARMLESS AND
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO PROVIDE
STABILITY. AND ALSO INCREASE
THE CALL UP OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THAT IS NUMBER 1%
TO MATCH COLORS IN K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS THE AS YOU AND THEY USE
THE AS WELL AS RMOTE
CONTINGENCIES. I URGE STRONGLY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ELIMINATE
PROBLEM RIGHT. PLEASE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND WE'VE HAVE
ANOTHER PART FIGURE ONCE ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME
IS RICHARD CORTEZ DYNAMIC
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNSELOR AND
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CS
AT THE FIFTEEN MEMBER I WANT TO
SUPPORT EXTENDING THE HOLD
HARMLESS AND WE'VE GONE THROUGH
A MAJOR TRANSITION EMOTIONALLY-
AS WELL AS PHYSICALLY WITH WITH
WITH ALL THE IF YOU HAVE TO DO
TO SAVE OUR BUDGET. IN
RETIREMENT BENEFIT A LOT THE
LOT OF FACULTY A LOT A LOT OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS AND WILL BE AVAILABLE
AT THAT BACK WITH YOU TO
ADDRESS THEM AND THEN THE END
OF WASTEFUL EXPENSIVE PROGRESS
OF HOW GREAT. ONE POSITIVE
THING ABOUT CODING IS A LOT OF
FACTORS A LOT MORE CONFIDENT
THAT DELIVERING ONLINE G. AS
WELL AS THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY
COULD HAVE GONE UP BECAUSE OF
ALL THE T. TWENTY WC THAT'S
REALLY THE ONLY ACCOUNT RIGHT
ABOVE THE FIFTY SIX CHANGE.
WHEREVER CAN LEVERAGE IS THAT
MORE THAN EVER AND SO- I
SUPPORT ANYWAY WHAT SPENT. ON
CALVARY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH WE HAVE. NO MORE PART T
Q. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE PART. WE HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR- SOME OF THE ISUES WERE.
YOU KNOW ALREADY FUNDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S ME RIGHT. BY SO I
THINK WE'RE SET SO THE OTHERS
WERE STILL DELIBERATING- BUT
EITHER WAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND WITH THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN.